Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier vor dem Salon, möchten euch ein Jahresende-Angebot an klugen Gedanken geben. Mit dem Buch sind wir heute sehr gut bedient, glaube ich. Spektakulär.
Oder? Es hilft, wenn man Statistiken lesen kann.
Ja, bilanzieren ist nicht verkehrt. Und auch der ein oder andere Gedanke, der sich bei mir so verfestigt hat, aus See- und Sprechgewohnheit, ist vielleicht noch mal zu überprüfen.
Oh, ja, also man wird wirklich geschult in einem Denken, dass man viel zu wenig sonst leistet oder auch geleistet bekommt. Das ist einfach unglaublich, wenn wir einen Ökonomen haben, also Branko Milanović, der eigentlich Experte für globale Einkommensungleichheit ist, aber von dort ausgehend dann sich fragt, wie verändert sich die Welt geopolitisch? Er hat die richtigen Zahlen dann zur Hand und hat jetzt nicht solche, wie in Deutschland beliebten Spiele, ja, was will der Putin da und was möchte Trump dort machen? Er schaut einfach auf die ganz großen Zahlen und die großen Veränderungen der letzten Jahrzehnte. Es ist so unglaublich, was dann plötzlich zutage tritt und dieses ganze psychologische Wühlen in ist der Xi vielleicht eher so oder so, spielt gar keine Rolle mehr.
Ja, am Ende assortiert sie nicht ganz aus, aber tut sie einfach alle in einen Topf. Xi, Putin, Trump und es ergibt dann auch Sinn, wenn man das liest. Also seid gespannt auf den.
Und sagt aber auch, die anderen sind im Prinzip auch so angedockt an diese ganze Entwicklung. Er fragt doch wirklich bei all der Fokussierung auf die großen Leute, die Geschichte machen, inwieweit sind die eigentlich determiniert. Und diese Determination, die führt er mit Zahlen vor, wie ich das so noch nicht gesehen habe.
Genau, er lädt auch wirklich ein zu Gedankenexperimenten. Wir haben jetzt Merkel immer unter dem 16 Jahre Stillstand, Fähnchen in den Wind hängen und so weiter. Nur vielleicht ist es einfach der Zeit geschuldet gewesen. Und Merkel heute wäre vielleicht die Herausforderung gewesen, ich muss mal an dieses Live-Leute-Interview denken, wo irgendwelche Leute auf die Idee kommen, können wir schicken, mal das junge Internetpack so zum Interview. Und sie pariert das dann alles so rechts und links, dass sie dann am Ende auch sagt, ja, so ein paar Fragen hätten schon kommen können. Also ein paar Herausforderungen wären schon möglich gewesen. Vielleicht wäre Merz einfach der Kanzler gewesen, für diese 16 Jahre. Wegverwalten, Partys veranstalten, wie auch immer, ein bisschen Bereicherung. Und jetzt bräuchten wir eigentlich so jemanden wie Merkel, der mal so ganz nüchtern in die Sachen einfach. Also wie auch immer, dieses Buch ist sehr gut für sowas. Gut, worüber wir gleich noch anders lesen und so weiter, sagen wir, vorher gucken wir Clips, wir hören Clips. Du fragtest mich, ob ich noch was hätte, was man heute spielen könnte. Ich sagte, nichts drängt sich auf. Dann sagtest du, du hast aber auch nichts. Also habe ich gesagt, na dann, Gabor Steingart bei Paul Ronzheimer.
Ja, Gabor Steingart, früher Chefredakteur des Handelsplatz, jetzt auf einem Dampfer mit Springer an Bord unterwegs, um wieder Vernunft in Wirtschaft und Politik zu bringen. Sein Morning Briefing ist unglaublich beliebt, seine Podcasts auch. Und er hat wieder mal ein Buch geschrieben, dass davon handelt, dass Deutschland den Bach runtergeht. Und in gewisser Weise haben wir ja auch schon diese These mal bestätigt. Also die Rezession ist da und sie darf nicht geleugnet werden. Aber Gabor Steingart hat da einen ganz anderen Ansatz, woran es denn liegt. Und er glaubt jetzt alles erklären zu können. Ich finde auch wunderbar, dass Ronzheimer ihn so ankündigt, als hätte er da einen der versiertesten Gesprächspartner in Sachen deutsche Wirtschaftspolitik.
Niemand kennt so viele wie Gabor Steingart. Und das ist ja das Auskunftsersuchen, was man sich einholt. Wer kennt die Chefs? Ja. Und dann ist ja alles, er erkennt die Chefs. Okay, dann ist alles gut. Ist ja auch ein bisschen März-Erfolgsrezept. Wir haben das letzte Mal Ferdinand von Schirach-Clips, auch von Ronzheimer gehört. Ferdinand von Schirach, möchte ich noch mal in Erinnerung rufen, ist aufgefallen durch eine Idee zu sagen, Kanzler bitte sieben Jahre und drei politische Freischüsse, Gesetze, die einfach jahrelang gelten, einfach weil der Kanzler das wollte. Und jetzt könnten wir sagen, wow, das ist so extrem. Das ist eine Abkehr vom Parlamentarismus. Das ist nicht das, was wir wollen. Oder aber man könnte sagen, wow, das ist ja ein ganz zurückhaltender, aber mutiger Vorschlag, den Deutschland jetzt braucht. Und dann im Hinterkopf die nächste Frage, wie würde das klingen, wenn man das formuliert hätte, ohne dass man noch mal darauf verweist, dass man ja Schirach heißt? Und das hören wir jetzt bei Gaber Steingart. Ich möchte es antisern. Wie kommt so eine Idee rüber, wenn man keine Rücksicht auf eigene Familienverantwortung, Holocaust, mit Hitler bekannt und was auch immer haben muss? Also wir fangen aber an bei Bildung. Wir lesen nachher Stellen von Milanović, bei denen Bildung noch mal thematisiert wird, auf eine Art und Weise, wie wir sagen, vielleicht sollte man es doch nicht immer so zur Seite schieben.
Es gibt da eine irre Zahl. Da geht es einmal um 10 Millionen Dollar Unterschied. 10 Millionen Dollar Unterschied Bildung.
Ich werde das nachher auch mit meinem Familienbuch mal verknüpfen. Ich nenne ja da auch Zahlen. Nur er nennt keine Zahlen, die er sich wünscht, sondern Zahlen von Geldern, die wirklich fließen. Ja. Pro Kopf, Kind.
10 Millionen Dollar.
So, also die Bildung.
Wir sind auf einem falschen System. Ja, die Politiker kümmern sich um Bildung, aber sie hat keinen Zweck, diese Bildung. Sie hat keinen ökonomischen Zweck. Deutschland steigt auch ab, weil andere sich an einen ökonomischen Zweck gegeben haben und haben gesagt, vor der Fabrik kommt, ach was denn, die Bildung. Das ist ja der Weg, der Weg zu allem, was danach kommt. Und wenn die Bildung auf dem falschen Ding ist, dann haben wir unfassbar viele Geisteswissenschaftler und keine Erfindungen.
Das ist das Problem. Wir haben nur noch Geisteswissenschaftler, die alle nicht mehr arbeiten können.
Die Bildung ist auf dem falschen Dings.
Ja.
Okay, das beiten wir mal alles im Hinterkopf. Wir bauen jetzt hier langsam das Puzzle zusammen, wie er sich Deutschland und die Zukunft vorstellt.
Economy first war kein Slogan, sondern das war die gelebte Praxis aller Haushalte. Es wurde einfach gearbeitet. Freizeit wurde als Belohnung von Arbeit gesehen und nicht als Ersatz. Heute ist für viele Freizeit der Ersatz für Arbeit.
Die Freizeit als Ersatz für Arbeit, Erholung, wie auch immer. Also er sagt, wir sollen mehr Bildung machen. Ist Bildung aber schon Arbeit?
Das ist die Frage.
Also er möchte jetzt, dass wir mehr arbeiten.
Und instrumentelle Bildung, die also nur darauf ausgelegt ist, kann ich damit das BEP steigern.
Also er möchte, dass wir klüger arbeiten und das schaffen, indem wir besser ausgebildet sind. Das passt aber nicht ganz zusammen bei ihm.
Was schätzt du, wie viel Arbeitszeit ein Akademiker, männlich, in seinem Leben, also wie viel Zeit seines Lebens er am Arbeitsplatz verbringt, schätzt du?
So jetzt hören wir, dass Ronz einmal diese Frage erst nicht versteht, was auch bedeutet, hier saßen wieder Leute zusammen, die ein Sachbuch konzipiert haben, die meinten, wir brauchen irgendwie eine harte Zahl, irgendwas ganz Imposantes. Ja, Gabor, aber das ist ganz schwierig zu argumentieren. Es macht auch gar keinen Sinn. Es ist nicht ohne Grund, dass wir diese Zahl so noch nie gehört haben. Sie ist vielleicht ein bisschen doof, aber Gabor, reite drauf rum.
Wir haben das für das Buch ausgerechnet. Schlaf und alles zählt jetzt mit dazu oder musst du abreden?
Wir sagen pro Woche.
Nein, für dein Leben.
Ich bin schlecht, Mathe ist schon immer gewesen, Gabor.
Einfach nur ein Gefühl. Das ist ja ein Gefühl. Wie viel deines Lebens? Die Kindheit schon mal nicht, Rente schon mal nicht, Wochenende schon mal nicht.
Ein Drittel meines Lebens?
Zehn Prozent.
Was ist das für eine Zahl?
Das ist eine Zahl, wie man könnte auch das Durchschnittsgewicht ausrechnen. Können alle Arbeiter oder so. Das ist völlig irrsinnig.
Also ich sehe ja das jetzt immer. Sagen wir mal, wir lesen es jetzt möglichst konstruktiv. Wie viel Lebenszeit verbringen wir mit Arbeit? Erwerbsarbeit? Ich würde jetzt sagen, die Definition ist für jemand anderen nicht für uns selbst. Das ist ja so die unausgesprochene Wahrheit da drin. 10 Prozent. Ich mache ja häufiger diese Pointe, wer mehr bib will, könnte auch abseits des Kalendereffekts darauf setzen, dass vielleicht die Bahn pünktlich kommt. Dann fallen schon mal ein paar Reisetage, die eingeplant werden, müssen raus. Also da würde ich jetzt sagen, ja, lass uns doch mal jede Lebenszeit durchrechnen. Also dass man nicht nur arbeitet, sondern auch den ganzen anderen Kram. Wir werden mal feststellen, wie wenig eigentlich so übrig bleibt. Also im Heck lünschen dieses eine Leben.
Genau, also Handwerker könnten in NRW sicherlich pro Tag einen Auftrag mehr annehmen, wenn sie nicht laufend im Stau stünden. Und ich könnte auch sehr viel mehr machen, wenn ich nicht jetzt wie vergangene Woche drei Mal hintereinander knapp zwei Stunden Verspätung gehabt hätte.
Genau, also einfach mal solche Sachen dann wirklich durchbilanzieren.
Wir haben die Kindheit sehr lang gemacht mit der Bildung.
Das ist das, was du gerade wolltest, dass wir gute Bildung machen.
Aber bitte nur instrumentelle Bildung. Das heißt aber auch, alle, die jetzt nicht gebraucht werden in der akademischen Kaste oder für irgendwelche Facharbeiten, wo man ein Studium benötigt, die sollen möglichst ganz früh wieder arbeiten. Also könnte man nicht sagen, warum, also er traut sich das natürlich nicht zu sagen, aber er könnte eigentlich sagen, könnte man nicht auch einfache Tätigkeiten ab dem 12. Lebensjahr machen.
Genau.
Das wäre nämlich dann die Idee und sie beglückwünschen sich ja noch gegenseitig dabei, den Clip hast du jetzt nicht, wie die sie als High-Performer bestimmt bei 15 Prozent sind mit dem Arbeiten. Dabei sind sie ja überhaupt nicht produktiv, also wir in dem Sinne auch nicht, wir nehmen Podcasts auf, aber sie tun ja gar nichts für dieses BIP, wo sie die ganze Zeit von reden im Sinne von Industriearbeit oder so. Das ist ja alles nicht da.
Genau, da kommen wir eh gleich drauf nochmal.
Sie haben ja ihr Leben auch nur mit Schwätzen verbracht.
Genau, was ist die Definition von Arbeit? Also befördern und bewirten und zwar auf der passiven Seite, dass man das erfährt als Komfort ist keine Arbeit. Das muss man ganz deutlich sagen. Ich sehe sehr viele Bundespolitiker, bei denen immer rumgejammert wird, wie voll ihr Terminkalender ist, aber ehrlich gesagt ist es deren Hobby. Markus Söder hat 400 Millionen auf dem Konto, der geht doch nicht morgens zur Erwerbsarbeit, sondern das ist doch ein ganz klares Hobby und das Lustprinzip für sein Ego, dass da einfach ausgelebt wird. Und zwar ein ganzes Leben lang.
Ja, ja, ja.
100 Empfänge pro Woche, das ist einfach toll. Immer wieder der König und es gibt Applaus.
Diese anstrengende Arbeit, dass der Saal bereitet wird, das Licht eingeschaltet, das Buffet, damit der Herr Söder kommt und seine Arbeit dort verrichtet.
Ja.
Gut, wir hören noch mal diesen Einstieg, diesen Clip.
Lang gemacht mit der Bildung, das Renten.
Wir haben die Kindheit lang gemacht mit der Bildung.
Lang gemacht mit der Bildung. Das Rentending ist...
Also er rechnet jetzt diesen Teil, man studiert Physik und danach ein Ingenieur zu sein, ist für ihn einfach eine Kindheit.
Ja, die wir lang gemacht haben.
Die lang gemacht, die Kindheit.
Auch dauernd länger. Renten. Wir haben die Kindheit sehr lang gemacht mit der Bildung. Das Rentending ist auch...
Das Rentending...
.dauernd länger. Dazwischen haben wir verkürzt 30 Urlaubstage. Zwei Tage sind sowieso frei, Samstag, Sonntag. 19 Krankentage im Durchschnitt. 30 Urlaubstage, 19 Krankentage. Wir haben 52 Wochen, zwei Tage, 104 Tage sind Wochenende. Überleg mal, was von den 365 Tagen überhaupt bleibt.
Ja, 0,1 Prozent, Gabor. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Im Prinzip ist alles dicht draußen, keiner geht mehr arbeiten.
Er baut uns jetzt eine mit Haffa.
So, also ein solches Missverhältnis zwischen denen, die Wohlstand erzeugen und denen, die Wohlstand verkonsumieren. Ich unterscheide das in Kern und Kruste, produktive Kern eines Landes. Und auf der Kruste sitzen die Rentner, die Bürgergeldempfänger, die Kinder, auch Hausbrauen. Alle, die Wohlstand von anderen erzeugt konsumieren und andere, die ihn produzieren, sitzen im Kern.
Kruste und Kern.
Ganz einfach.
Muss man das noch kommentieren?
Unser realisiertester Wirtschaftsjournalist.
Dann ein Wort zur Bürokratie.
Also ich glaube, die Unternehmer und Unternehmerinnen würden gerne richtig loslegen. Die müssen entfesselt werden. Die haben keinen Bock, einfach Zettel auszufüllen für die Bürokratie.
Ja, die müssen einfach alle entfesselt werden. Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, sagt er jetzt.
Also der Staat macht es denen schwer. Ich glaube, die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, glaube ich.
Wir wissen ja, wie die Reallöhne sich entwickelt haben. Komischerweise hatten wir alle Lust auf Wohlstand, aber es ist nicht angekommen.
Er hat auch gerade selber definiert, wie er sich das vorstellt. Urlaubstage weg, Lebensarbeitszeit hoch. Wo genau passt jetzt hier die Wohlstandsdefinition ein?
Du kannst dann sagen, mit nur noch 15 Urlaubstagen und einem Renteneintrittsalter von 75 Jahren, aber unser BIP ist richtig nach oben gegangen. Ich habe zwar davon nichts abbekommen, aber ich habe dem BIP alles gegeben, was ich habe.
Die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand. Wessen Wohlstand?
Genau, das ist der Wohlstand derer, die sich Arbeitskraft kaufen können. Und diese Arbeitskräfte sollen bitte jetzt länger arbeiten. Das ist wirklich kapitalistische Propaganda in Reihenform.
Das ist 1850.
Das ist ja so von Marx und Engels in der Analyse abgeschrieben, aber dann als Gebrauchsanweisung gewendet, dass man es gar nicht fassen kann.
Das ist nämlich mein Punkt. Das sind im Grunde Marxisten nur auf der falschen Seite und sie haben es nicht gelesen. Aber die Fremdzuschreibung, wie schon bei Linnemann, wenn man einfach überall nur noch Reservaarmee sieht und so und in diesem Begriff Struktur denkt, ist man einfachen Marxist. Das muss man ihm schon nur halt nicht in diesem…
Naja, beziehungsweise es bestätigt sich, wie einmal mehr des Marx richtig lag.
Gabo Steingart ist sehr klug, aber die SPD, dafür reicht sie nicht, um das zu verstehen.
Gerhard Schröder, die haben sich Gedanken gemacht, wie kriege ich das da unten ein bisschen heißer im Kern, dass das Land Wohlstand hat. Das ist mir unverständlich tatsächlich, weil die Partei wird ja dafür gar nicht belohnt. Sie schrumpft die ganze Zeit. Also mit dem Kern, wo die Facharbeiter ja zu Hause sind, also ihre Wähler. Diese Kernschrumpfung ist eine Schrumpfung auch der SPD.
Diese Facharbeiter hat die SPD mit der Agenda 2010 geschwächt, deshalb, weil die Tarifbindung aufgehoben wurde, weil man jetzt an den Werkbänken der Facharbeiter Leute hat, die von irgendwelchen Zeitarbeitsfirmen da kommen und zu sehr viel schlechteren Bedingungen dort sind, als die Facharbeiter, die noch die alten Verträge haben. Die SPD hat genau diesen Kern zerstört.
Man könnte auch im Milanovićen Sinne kurz einfach nachfragen. Gabor, hast du dir den Strukturwandel der Wirtschaft angeschaut, die letzten 40 Jahre, als die SPD so verlor? Wo sind die Industriefacharbeiter, die damals noch Kohle, Fabrik und so weiter? Also es ist halt auch ein bisschen Zeitgeist.
Und deswegen verstehe ich gar nicht, wie dumm kann man sein, wie dumm kann man sein, das für klug zu halten, immer diese Kruste zu erweitern und anderen Menschen Energie abzuzapfen. Erbschaftscheuer, immer noch eine Idee, wie man irgend wem was neckt. Du weißt, wo der Spitzensteuersatz ist. Der ist mitten da, wo der Facharbeiter sein Gehalt hat. Der ist mitten da. Also wer kommt auf die Idee, seine Kernwähler dauernd zu massakrieren? Die Industriearbeiter werden auf diese Art gekillt in Deutschland.
Ihr kommt auf die Idee, weil ihr ja nicht die höheren Einkommen stärker besteuern wollt, weil ihr keine Erbschaftssteuer wollt, weil ihr keine Vermögensteuer wollt. Dann kann man nur dort in der arbeitenden Bevölkerung eine große Umverteilung vornehmen. Und tatsächlich trifft das dann die Leute, die, sagen wir, 70, 80.000 im Jahr verdienen, eigentlich am stärksten. Das ist aber genau die Klasse, die Eingabe auf Steingart nicht vertritt. Denn er vertritt ja die Kapitalseite, die sagt, also ich kann hier nichts mehr machen, ich brauche eher eine Steuersenkung. Mach das mal mit denen Leuten, die arbeiten gehen. Die sollen mal einen ordentlichen Steuersatz zahlen.
Also Hans Eichel mal eingeklammert hier. Aber das, was er beschreibt, ist eben auch Theo Weigel und Wolfgang Schäuble.
Ja, ganz klar.
Das hat jetzt so viel mit SPD gar nichts zu tun.
Aber gut.
Steingart findet Sozialstaat nicht ganz so gut.
Wenn ich das noch gerade anführen darf, das war ja so interessant, dass die CDU ja immer rumlief und sagte, wir müssen den Solidaritätszuschlag für alle streichen. Also da auch für die oberen zehn Einkommensprozent. Und das haben sie ja nicht gemacht. Warum können sie das nicht machen? Denn man kann darüber streiten, ob man das machen sollte oder nicht. Ich bin nicht dafür, aber selbst wenn man jetzt dafür wäre, muss man sich ja fragen, was geschieht dann? Wo kommt das Geld sonst her? Und da man sich genau nicht herantraut an das wirkliche Kapital, kann man in der Arbeitenbevölkerung selbst eine solche kleine Erleichterung für die ohnehin Gutverdienenden nicht durchsetzen. Man ist völlig gebunden. Man hat sich die Hände gebunden aufgrund von Austeritätspolitik und einer Steuerpolitik, die sagt, niemals werden wir die Reichen, niemals die Vermögen, niemals die Erbschaften stärker besteuern. Dann kann man innerhalb der Arbeiterschaft auch nicht mehr viel umverteilen.
Ist im Grunde ein Lockdown, der hier stattfindet?
Nur an den Posten in der Tat, da ist dir recht, wenn die Leute sagen, ich will eigentlich die Viertagewoche und ich möchte bei der Rente doch eher noch eine Schippe drauf. Wenn das die Mehrheitsmeinung ist, dann hat auch Friedrich Merz niemand eine Chance.
Also, Gabor, haben die Deutschen Bock auf Wohlstand oder haben sie Bock auf ganz viel Arbeit und eben keinen Wohlstand? Ich blicke noch nicht ganz durch.
Könnte dann vielleicht auch mal ein Moderator eine kluge Frage stellen?
Das wäre natürlich... Also, Rondsheimer ist nicht ganz so schlecht in dem Gespräch hinten raus, wenn es um die AfD geht, kommen wir gleich zu. Jetzt erstmal alles kürzen, ja.
Natürlich wollen die Leute nicht gerne in Rentenkürzungen.
Nee, die haben ja Bock auf Wohlstand. Klar haben die da keinen Bock auf Rentenkürzungen.
Eigentlich lief doch jetzt alles darauf hinaus, dass Gabor Steingart sagen würde, wir müssen unbedingt die Rente kürzen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Aber dann würde er sich wahrscheinlich mit seiner eigenen Hörerschaft anlegen und Leserschaft.
Das weiß ich nicht, weil es könnte sein, dass ihm Leute sagen, also wir haben Auswertungen unserer Zahlen gesehen, Rentner hören uns nicht. Es ist die arbeitende Bevölkerung, die morgens nicht viel Zeit hat und schnell zur Arbeit und sich dann nochmal kurz indoktriniert.
Aber eigentlich würde es jetzt auf eine Rentenkürzung hinauslaufen, ja an seiner Argumentation.
Ja, also das war unmissverständlich.
Natürlich wollen die Leute nicht gerne eine Rentenkürzung. Das wäre auch gar nicht meine Empfehlung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ach so, die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, aber eigentlich sollte man mal die Renten kürzen, aber das wäre auch gar nicht meine Empfehlung, aber das sollte man trotzdem machen. Ping-Pong.
Ökonom, ich weiß, dass die Renten im unteren Drittel und das sind Millionen schon jetzt nicht reichen. Also insofern Vorsicht sozusagen, nicht Erkenntnisse zu einer Ideologie verdichten und dann sagen, und jetzt die Kürzung für alle. Das ist es nicht. Insofern ist die Rente schon ein super diffiziles Thema.
So, und erst jetzt geht dieses Interview richtig los. Also die Rente ist ein ganz diffiziles Thema, die Deutschen haben Bock auf Wohlstand, aber hohe Renten können wir auf gar keinen Fall machen. Also sollte man irgendwie, aber das wäre jetzt nicht meine Empfehlung, aber März muss mal und so. Keine Ahnung. Jetzt kommt seine alternative Idee. Die ist so genial. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht heraus. Wir werden das gleich im Pi mal Daumen mal so durchrechnen, was das so insgesamt bedeutet.
Unser Umlagesystem, du zahlst für deine Eltern und unsere Kinder zahlen für uns, so es Kinder gibt. Und that's it, da wird nichts verzinst. Das Geld wird weiter gereicht, ich sage mal, wie einer afrikanischen Großfamilie von der Hand in den Mund. Und zwar die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts.
Also es ist ihm jetzt noch eingefallen, dass er das mal besser nicht auf die Gegenwart bezieht, nicht, dass er da noch was an...
Die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts. In welchem Geschichtsbuch muss ich nachlesen um etwas über die afrikanische Großfamilie des 19. Jahrhunderts? Also was ist das bitte für eine Empirie?
Aber das wollte sich jetzt mal schnell retten. Das war früher. Also nicht, dass ihr mir jetzt Rassismus hier unterstellen wollt.
Das ist des 19. Jahrhunderts. Afrika ist fortschrittlicher als wir.
Afrika des 19. Jahrhunderts. Die Großfamilie dort war fortschrittlicher als wir, weil wir haben einen Rentenumlage-System.
Also dieses Umlageverfahren Null. Das kann gar nichts werden. Bei Kinderlosigkeit verbreitet. Demografischer Faktor ist ein anderes Wort für Kinderlosigkeit.
Demografischer Faktor ist ein anderes Wort für Kinderlosigkeit.
So und deswegen muss man um, das System muss um. Am Kapitalmarkt gibt es acht Prozent jedes Jahr. Seit Gründung des DAX jedes Jahr. Es gibt mal einen DIP, dann sind es sechs, im nächsten zwölf. Acht Prozent ist die Durchschnittsrentität.
So, der DAX macht ja jedes Jahr acht Prozent. Also sollten wir das Geld, das wir jetzt in die Rentenkasse einzahlen, einfach dorthin bleiben. Das Problem ist, da ja das Umlagesystem zweifach verrechnet wird, also Einzahlung, Auszahlung, wo kommt dann das Geld für die Auszahlung her? Das haben wir dann nicht mehr. Das heißt, für die Jungen gehen wir jetzt in den DAX und für die Alten haben wir leider keinen Auszahlungsbetrag mehr. Dass wir für die Alten dann kein Geld mehr haben, blenden wir jetzt mal aus, weil das ist einfach bescheuert. Aber der DAX ist um 8 Prozent gewachsen die letzten Jahre. Ich bin mir nicht so ganz sicher, aber ich höre immer so Nachrichten, wie ein amerikanisches Unternehmen wie Nvidia oder so ist mehr wert als der ganze DAX. Das heißt, der DAX ist wahrscheinlich so knapp unterhalb 5 Billionen. Keine Ahnung. Man muss es jetzt gar nicht genau nehmen. Wir zahlen jedes Jahr 350 Milliarden Rente aus und 250 Milliarden ins Umlagesystem ein. Dann kommen ja 100 Milliarden Staatsgeld dazu, Bundesgeld. Das heißt, diese 250 Milliarden möchte er pro Jahr in den DAX zahlen. Also wer soll das Geld entgegennehmen? Sagen wir dann, alle vier Jahre sind die DAX-Konzerne einfach eine Billion mehr wert, weil wir ja jedes Jahr 250 Milliarden eingezahlt haben. Und das über 30 Jahre.
Also wir haben jetzt...
Die DAX-Konzerne sind jetzt einfach 10 Billionen Euro mehr wert. Weil wir das ja einzahlen, das Geld.
Ja, wir schaffen einfach Reichtum dadurch.
Ich bin ja kein Ökonom, sondern du, aber wie genau ist das? Also sollten wir dann feierliche Texte beim Wall Street Journal anmelden und sagen, ja, ganz wundersamerweise ist der DAX dreimal so viel, wert wie eure teuren Unternehmen. Ihr dachtet immer, das sei umgedreht, aber nein, denn ja.
Und dann bleibt natürlich auch diese enorme Rendite und könnte diese enorme Rendite vielleicht auch damit zusammenhängen, dass es den Arbeitern schon so schlecht geht, dass man die Löhne eben nicht erhöht hat, sondern tatsächlich die Profite steigern konnte. Nämlich dann steigert man ja die Aktienkurse. Aktienkurse sind ja noch nie gestiegen, weil man die Arbeiter besser bezahlt hat.
Also das sind ganz merkwürdige Fantasien, die man hier hat.
Man fragt sich auch, warum geht man dann überhaupt noch arbeiten? Können wir nicht einfach nur noch Börsianer alle sein?
Genau. Weil das größte Problem der Superreichen, das ist ja selten thematisiert, sie wissen nicht wohin mit dem Geld. Ja. Wenn jetzt Deutschland pro Jahr noch 250 Milliarden zusätzlich in diesen Markt der Asian-Orientierungslos geht, wird man dann in Immobilienfonds, weil die DAX-Konzerne nicht genug Volumen haben. Also wir machen eine Altersvorsorge, die dazu führt, dass die deutschen Städte, wenn man mal die Mietfläche einfach durchkalkuliert, pro Jahr um 250 Milliarden im Wert steigt. Das muss ja auch verrechnet werden. Ich verstehe, es ist einfach völlig absurd, solche Sachen.
Also es geht natürlich nur auf eine Weise, wenn man das wirklich mal auf das Inland denkt, dann können wir das mit einem ganz simplen Beispiel machen. Also ich kaufe mir eine Netflix-Aktie und dann sage ich toll, der Wert ist gestiegen, der Netflix-Aktie. Und dann schaue ich bei Netflix rein und bekomme dort angezeigt, ihr Abo ist jetzt fünf Euro teurer. Und da gibt es einen Zusammenhang. Und dann habe ich fünf Euro mehr zu zahlen für Netflix und habe fünf Euro mehr bei der Aktie. Und genauso wäre das natürlich bei Mieten. Die Mieten werden entsprechend die Konzerne dann noch mehr haben, werden die Mieten also steigern. Aber ich bekomme dann eine Rendite wieder raus. Also das führt zu nichts. Das einzige, was also geht und was natürlich dann immer die Länder da machen, die viel Erdöl haben und dann diese Fonds auflegen, man investiert irgendwo im Ausland und hofft, dass da so viel Wirtschaftswachstum ist, dass man davon dann was abschöpft. Aber es ist natürlich der Wunsch, dass andere arbeiten für einen.
Andere müssen das dann hinkriegen.
Ja und dass das nicht für die Gesamtgesellschaft möglich ist, zumal auch diese Rechnungen ja in dieser Weise nicht stimmen, wie ihr das dann einfach so sagt, wir gehen da mal alle rein.
Also wir stimmen einfach gar nichts. Also wir hören jetzt mal das Resultat aus dieser Überlegung, die er da anführt. Und wir überlegen mal gleichzeitig, was bedeutet das für die Kosten derjenigen, die plötzlich von diesem neuen Rentenregen den er da verspricht, profitieren?
Es gibt gar keine Alternative, Paul. Ich sage dir, es wird kommen. Nicht der Einzelne. Ich will nicht Lieschen Müller jetzt an die Börse schicken morgens.
Ja, das kann die ja gar nicht, weißt du.
Statt auf dem Wochenmarkt an die Börse. Funktioniert nicht. Aber ein Staatsfonds. Diese gigantische Umverteilungsmaschinerie der Rente, das Geld genommen, nicht 0,0 Verzinsung, sondern das an der Börse, 8 Prozent. Und dann wird tatsächlich, und das klingt jetzt unseriös und ist trotzdem wahr, jeder heute 25, 28-Jährige, wenn wir das machen würden, ist nachher Millionär.
So, wenn jeder Millionär ist und Wirtschaft hat immer ganz viel mit Relation zueinander zu tun, dann kostet auch deine Miete einfach eine Million Euro im Jahr. Sonst geht das gar nicht auf. Dann kann zwar jeder Vermieter von sich sagen, ich bin jetzt Milliardär, aber das nützt ja gar nichts.
Nein. Also er sagt die ganze Zeit, die Produktivität muss gesteigert werden. Und jetzt will er aber einfach nur so ein Rentiersystem haben, aus dem jeder jetzt was bezieht.
Das stimmt, wir sind ganz weit weg von Produktivität gerade.
Man könnte auch den Vorschlag machen, warum werden wir nicht eigentlich alle Vermieter und vermieten, ich werde dein Vermieter, du wirst mein Vermieter, dann können wir doch immer Geld hin und her tauschen, dann ist doch jeder reich. Ach nee, ist ja gar nicht.
Hat denn nicht irgendwer gesagt, wir können uns nicht alle nur noch die Haare schneiden?
Ja.
So, er ist natürlich jetzt so klug, dass er auch die Klugheit anderen gibt, und zwar nicht nur uns Podcast-Hörern.
Frau Merkel hat es ja versucht und ich beschreibe das auch in dem Buch. Ich hatte vor, weiß nicht, 2004 ein Buch geschrieben, Deutschland, der Abstieg eines Superstars. Sie war Oppositionsführerin. Auf den letzten Tagen, sie lud mich ein, sagte Steingart, ich will was verändern. Ich war beim Spiegel damals. Erzählen Sie mir, ich will das wissen. Und sie hat mitgeschrieben, wir haben anderthalb, zwei Stunden, sie wird Kanzlerin. Sie lädt mich wieder ein. Steingart, ich mein's ernst. Ich sollte fünf Leute mitbringen, fünf Kronzeugen, wie es gehen kann. Ich habe mitgebracht damals. Sie war gerade Kanzlerin.
Ist ja auch irgendwie erschreckend, dass Merkel sich überhaupt darauf einlässt, oder?
Ja, das auch. So, Merkel bittet dich als jungen Gaber Steingart, bitte bringen sie die Weisheit mit. Wen bringst du mit? Fünf Leute sollte sie ja mitbringen. Wir hören jetzt die Liste. Es ist wirklich...
Matthias Döpfner, der dich schon damals kannte und schätzte. Ich habe mitgebracht Bert Rührup vom Rate der Weisen. Ich habe einen Investmentbanker aus London, David Marge, mitgebracht. Rainer Neske aus dem Vorstand der Deutschen Bank, heute Chef der Landesbank Baden-Württemberg. Und noch jemand.
Rührup, Döpfner, ein Typ aus der City auf London und ein deutscher Bankvorstand.
Das ist doch ganz ausgewogen, denke ich.
Das ist wirklich. Aber sie hat ja dann nicht auf ihn gehört.
Ja, das muss man gerade in den Kontext setzen. Es gab die Agenda 2010 und dann wollte Merkel noch härter da rein. Sie wollte ja wirklich den Sozialstaat kurz und klein schlagen. Und da gab es ja dann auch Rebellionen aus der christlichen, aus der sozial-christlichen Warte da, aus der Union, vor allem auch aus der CSU. Da ist sie also böse mit hingefallen. Und dann hat sie das nicht mehr angefasst, das Thema. Und das wirft Steingardier bis heute vor.
Und wir wissen ja, Döpfner und so, wie verantwortungsvoll sie auch mit dem deutschen Wohlstand umgehen.
Ja.
Da wird einfach mal eine Milliarde hier so gar nicht verzollt an der Altersgrenze und an der Schenkungsgrenze. Sein Urteil heute über Merkel, wo sie doch nicht auf ihn hörte.
Angela Merkel ist eine intellektuelle, eine wohltemperierte, nachdenkliche Frau. Aber in dieser Phase der Geschichte wäre jemand, der Mut gehabt hätte, ich sage nicht tollkühn, aber doch in die Richtung, das was Gerhard Schröder eben riskiert hat. Oh, sie hat einfach nichts riskiert.
Ja. Sie hat es einfach nicht riskiert, den Leuten, die gerade erfahren haben, dass ihr Wohlstand jetzt doch nur noch so ein Jahr Arbeitslosigkeit aushält, denen auch noch zu sagen, dass es im Alter dann auch nichts gibt. Hat sie sich nicht getraut, wo die Deutschen auch so viel Bock auf Wohlstand haben. So, jetzt kommen wir zu diesem Schirach-Ding. Also Schirach sagt, ich wähle einen starken Kanzler, sieben Jahre, drei Freischuss-Gesetze. Aber ich sage es nur vorsichtig, weil mein Name ist Schirach. Gabriel Steingart heißt Steingart. Unverfänglich. Also richtig reinbuttern.
Du nennst in deinem Buch Die deutsche Verfassungskonstruktion einen, Zitat, deutschen Defekt und schreibst dazu, wir seien das wahrscheinlich langsamste Staatswesen der westlichen Welt, wenig sprunghaft, frei von Exzessen, gründlich in jeder Hinsicht, auch in der, dass wir den Weg nach unten seit Jahrzehnten unbeirrt weitergehen. Was genau ist dieser deutsche Defekt?
Ja, das ist der Antiführerstaat. Also nach Hitler haben die Alliierten, der Parlamentarische Rat, einen Staat geschaffen, der eine Prämisse hatte, nie wieder Krieg und nie wieder einen Führer.
Das ist jetzt genau das Thema von Stefan Kühl eigentlich, ne? Ja, also nur halt falsch verstanden.
Genau, genau falsch verstanden. Also die ganze Idee, dass Deutschland nach dem Krieg so ein einzigartiges Wirtschaftssachstum hingelegt hat, kam durch diese Bürokratie. Das einfach alle wussten, was sie jetzt zu tun haben. Und keiner über die Stränge schlug und sagte, aber das ist doch eine gute Idee, die ich gerade vorgeschlagen habe. Können sie einfach machen. Ne, wir gucken noch mal im Handbuch nach, ob das passt. Also Bürokratie hat uns nicht die Freiheit von Superreichen und Zampanos. Wir sind eben nicht als Zampano-Business aus dem Dritten Reich rausgekommen, sondern wir haben genau das Gegenteil versucht. Und das ist bis heute eigentlich weltweit bewundert.
Also die ganze Ingenieurskunst, die bewundert wird, beruht nur darauf, dass man sich an diese Regeln gehalten hat bzw. neue Regeln geschaffen hat. Aber das waren nicht irgendwelche Basteleien, wo man einfach geguckt hat, schauen wir mal, ob das Auto auch fährt. Sondern man hat versucht, so verlässlich wie möglich zu produzieren. Deshalb sind ja die deutschen Premium-Autos in der Welt so beliebt, weil sie diese enorme Verlässlichkeit haben. Das bringt natürlich eine gewisse Inflexibilität mit sich, aber das ist ja zugleich auch Garant dafür, dass diese Autos funktionieren.
Genau. Und eigentlich ist das Argument auch nicht schwer zu verstehen. Wenn die Bahn so fährt, wie es im Fahrplan steht, weil das die Regeln für alle sind, dann funktioniert es. Und wenn wir einen Fahrplan haben, aber keiner hält sich dran, dann funktioniert es halt nicht. Ja. So. Und wenn es daran liegt, dass man den Fahrplan gar nicht einhalten kann, selbst wenn man will, weil Geld fehlt, dann weiß man genau, wo man jetzt ansetzen müsste, eigentlich.
Bei Geld und nicht bei den Regeln. Genau.
Aber so wie der Schirach wird hier einfach, oder meint es wirklich ernst, er möchte jetzt wieder das Führerprinzip.
Dieser Anti-Führer-Staat, ich nenne das einen deutschen Defekt, das ist die Hitlerzeit, die wir mit uns mit schleppen sozusagen. Die Hitlerzeit verewigt sich in unseren Verwaltungsroutinen der Entschleunigung. Jeder darf klagen, wir sind superdemokratisch und alles.
Ja, die Deutschen haben Wohlstand, doch nicht. Demokratie, schöne, gute, nee. Es wird alles abgeräumt hier. Das sind wirklich, also diese, vielleicht sollte man es, kann jemand ein Sachbuch schreiben über diese Leute, also Schirach, Gaber Steingart, natürlich auch so ein bisschen Thomas Gottschalk, kann man so ein bisschen schreiben, warum wird der ausgelacht und die anderen nicht, also offene Frage. Man nennt es dann, also Titel ist Die Abräumer. Ja. Die einfach, die sehen den Tisch vor sich, ist auch reichlich gedeckt, drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft der Welt. Einmal abräumen, bitte. Alles weg, was hier irgendwie noch als, wir brauchen wieder den Führer. Dieses Rentensystem ganz schlecht, Bürokratie ganz schlecht, Demokratie ganz schlecht.
Führer? Super.
Das ist im Grunde T-Nord dieser alten Männer, ja. Es ist unglaublich.
Wurde er unverbewertet, Robert Habeck?
So, das ist witzig. Nachdem sie jetzt über den Führer, und wie toll das doch war, als wir noch einen Führerstaat hatten, das ist natürlich blöd, wenn du dir einen Führer wünschst und dann kommt es aber über demokratische Verfahren, so ein Robert Habeck ins Wirtschaftsministerium. Das kannst du natürlich als, ich kenne mich ja auch aus mit Wirtschaft, ich bin Gabriel Steingart, da musst du natürlich Worte elefanten.
Hattet Robert Habeck?
Naja, sag mal so, ich glaube, der ist ein fähiger Politiker und ein großer Denker sogar.
Ein Sozialwissenschaftler wahrscheinlich.
Auch einer, der gut formulieren kann, aber der hätte nicht auf diesen Job gehört.
Also Wirtschaftsminister war falsch.
Auf jeden Fall, weil er das nicht verstanden hat.
Also anders als die Reiche, anders als der Peter Altmaier. Robert Habeck hat es einfach nicht verstanden.
Wirtschaft, glaube ich, ist genau wie Tanzen. Also ich zum Beispiel.
Wirtschaft ist genau wie Tanzen. Ja, Herr Steingart.
Also ich zum Beispiel kann nicht tanzen. Und ich glaube, obwohl ich in der Tanzschule war. Kannst du tanzen, Paul?
Ich habe es mal in der Tanzschule versucht, aber nicht.
Liebe deutschen Podcaster, müsst ihr immer kokettieren? Auf die Frage hin, kannst du tanzen, Paul? Kann man nicht einmal sagen, ja, ich werde mich für einen sehr guten Tänzer. Ich bin vielleicht der Beste. Ich gehe da sehr gerne hin. Ich mache das regelmäßig. Warum immer diese Kokettierscheiße? Ach, Mathe, da waren wir alle schlecht und so. Das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Also falls ihr von uns kein Kokettieren hört, werft es uns nicht vor. Wir sind einfach nur normale Menschen.
Ich kann nicht wirklich tanzen, nein.
Man muss das im Blut auch haben, ein bisschen das Rhythmusgefühl.
Ich bin aus Friesland.
Also die reden gerade über Wirtschaftspolitik, ja.
Ich bin jetzt so gespannt, was das mit der Wirtschaft zu tun hat.
Das Rhythmusgefühl ist schwierig.
Ich bin aus Friesland, also schwierig.
Ja, ich bin Berliner, Kreuzberg, also keine Ahnung. Also wir sind frech, wir Kreuzberger, wir können nicht tanzen. Und in Norddeutschland vielleicht auch Schunkeln geht.
Schunkeln, ja.
Aber dieses Rhythmusgefühl für Wirtschaft fehlte ihm. Und das muss man merken. Wenn man nicht tanzen kann, dann muss man nicht der erste auf der Tanzfläche sein, wie John Travolta. Und wenn man das Rhythmusgefühl für Wirtschaft nicht hat, dann sollte man diese Zone meinen.
Jetzt haben wir endlich die alles erklärende Argumentation bekommen, warum Habeck nicht erfolgreich war. Er hatte das Rhythmusgefühl nicht. Ja, wer hätte das gedacht? Wir haben immer in den Zahlen gesucht, überlegt, war diese Sache mit Intel das Richtige? Hätte man stärker auf Infrastruktur gehen müssen? Nein, es lag einfach nur am Rhythmusgefühl. Peter Altmaier ist ein großer Tänzer.
Er konnte Supertanzen.
Und der hat ein Rhythmusgefühl.
Das ist so schräg, das kann man sich alles gar nicht vorstellen. Klar, da sitzen jetzt beide, die erklären uns über die Welt. Das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass sie alles wissen.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine Elitendämmerung, die wir jetzt hier seit ein paar Monaten begleiten? Da ist ja nichts mehr da. Ich wundere mich ja, wenn ich das hier höre und weiß, dass die Leute auf die gehört wird und die sich mit den wichtigen treffen. Mich wundert ja, dass da draußen überhaupt irgendwas noch funktioniert. Also das scheint ja aufgrund der Bürokratie, aufgrund des Regelwerks alles so gut gefestigt zu sein, dass selbst diese Hainis das nicht zerstören können so einfach. Also ein Glück, man muss eigentlich jetzt mittlerweile froh sein, um jede bürokratische Hürde, weil die alles einhegt, was die da vorhaben.
Ich stelle mir vor, Gabor Steinger würde dich aus dem Cockpit begrüßen und sagen, wir fliegen jetzt hier nach Hamburg.
Ja, würde ich sofort freiwillig rausspringen.
Eine Schule leiten, das würde alles überhaupt gar nicht funktionieren. Also wir haben Elitendämmerung, das sind Abräumer hier. Das ist, man kann es sich alles, meine These ist ja immer, mir ist es früher aufgefallen, wenn Leute Rezension schreiben mussten, zu Büchern oder so und sie haben es nicht ganz verstanden oder hatten auch nicht Lust, das Ganze zu Ende zu lesen. Dann war das Urteil einfach immer so negativ, um sich so selbst behauptend noch zu dem Text zu verhalten und sich nicht geschlagen zu geben. Dann hat man irgendeine Kritik erfunden einfach und so ist das hier auch. Diese Leute haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Wir hören gleich noch ganz schlimme Zitate von Gaberstein Gott über Friedrich Merz. Die haben keine Ahnung von nichts. Das erinnert mich an diese Medienleute, die wohl mal so eine ganze Republik ausraste, dass man als Headliner noch irgendso einen Intendanten da hat. Und dann sitzen hundert Leute im Publikum, die alle jetzt gerade ein YouTube-Video hochladen oder irgendwas auf Instagram machen oder so. Und so nach zehn Minuten dämmert denen der Typ auf der Bühne, der uns gerade das Mediensystem erklärt, hat noch niemals das YouTube-Upload-Formular gesehen. Der weiß nicht, wie Instagram funktioniert. Der hat keine Ahnung von nichts. Der sitzt nur in irgendwelchen Redaktionskonferenzen immer rum und wirft am Ende noch mal so eine alles entscheidende Idee, bei der man sich aber vorher nicht einmüscht, die Diskussion. Ich entscheide hier, weil ich der Chef bin. Punkt. Wir färben rot. Also wir haben es ja wirklich mit Leuten zu tun, die keine Ahnung haben. Weshalb es besonders witzig ist, solche kleinen Snippets wie dieses hier zu hören.
Also erstmal muss sich jeder selber prüfen, bevor man sich für Dinge bewirbt. Also das glauben nur Politiker, dass sie alles können. Auf die Idee würden wir doch gar nicht kommen.
Glaubst du, dass sie das wirklich glauben?
Nee, auf die Idee würdet ihr nicht kommen. Ihr seid so bescheiden und demütig gegenüber jedem Sachverstand und gegenüber jedem Gegenstand.
Gabor Steingart würde doch in jede Karamioska-Sendung gehen, egal zu welchem Thema. Der würde doch niemals sagen, sorry, dazu habe ich keine Ahnung. Der würde doch Krebsforschung mit drei Professoren dort diskutieren.
Ja, der ist ja klar, was der sagt. Das Problem ist natürlich die allgemeine Krankenversicherung.
Ja, absolut. Also, das große Wettern hier geht weiter. Der Beamtenstaat, das geht ja gar nicht. Wer braucht schon einen Staat? Naja, so einen kleinen Teilbereich hat er jetzt doch noch markiert.
Ein Staat, der uns hilft, beim Gründen hilft, der bei der Öffnung einer Kindertagesstätte hilft, der dabei hilft, dass Menschen sich entfalten können, das tut unser Staat auf gar keinen Fall. Im besten Falle, und da sind viele wohlmeidende Menschen, aber unser System ist anders gegründet und versteht sich auch anders. Ich glaube, die Entfesselung ist nicht ein paar Gesetze abschaffen, Bürokratie, es ist den Beamtenstaat abschaffen. Also ich gehe schon radikaler an, auf Kernbereiche wie den Ausweisdrucken und auch an der Grenze und so weiter. Ich will an der Grenze keine private Armee stehen sehen.
Also so ein bisschen militär, eigentlich ein Nachtwächterstaat.
Genau, und ein Bundesdrucker.
Ein Nachtwächterstaat, der passt auf, dass das Eigentum morgen noch da ist.
Im Grunde ist das der Nachtwächterstaat. Das war's. Aber wir haben doch gerade so viele Beamten.
Wenn diese Menschen in die Produktion gingen, in produktive Tätigkeiten, das sind ja alles auch Krustentierchen, die verzehren.
Die Beamten, die in den Laden am Laufen halten, sind alles Krustentierchen....
auf ihren...
Also die Rente, ne? 350 Milliarden im Jahr zahlen wir an die alten Leute. Die Verwaltungsgebühr dafür liegt bei 0,8 Prozent oder so. Da sitzen ganz wenige Leute, die das einfach alles im Griff haben. Wir haben diese Woche ein Urteil gehabt vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, glaube ich, zum Thema Riester-Rente. Ja. Es gab einmal den Versuch zu sagen, wir machen es ein bisschen privatwirtschaftlich. 20 Jahre später entscheidet das Bundesverfassungsgericht, ja ja, das ist schon nicht korrekt, dass der Versicherungsgeber einfach im Nachhinein seinen Auszahlungsbetrag anpassen kann. Und der konkrete Rentenfaktor, der da strittig war, war, die Allianzversicherung hat jemandem 38 Euro als Einheitspreis zugesichert und am Ende gesagt, wir zahlen doch nur 30 aus. Wir kürzen das hier einfach mal von 38 auf 30 runter. Damit mussten sich also zum einen vorher in der Planung bei der Allianz sehr viele Juristen auch gegen innere moralische Widerstände sagen, okay, wir finden das falsch, also ich bin von meiner eigenen Arbeit nicht betroffen, müssen das planen. Danach müssen sich 20 Jahre Gerichte damit befassen, damit man mal sagt, liebe Leute, Rieser-Rente heißt, es lohnt sich nur, wenn du über 100 Jahre alt wirst. Es hat gar, also hier ist nichts mit, wir werden alle Millionäre und so.
Nein, nein, wir hätten es besser unter das Kopfkissen gelegt.
Also Carsten Maschmeyer wurde Milliardär, ist der Einzige, der davon profitiert hat. Alle anderen. Rechtsweg ist er offen, wie in der Rechtsstaat so. Ja. So, hier wurde also schon gegen die Rente gewettert, wo man sagt, nee, das ist schon ganz gut, wenn wir 350 Milliarden einfach von so ein paar tausend Leuten verwalten lassen, weil die kriegen das einfach hin, das sind Staatsbeamte, die machen das einfach. Statt dass wir kleinere Beträge zu viel größeren Nebenkosten, Rechtswege hier, Planung da, ein bisschen Lobbyismus und so weiter. Also das ganze Ding geht überhaupt gar nicht auf. Und jetzt will er diese wenigen Beamten, die die Sache noch gerade so über die Bühne bringen hier in Deutschland, ja plötzlich in diese Produktion stecken.
In produktive Tätigkeiten. Das sind ja alles auch Krustentierchen. Die verzehren ja auf ihren gut bezahlten Beamtenjobs das, was andere, der Stahlarbeiter, der Autoarbeiter, im besten Fall auch ein profitables Medienunternehmen erwirtschaftet hat.
Es ist mir jetzt noch kurz eingefallen, was ist eigentlich mit uns? Wir sind ja gar keine Stahlarbeiter. Profitables Medienunternehmen.
Wir hören heute, ich habe diesen Text aus der Süddeutsch mitgebracht, über das Potemkinsche Medienimperium von Wolfram Weimar. Man kommt aus dem Staunen nicht raus. Also es ist wirklich Gänsehaut.
Wir sprechen nämlich auch über den Kulturpass noch mal.
Oh ja, sehr gut. Die besten Ideen von Wolfram Weimar, die er sein Leben lang ausgeputet hat heute. Er möchte gerne zeigen, dass die Kritik von Stefan Schulz zum Thema Gabo Steingart hat noch nie ein YouTube-Video selber hochgeladen. Nicht ganz stimmt. Er kennt sich in der Sprache der Computerfreaks aus.
Diese Systeme sind heute outdated. Und so wie wir beim Computer mit outdated, dann kommt eine neue Diskette rein oder wir gehen in die Cloud. Und wir sind nicht in der Cloud, sondern wir handeln hier noch mit Floppy Disk, um in der Sprache der Computerfreaks zu sein.
Oh, da kennt sich aber einer richtig aus.
Die Sprache der Computerfreaks, Floppy Disk.
Ja, ne, das ist... Wann war das? 1994 oder so?
Ja, im Grunde 1803. Friedrich Merz, Gabor Steingart urteilt jetzt über Friedrich Merz. Wir haben ja gerade gehört, die Politiker kommen bei ihm nicht so gut weg. Robert Habeck zum Beispiel. Hitler, ziemlich gut, Führer. Jetzt Friedrich Merz.
Friedrich Merz wäre wahrscheinlich jemand, wenn er jetzt nicht in der Verantwortung wäre, der als Erster zusammen mit Wirtschaftsbossen dort stehen würde und sagen würde, wir brauchen einen Alten da, wie Gerhard Schröder. Warum kriegt er das jetzt als Kanzler zumindest bislang nicht hin?
Tja, also positiv muss man sagen, er ist wirklich ein Wissender. Alles, was ich hier aufschreibe, weiß er. Ich habe viele...
Friedrich Merz ist vieles, aber er ist kein Wissender. Der hat keine Ahnung von nichts.
Gut, er hat genau dasselbe Buch wie Gabor Steingart geschrieben damals.
Das stimmt, aber jetzt ohne Quatsch. Es würde mich nicht wundern, wenn Friedrich Merz noch niemals ICE gefahren ist.
Ja, könnte sein.
Ich glaube, diese Fahrt in die Ukraine war für ihn das einzige Zugfahren ever. Und er hat einfach zwei Waggons für sich gehabt, den er sich mit Kirst Damer und Macron teilen musste. Das ist für ihn Zugfahren. Er glaubt, das ist Zugfahren. Mediengeschehen ist für ihn... Ja, ich bin heute Abend in der ARD eingeladen. Und dann wundert er sich, warum das Land nicht auf ihn hört. Er hat doch heute Abend eine Ansage gemacht. Ja. So. Ja. Das ist der Wissender, ja. Und es kann... Also dieses Urteil kann man nur sagen, wenn man selber sich zu diesen Wissenden zählt. Ja. Also dass er hier das argumentiert mit Friedrich Merz weiß, was ich weiß, er ist ein Wissender, ist wirklich sehr vielsagend.
Friedrich Merz wäre wahrscheinlich jemand, wenn er... Warum kriegt er das jetzt als Kanzler zumindest bislang nicht hin?
Tja.
Also positiv muss man sagen, er ist wirklich ein Wissender. Alles, was ich hier aufschreibe, weiß er. Ich habe viele Gespräche, nicht jetzt als Kanzler, früher mit ihm geführt, immer wieder. Er ist ein Wissender. Er kennt auch den Kapitalmarkt. Er kennt die Schwäche des Sozialstaates.
Er kennt den Kapitalmarkt und die Schwächen des Sozialstaates. Ja, das weiß er. Ja, klar. Oh Gott, Rondsheimer steigt ein bisschen mit ein.
Jetzt sagen einige, das ist interessant, weil du hast gerade gesagt, Angela Merkel hat immer die großen Krisen benutzt, um zu begründen, warum sie innenpolitische Reformen eher nicht anpackt. Jetzt sehen wir Friedrich Merz, der nach Brüssel jettet. Da geht es um das russische Vermögen. Der versucht, Zelensky immer wieder zu treffen. Der versucht, mit Trump eine Brücke zu bauen, sich aber auch klar abzugrenzen, wenn Trump zu weit geht. Also der sich klar, und das war ja auch davor, als jemand der Chef der Atlantikbrücke war, also der sich klar außenpolitisch verortet.
So, Merz klar außenpolitisch verordnet, der Trump auch mal die Schranken weist. Die beiden konnten natürlich noch nicht wissen. Wir haben das natürlich auch vorher schon gewusst. Also wir brauchten jetzt diese Empirie dafür nicht. Aber wenn in dieser Sicherheitsstrategie Amerikas drin steht, fuck the you, dann sagt Merz, ja genau, weg damit. Ja. So, die beiden haben natürlich, also vor allem Ronz haben abgehört später im Podcast dann, also in seinem Podcast nach diesem Ereignis so, ja das war wirklich unklug und so.
Aber wo hat denn sonst auch Merz Trump Paroli geboten? Habe ich irgendwas nicht mitbekommen in den letzten Monaten?
Ja, er hatte eine sehr gute Performance, als Trump ihn 45 Minuten im Oval Office hatte, aber abgelenkt war von seinem Break-up mit Musk. Und in den zwei Minuten 37, die er da gesprochen hat, kam er ja einer Talking Point zur Ukraine, schon ganz gut.
Ah ja, okay, das hätte ich beinahe vergessen. Mutig.
Also wir hier, das Milieu, die aufgeklärten, die Wissenden in Deutschland, die brauchen keinen weiteren Fauxpas von März vor laufender Kamera, um einfach zu sagen, nee, der ist nur im Ausland, um Innenpolitik zu vermeiden.
Ja.
Und im Ausland gelingt das auch nicht allzu gut, was er da macht.
Und wenn er dann zurückkommt, dann sagt er, da gab es wieder kein deutsches Brot.
Genau. Und hier diese anderen Wissenden, die sind dann immer so überrascht. Also ich fand es auch nicht schlecht, Robin Alexander, bis zu Ende des Monats im Podcast zu hören, wie er sich dazu äußert, was Merz da gesagt hat. Nur ich denke mir so, warum bist du überrascht? Also warum wartest du immer auf das, klar ist jetzt sein Thema große emotionale Ereignisse, was dann irgendwie so Ohrpots blitzt. Aber das ist doch völlig klar, dass der Merz so tickt. Also das Fuck the EU, da einfach Programm ist so. Wenn die Amerikaner einen Partner brauchen und auf die EU nicht setzen wollen, dann versucht es doch mit uns so. Und die ganze Handelspolitik macht man dann über Katharina Reiche oder was? Also das sind alles keine guten Aussichten.
Wir kriegen bei ihm nicht das, was wir bestellt haben und die CDU kriegt nicht, was sie bestellt hat. Ich glaube sein Hauptproblem ist, dass er kein Politiker ist tatsächlich.
Ach so. Also das ist jetzt das Zwischenfazit irgendwie. Von Gabriel Steingold über März. Ich glaube das Hauptproblem ist, er ist eigentlich ein guter Mensch und in der Bundesrepublik sind ja nur schlechte Menschen. Und er ist aber eigentlich kein Politiker. Deutschland muss jetzt jedenfalls restrukturiert werden.
Mir fallen sehr viele Sozialdemokraten ein, mit denen ich absolut konform bin, dass diese Dinge, die ich beschreibe, das ist nicht crazy. Und das ist auch nicht Neoliberalismus. Das ist nicht links nicht.
Nee, das ist weder crazy noch Neoliberalismus. Klar.
Neoliberalismus. Das ist nicht links, nicht rechts, was ich vorschlag. Das ist vernünftig. Die Dinge gemeinsam, wie in einer Firma auch. Sozialpartnerschaft heißt ja, man macht das zusammen. Und Deutschland muss restrukturiert werden.
Ja, Sozialpartnerschaft heißt, man macht das zusammen. Nee, Sozialpartnerschaft heißt, dass man die Arbeiter durch Umarmung erdrosselt und nicht sozialpartnerschaftlich vorgeht, wie ja die Reallohnentwicklung und die Entwicklung beim DAX deutlich zeigen. Da gibt es ja einen Unterschied. Und was er hier als vernünftig preist, ist ja einfach nur zu sagen, alles, was dem Interesse der Konzerne dient, ist vernünftig fertig.
Ja, also Sozialpartnerschaft heißt übersetzt ganz konkret, hier hält sich die Politik raus. Und dann bleibt nur noch eine Logik und das ist, der Reichere hat Recht. Ja. So, Punkt. Und so möchte er Deutschland strukturieren. Ich finde auch gut, dass man in diesem Trump-Zeitalter, wo sich wirklich alle vernünftigen Autoren darüber lustig machen, wie sehr Trump Amerika einfach als ein Teil seiner Firma versteht. Die Idee hat, wir sollten das wie eine Firma machen. Na ja, Benchmarks. Ganz wichtig. Die Gefahren sehen und vor allem Tendenzen und Trends ablesen.
Deswegen muss ich die AfD nicht heiraten und auch keine Koalition machen. Den ganzen braunen Kram draußen lassen.
So, den ganzen braunen Kram draußen lassen. Man hört schon im Gespräch, man sollte schon mal mit der AfD so ein bisschen, man muss ja jetzt nicht die heiraten. Aber so eine kleine Anwarnung, so ein Dating, ein bisschen Vormelden, das kann man machen.
Ist ja da, dieser braune Kram, Graber. Wenn du sagst, du willst mit denen eine Mehrheit, dann brauchst du da ja auch diejenigen, die mit Identitären zusammen Dinge machen, die rechtsradikal sind. Also da gibt es ja nur eine Menge von.
Aber es gibt vielleicht auch die anderen. Ich würde das Gespräch suchen und es wird ein Regierungschef kommen. Glaubt mir Paul, der das Gespräch sucht mit denen, die das Land reformieren wollen und keine mit einer Partei, die vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz so bewertet wird. Tja.
Tja. Der Kommentar lautet tja.
Vom Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz so bewertet wird.
Tja. Ja, aber sie ist zulässig. Sie ist erlaubt. Sie sitzt da im Parlament vor ihm.
Sie ist zulässig. Sie ist erlaubt. Sie sitzt im Parlament, ja, weil die Demos zum Thema könnte sie bitte mal überprüfen und im Zuge dessen gleich mal alle Parteien noch zu klein sind. Aber wahrscheinlich gehe ich mit auf die Straße. Soll ja Demos geben.
Das ist der Oppositionspartei. Das meine ich. Ein Politiker muss sich die Mehrheit holen. Pass auf. Oder er sagt, ich mache mit denen, das ist die andere Alternative und wir ziehen in Neuwahlen. Und ich überzeug die Deutschen, jetzt packen wir es gemeinsam an. Und wir kommen aus der Nichtwahlgeschichte raus. 25 Prozent, also ein Viertel der Erwachsenen sind in dieser Fraktion, wählen nicht.
Ach so, das ist jetzt ein Problem.
Und ich versuche, den mittigen Teil der AfD zu gewinnen. Ich versuche, die FDP-Wähler jemals...
Gibt es denn da einen mittigen Teil? Siehst du da bei der AfD einen mittigen Teil?
Ich kenne mich zu wenig aus. Ich kenne...
Ach so.
Jetzt gerade kennt man sich gleich da kurz zu wenig aus. Das mit dem Führer ist eine super geile Sache gewesen.
Aber wir können schon mal lösen. Alles, was Gabor Steingart vorschlägt, würde Alice Weidel so hundertprozentig mittragen. Also ich wüsste überhaupt gar nicht, wo Gabor Steingart und Alice Weidel irgendeinen Disput haben. Ich hätte bis vor diesem Podcast noch gesagt, naja, Gabor Steingart würde vermutlich sich mit der deutschen Geschichte wesentlich kritisch auseinandersetzen wollen als Alice Weidel. Aber nachdem wir gehört haben, wir haben da eh so einen kleinen Defekt, weil wir Angst vor einem Führer haben, würde ich sagen, gibt es auch diesen Anknüpfungspunkt nun.
Also Rente abschaffen und das ganze Geld zu Goldman Six bringen, ist Alice Weidels Programm. Das muss sie eigentlich im Konflikt mit Höcke gerade durchboxen.
Genau.
So jetzt kommt Gabor Steingart einfach und sagt, nö, die hat schon recht.
Gibt es denn da einen mittigen Teil, siehst du da bei der AfD den mittigen Teil?
Ich kenne mich zu wenig aus, ich kenne sehr wenige.
Dafür sagst du das aber sehr leichtfertig, dass man einfach mal mit denen doch mal ein paar Mehrheiten sich holen sollte.
Naja, was heißt leichtfertig? Wir stehen vor der Frage, ob das Land sich selber reformieren kann oder ob die AfD weiter durchmarschiert. Also wenn man die Gefahr der AfD ernst nimmt.
Also gegen die AfD hilft, die Reform zu machen, die die AfD will.
Am besten mit der AfD zusammen.
Ja, dann haben wir sie besiegt.
Dann kann man ja nicht mit dem Rezept der letzten fünf Jahre das zu Verdopplung, Verdreifahrung, ich weiß nicht. Kein Aggregat in Deutschland ist schneller gewachsen, außer der Sozialstaat vielleicht als die AfD. Die AfD wächst schneller als die Börse. Also die AfD ist der schnellste, irgendwas kann ja nicht richtig sein.
Ja, hier, das war ja sehr offenbar gerade, ne, also so eine echte Ehrlichkeit von Gabo Steingart. Alles nur so in Wachstumskurven denken. Und Wachstum kann auch schlecht sein, wenn die falschen Sachen wachsen. Und nachdem er eigentlich gerade zwei Minuten lang im Fokus-Korridor AfD war, bringt er da noch mal den Sozialstaat begrifflich mit rein, weil der wächst noch schneller als die AfD und ist ja auch schlecht. Also das ist doch wirklich... Wieso, also wieso kämpfen wir überhaupt in irgendwelchen Sachen gegen eine AfD? Und Gabor Steingart macht aber jeden Morgen einfach so ein Briefing.
Ja, ja, ich mein...
Das sind doch hier wirklich, und ich weiß, das klingt jetzt beleidigend und gerne Anwaltsbriefe, aber das, was ich hier gehört habe gerade, ist wirklich Verfassungsfeindlichkeit. Je nachdem, wie eine Podcast-Kontrollnote aussehen würde, die man dann formuliert, aber das Verfassungsgericht würde, glaube ich, sagen, Vorsicht hier. Das ist nicht ganz konform, so mit typischer Erzählung.
Meine These ist sowieso, dass wir mit dieser permanenten Konzentration auf die Faschisten ganz übersehen haben, was sich in der Mitte tut und dass das alles gar nicht verhandelt wird. Wir reden die ganze Zeit über Propaganda und das kommt ja dann immer von Russland oder von der AfD. Nö, das kommt hier ganz aus der Mitte und wird von breiten Teilen der Medienöffentlichkeit getragen, wie man ja sieht, weil er hier prominent im Rondsheimer Podcast ist, zum Springerkonzern in gewisser Weise dazugehört. Und nur von dieser Seite aus ist überhaupt der Rechtsruck zu vollziehen. Also es wird ja nicht in Volksaufstand geben und dann übernimmt Höcke plötzlich alle Landesregierungen und dann wird alles gleichgeschaltet. Das ist ja nicht vorstellbar. Sondern es geht nur so, dass der Rechtsruck sich über diese Mitte vollzieht, die alle Türen so langsam öffnet oder zumindest schon mal die Fenster auf Kipp stellt. Und das ist etwas, was aus der Mitte kommen wird. Und da wird man sich dann eher mit Alice Weidel verbünden als mit einem Koppala oder Höcke. Das mag dann sein, aber das macht es ja nicht besser.
Genau. Also bei Ferdinand von Schirach, das ist heute gar nicht so groß Thema hier, aber dieses Wetter gegen Migration. Und das muss man doch jetzt mal einsehen. Und die ganzen Gerichte sind über, und die ganzen Ausländer und so, das geht ja gar nicht. Ja, das war da schon ein Thema komplett auf AfD-Linie. Und hier alles andere. Die ganze Sozialstaatsdiskurs auf dieser AfD-Linie. Onzeigern muss man sagen, hält ein bisschen gut nach, so, hält gut dagegen.
Wenn man von der Sache herkommt, muss man über die Sache sprechen, nicht über Koalitionen, nicht über die ganzen antihumanen Ideen der AfD.
Aber ich finde, man muss, sorry, dass ich da dazwischen gehe, aber zuallererst darüber sprechen, was die AfD angeht. Weil ich kann noch nicht sagen, ich öffne mich jetzt für eine Partei, die vom Verfassungsschutz als gesichert rechtsextrem bewertet wird und ignoriere das irgendwie und sage, naja, ist jetzt halt so.
Aber was ist dann deine Antwort?
Ja, das ist aber genau die Haltung. Wer BEP-Wachstum verspricht, kann so schlimm nicht sein. Und wir geben, wir kennen ja zum Beispiel auch von Hayek diese Aussagen, wie ist das, wenn eine Diktatur da ist, dann würde der auch sagen, ja, bevor sozialistische Ideen sich breitmachen, hat er ja auch so formuliert, ist dann eine faschistische Diktatur vorzuziehen. Nicht auf Dauer gestellt, aber das kann zunächst einmal doch weiterhelfen, dass man wieder ein bisschen auf Trab kommt.
Ja, das Problem ist halt, in dem AfD-Programm, das ja Steingart nicht liest, weil er einfach nur von Weidel fasziniert ist, steht drin Rentenniveau 70 Prozent. Also es ist ganz unvereinbar wiederum mit dem, was er da labert so, ne. Also man wüsste gar nicht, also wenn jetzt er öffnet der AfD Tür und Tor und dann ein Jahr später, wie jetzt Rente 70 Prozent, wie was, also ich wollte eigentlich 47, nicht 70. Steingart meint es wirklich, der ist ganz überzeugt.
Mit den Konzernscheinen, mit denen du redest, du bist wahrscheinlich einer der best vernetzten in der deutschen Wirtschaft, sagen das viele das gleiche, was du mir jetzt gerade gesagt hast.
Ja, und zwar die sagen alle dasselbe. Da ist ganz viel braune Soße. Damit wollen wir nichts zu tun haben. Damit darf ein demokratischer Politiker nicht koalieren. Nicht koalieren. Und dann, und dann kommt der Punkt 4. Aber wir müssen ein Gespräch trotzdem beginnen darüber, wie Deutschland reformiert werden kann.
Ja, das heißt ja einfach als Arbeitsaufgabe für die AfD. Bitte haltet die Identitären klein oder vielleicht könnten wir da ein Verbot hinbekommen. Lasst den Höcke draußen. Der kann höchstens dann noch auf Landesebene den Zampano machen. Aber bitte auf Bundesebene übernimmt das neoliberale Programm von Steingart vollends. Und bei Fragen der Migration haben wir sowieso keine Differenzen mehr. Insofern ist das ja eine ausgemachte Sache. Das Einzige, was man eben nicht möchte, ist, dass man jetzt zu sehr jetzt vielleicht noch die Waffen essen oder so glorifiziert. Das wäre wirklich ein bisschen unangenehm. Auch gerade im Ausland sieht das bisschen hässlich aus. Aber sonst können wir eigentlich alles machen.
Milanović beschreibt es ganz wunderbar. Jähl ziehen, besoffen, aus dem Abend, wie auch immer. Und ganz Russland droht einfach diesen Oligarchen zum Opfer zu fallen. Also kommt so ein Typ auf die Idee und sagt, komm wir nehmen einfach diesen Putin. So ein kleiner, zarter Typ, der ist so schmächtig, der äußert sich nie, keine Gefahr.
Der hat keine Ideologie.
Genau. Und dann glaubt man, man könnte mit ihm gemeinsame Sachen machen gegen die Oligarchen. Ein Jahr später ist Vladimir Putin der Zar der Oligarchen. Und 25 Jahre später ist er es immer noch. Also diese ganze Idee, die er hier hat mit, ja, ich möchte den Sozialstaat abräumen und die SPD macht ja irgendwie nicht mit, die linken und grünen sind eh verloren und vergessen, lass uns doch mit der AfD machen. Aber diese ganze braune Soße, das ist ja nicht so wichtig. Wir wollen ja nur kurz den Sozialstaat abräumen. Danach geben die uns das Land bestimmt zurück. Dann machen wir das. Und dann ist es irgendwie 2055 und wir müssen wieder Bücher schreiben über, dass mit dem Führer war, auch beim zweiten Mal keine gute Idee. Ja, das droht hier einfach. Kostenverkleinerung, ja. Wir müssen jetzt die Größte verkleinern, letzter Clip.
Und wenn wir uns auf dieses Ziel, wir vergrößern jetzt den produktiven Kern, verständigen, dann leiten sich viele Maßnahmen genau daraus ab. Weil dann sortiere ich die Welt, vergrößert es die Kruste oder den Kern. Rentenreform im Bundestag? Eine eklatante Kostenvergrößerung. Weg damit. Tariftreuegesetz, wo jetzt jedes kleine Firma Tariflöhne zahlen muss, also Lohnerhöhung, schadet ihnen auf den Weltmärkten. Weg damit. Also verstehst du, ich brauche ein sehr klares Raster. Das versucht dieses Buch jedem Menschen zu geben. Dieses klare Navigationssystem.
Ja, dieses Buch sagt den Menschen, du sollst verarmen, damit es der Klasse, die ich repräsentiere, besser geht.
Du bist Großte, du musst weg.
Und wenn du im Kern bist, dann hast du dich gefälligst noch viel mehr anzustrengen, weil ich gerne für meine Klasse mehr rausholen will.
Das ist wirklich ekallhaft. Man will es einfach abschütteln.
Deswegen will ich das als Ansatz machen, ich will also nichts mehr hören auf irgendwelchen Podiumsdiskussionen. Man wird ja doch viel eingeladen. Ja, was tun wir gegen die Gefahr von rechts? Und damit wird immer die AfD gemeint und Fake News im Internet. Dann stellt bitte die Frage, was tun wir gegen den Springer Verlag? Da können wir gerne mal darüber diskutieren. Was tun wir gegen öffentlich-rechtliche Talkshows, die mit solchen Leuten besetzt sind? Ich will nur noch über diese Fragen diskutieren. Ich habe keine Lust, mich daran aufzuhalten, ob man die Publizistik in Schnellroda verbieten sollte oder nicht. Die spielt keine Rolle. Hier wird die große Politik gemacht. Diese Leute drehen am Großen Rat.
So ist es. Termine. Ich war bei Lanz. Mit mir war dort die Chef-Volkswirtin oder was auch immer der Welt.
Bei der Welt bekommt jeder so einen Cheftitel.
Egal, was man hat. Sie ist die Wirtschaftschefin. Frau Siems und zwei Professoren und Institutsverantwortliche. Einmal aus dem IFO-Institut, einmal vom Bevölkerungsforschungsinstitut hier, von BIP. Freut euch bitte auf zwei Argumentationen. Zum einen, alle feiern immer so Hartz-IV-Reform ab und so. Und ich will das auch an niemandem madig reden. Nur, ich denke mir, vor 20 Jahren waren die Armen dran. Jetzt brauchen wir wieder eine Sozialstaatsreform. Jetzt soll es um die Reichen gehen. Zweites Argument. Und da bin ich auch erst drauf gestoßen, als ich mich auf die Sendung vorbereitete, weil der Herr Peichel vom IFO-Institut selber da war als Autor. Typischerweise sitzt man ja im Fernsehen immer mit irgendwelchen anderen Politikern oder so. Oder Leute, die mal so ein Kommentar schreiben. Aber Leute, die so echte Forschung machen, schon was Besonderes. Und der Herr Peichel hat letztes Jahr einen Text mitverantwortet, der davon handelt, wie sich die Lohnentwicklung von 1983 bis heute entwickelt hat. Das ist also genau die Erwerbsbiografiephase der Boomer, die heute in Rente gehen, die Deutschland zur drittgrößten Volkswirtschaft der Welt gemacht haben. Die haben also richtig reingebuttert. Sie haben während ihrer Lebensarbeitszeit das BIP verdoppelt. Wirtschaftswachstum 100 Prozent. Und jetzt war natürlich die Frage, die ich an den Text stellte, wie haben sich denn die Löhne in der Zeit entwickelt? Auch verdoppelt? Und der Herr Peichel schreibt von Dekaden der Stagnation und Reallohnverlust. Und da liegt natürlich die Frage auf der Hand, wieso ist denn dieses produktive Wachstum niemals in die Rentenkasse angekommen? Warum reden wir über auch zu wenig Junge, zu viele Ältere und so weiter und so fort? Hat es vielleicht, wie Moses Höfgen schon schreibt, gar nichts mit Jung und Alt, sondern mit Reich und Arm zu tun. Und nachdem dann die Frau Siems ewig lange ausführt und hier und da und so, habe ich dann die Rückfrage an sie, wo denn das Leben in ihren Ausführungen vorkommt. Denn ich habe ja auch daran teilgenommen und ich habe das eigentlich, glaube ich, es war keine Vater Morgane, als es hieß, da ist irgendwie eine Liemann-Bankpleite gegangen und jetzt ist da irgendwie ein Angriffskrieg und jetzt sind da irgendwie Inflationen 10 Prozent. Ach ja, eine Corona-Krise haben wir auch noch. Findet einfach gar nicht statt. Sie guckt einfach so in die Bücher und sagt, also für mich ist das alles, das ist like anything to me. Wie so ein Host aus Westfölter und so. Naja, also es ist die letzte Sendung von Lanz des Jahres, ich glaube, die kommt am Donnerstag.
Prima. Und noch einen Termin im Januar bist du?
Ja, am 9. Januar in Erlangen abends mit Obie Florian Janik. Gespräch über die Kinderwüste. Für ganz Ausgewählte ein, jetzt fällt mir der richtige Name nicht ein, aber es ist super witzig. Denn ich habe ja gesagt, das ist ja direkt neben Nürnberg. Ich würde gern mal die historischen Städten, als das mit dem Führern auch funktioniert hat und so sehen. Und bei mir hat sich Thorsten gemeldet. Und es ist super witzig, wenn man fragt. Also er ist Rundgangsleiter, möchte ich damit sagen. Die Pointe ist, er nennt sich Rundgangsleiter, weil natürlich, also Guide könnte man auch noch sagen.
Ja.
Aber alles, was Führer im Namen hat, den nennt man natürlich nicht. Also haben wir den Rundgangsleiter Thorsten gefunden. Thomas aus dem Fernsehpodcast und ich werden also einen Rundgang mit Thorsten machen. Und wir hätten vielleicht noch so ein oder zwei, aber bitte nicht einfach nur flapsige E-Mails schreiben jetzt, sondern wirklich so richtig kleine Bewerbungen, warum ihr mit uns da fünf, sechs Stunden mit verbringen wollt.
An Stefan, an deinen Adresse.
An mail.stephanschulz.com. Dann nehme ich das gerne in Begutachtung. Und dann können wir uns einen schönen Tag machen.
Wir werden also jetzt in den Salon rübergehen und sprechen dann über Branko Milanović, The Great Global Transformation, über den Nationalmarkt-Liberalismus in einer multipolaren Welt. So der Untertitel. Es ist ein sensationelles Buch. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie wir da gleich darüber diskutieren werden. Ich hatte eigentlich angekündigt, dass ich das Buch von Thomas Wagner bespreche. Ich habe mich nicht gegen das Buch entschieden. Das kommt nämlich dann im nächsten Salon. Aber wir müssen uns auf einen Text viel intensiver konzentrieren. Ich habe da so viel zu sagen, dass einfach das schade wäre, wenn ich das Sachbuch dann nur kurz verhandle. Denn ich habe 150 Seiten der EKD gelesen, der Evangelischen Kirche Deutschlands. Die haben sich zu Krieg und Frieden geäußert. Und es ist empörend, es ist skandalös, dieses Dokument. Ich bin ja schon aus der Kirche ausgetreten und ich bin sehr gespannt, wenn Leute das jetzt hier hören werden und die in der Kirche sind, wie sie sich dazu verhalten. Ich will nur kurz sagen, man kann ganz leicht aus der Kirche austreten. Es ist ganz einfach. Man braucht nur schnell zur Stadtverwaltung, braucht wahrscheinlich auch nicht mal einen Termin. Und es ist ein Gespräch von fünf Minuten. Also man muss sich ja nicht rechtfertigen, sondern einfach nur was unterschreiben. Es ist nicht zu fassen, wie der christliche Pazifismus hier nicht nur abgeräumt wird, sondern wie hier eine Kirche für Musterung, für Wehrpflicht plädiert, für atomare Aufrüstung und sogar noch das Fliehen vor Krieg unter Bedingungen stellt. Also ich bin so empört darüber und glaube ich muss da ganz lange drüber reden, habe hier fünf Seiten Exzerpt. Das wird also das große Thema, das zweite für mich im Salon sein. Außerdem noch einen Roman aus Japan über einen Tokyo Sympathy Tower, so heißt der Titel, in dem die Kriminellen leben sollen. Und die sollen dann aber paradiesisch leben, denn die Sprachpolitik will es, dass über alles nur noch positiv gesprochen wird. Es ist aber jetzt nicht einfach so ein antipolitikalkorrektes Roman, sondern ein bisschen differenzierter, interessanter. 5% des Romans wurden mit Checi Petit geschrieben, hat die Autorin auch gesagt. Außerdem beschäftigen wir uns nochmal mit dem Kulturpass und ziehen da Bilanz. Und es wird von mir auch noch einen Musiktipp geben, nämlich es gibt eine neue Winterreise-Einspielung. Ich habe ja schon mal die Winterreise hier von André Schuhn empfohlen. Nun Johannes Martin Krenzler, grandios.
Okay. Aladin Elmar Falani hat ein Buch geschrieben. Wichtiges Thema Vertrauen und Misstrauen in unserer durchrüttelten Welt. Dieses Buch ist so schlecht, ich konnte es gar nicht glauben. Für mich rangiert leider der Autor jetzt Haaresbreite über Markus Gabriel. Oh je. Es ist wirklich vernichtend. Und die Potemkinsche Mediengruppe, die Süddeutsche Zeitung Jörg Henschel hat sich Wolfram Weimers gigantisches Medienimperium angeschaut. 293 Abonnenten. The Verge hat einen Text aufgegriffen, den es schon woanders gab, nämlich bei Benjamin Riley. Die haben ihn gebeten, nochmal ein Argument auszubauen, der selbst ist Mitglied einer, wie nennt man das, NGO, irgendwie Cognitive Resonance, die also gegen den AI-Hype ankämpft. Das kommt dir sehr entgegen und ich finde es auch wahnsinnig interessant, aber es stellen sich noch soziologische Fragen, die wir gleich mal aufgreifen. Und Sven Kalisch hat Born, Rich or Die, Trying, eine wunderbare Auftröselung über die Deutsche Erbengesellschaft mit der Ankündigung, weitere thematische Texte anschließen zu lassen. Ich sehe hier die Anbahnung einer Enzyklopädie zum Thema, was uns alle interessiert. Und zwar bei Substack einfach so als Privatvergnügen. Und das ist ja auch ein Format, das ich immer besser finde so, dass jetzt immer mehr Leute immer mehr Kram machen. Und von daher hier Blogosphere 2.0 oder so.
Wunderbar. Das ist auch zugleich, wenn man in den Salon geht, die einzige Möglichkeit, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen. Und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Dort findet man dann übrigens auch, weil wir jetzt ein paar E-Mails bekommen haben nach Geschenktipps. Nun ja, wir haben jetzt ja so viele Bücher besprochen in den letzten Monaten, auch noch mal Einzellempfehlungen dabei gehabt. Ich habe ja fast jedes Mal was Literarisches noch dabei. Da findet man jetzt wirklich Geschenkideen noch und nöcher. Ich glaube, wir brauchen jetzt nicht noch mal extra zehn Bücher nennen, die man verschenken kann. Da ist alles dabei oder den Salon verschenken.
Genau. Also in der Ansicht, ich habe jetzt meinen Freundeskreis erweitert um diese ganzen KI-Sachen. Und es ist wirklich sehr, also es ist einfach nur der Zeit geschuldet, dass neuezwanzige.de noch nicht so eine richtig große Stöberseite ist, wo auch alle Argumente, die wir zu den hunderten Büchern, die wir besprochen haben, noch mal schön durchsuchbar und so weiter alle. Also wenn ihr dann nächstes Jahr Geschenke sucht und kluge Sachen verschenken wollt, dann können wir bei Neuezwanziger Sachen anbieten. Das haben die Föhtons in Deutschland, die auch zum Jahresende immer so jeder Redakteur schreibt, mal kurz drei Zeilen zu irgendwas, noch nicht gesehen.
Also ich bin sehr gespannt, was da kommt.
Der Schatz wird gehoben.
Gut, dann bis gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich. Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Ich habe in unserem Buch einiges zu Marx gelesen. Überdenkst du deine Lektüre von Marx nochmal?
Ich würde sie erweitern.
Was heißt erweitern?
Nun ja, deine These ist, dieses Buch sagt uns, Marx hat Unrecht oder was?
Also ich möchte es ganz explizit wie folgt sagen, nachdem ich dieses Buch ausführlich studiert habe und überrascht war, es war ja deine Empfehlung.
Ja.
Und ich dachte mir so, ah ja, hier kommt ja auch Marx drin vor. Also es liegt irgendwie nah. Ich kannte Branko Milanović, obwohl du den vorher immer mal erwähnt hast, nicht lesend.
Und muss doch jetzt sagen, diese ganze große Idee von Marx, dass auf den Kapitalismus zwangsläufig der Sozialismus folgt, geht vielleicht gar nicht auf. Und Milanović schreibt so darüber, dass er sein eigenes Argument abschließt mit, und es würde auch Marx heute so sehen.
Ja, die Sache ist ja die, dass Marx gar nicht so sehr eine Zwangsläufigkeit sah. Also es wird kommen. Ja, dann muss man ja nur warten. Dann hätte man ja auch gar nicht über revolutionäre Subjekte oder so nachdenken müssen über eine Arbeiterklasse, sondern dann warten wir ab und irgendwann schlägt die Uhr zwölf und dann ist der Sozialismus da. Sondern es ist ja die Frage, ob der Kapitalismus ein Stadium schafft, von dem aus der Sozialismus möglich ist. Und wenn ich gerade diese kleine Abzweigung machen darf, es gibt ja von Branko Milanović noch das Buch Kapitalismus Global. Und dort erzählt er ja, wie der Sozialismus im 20. Jahrhundert eine wichtige historische Funktion hatte. Nämlich eine kontraintuitive. Wir würden ja auch sagen, aha, der Sozialismus entwickelt sich aus dem Kapitalismus. Die These ist ja relativ leicht zu verstehen. Die Produktivkräfte werden entfesselt. Wir haben heute, das betonen wir hier laufend, einen unglaublichen stofflichen Reichtum. Nur kommt er ganz häufig bei denen, die ein Bedürfnis danach haben, nicht an, weil sie kein Geld in der Hand haben, um das entsprechende zu kaufen. Aber eigentlich sind wir uns ja einig, zum Beispiel jetzt für Deutschland oder für ganz Europa gesprochen oder für den Westen müsste kein Kind hungern. Man sagt nicht, ja leider haben wir zu wenige Äpfel, deswegen gibt es keine für die Kinder, sondern wir haben Leute, die sehr viel Geld haben und Leute, die haben wenig Geld. Die Idee ist also, wenn diese Produktivkräfte so entfesselt sind, dann kann man eigentlich sie irgendwann in die Hände der Arbeiter nehmen oder sie ergreifen sie sich und dann kann man die Wirtschaft so organisieren, dass man nach den Bedürfnissen produziert und da ein Reich der Freiheit schafft, dass so ein Kapitalismus nicht möglich ist. Die historische Entwicklung aber war folgende und das ist etwas, wo Branko Milanović nochmal Bezug drauf nimmt, ist, dass der Sozialismus diente in 20. Jahrhundert dazu, dass in den noch feudal organisierten Gesellschaften plötzlich eine Revolution stattfand und diese Revolution hat die feudalen Verhältnisse abgeschafft. Da wurden dann die Könige geköpft oder was auch immer oder der Zar und das hatte aber nicht dazu geführt, dass der Sozialismus sich dauerhaft etablierte, sondern man hat durch den Sozialismus dann die Produktivkräfte entfaltet, hat stofflichen Reichtum geschaffen und dann hat der Kapitalismus übernommen. Das heißt, der Sozialismus wurde zur Kapitalismus, zur Brücke für den Kapitalismus. Jetzt gibt es aber eine neue Entwicklung, nämlich dass wir eine Klasse haben, die nicht nur Vermögen hat und reine Rentierdaseins führt, wie wir das aus dem 19. Jahrhundert kennen. Denken wir an Jane Austen Romane, da sitzen die da, sind Pächter von irgendwas. Wir wissen gar nicht so genau, wo kommt das ganze Geld her. Jedenfalls arbeiten die nie, die machen nie einen Finger krumm. Und jetzt haben wir so eine neue Klasse, die viel Geld hat, geerbt durch Vermögen und auch noch viel Geld verdient, also die sich absolut zur Arbeiten Bevölkerung sieht. Und diese Klasse hat Marx nicht sehen können, weil das auch nicht klar war, dass der Kapitalismus sich so entwickelt. Und Marx hat auch nicht sehen können, dass sich ein Wohlstand so global entfalten kann, dass plötzlich wir die Staaten in dieser Weise konkurrierend gegenüber haben, wie Milanović uns das jetzt hier beschreibt. Und das führt natürlich erst mal dazu, dass hier kein Weg für den Sozialismus offen ist.
Ja, also finde ich interessant, dass er sagt, Marx hätte mir zugestimmt, so wie ich, über die Manager schreiben, den Managerialismus, also die Managerial Class, die wir von Kathrin Lu und so schon gehört haben und die sozusagen die großen Verwalter sind, die dieses Konkurrenzverhältnis der Staaten und so weiter für sich weiter ausnutzen. So ein bisschen wie, wenn das Family Office plötzlich sich einfach mit aufschwingt.
Ja. Dann plötzlich damit machen.
Außerdem haben wir hier eine starke These, finde ich, über Nationalismus oder eine Aufforderung, fast ein Appell über Nationalismus nochmal neu nachzudenken. Du hast ja im Vorgespräch eben schon gesagt, Milanović interessiert sich nicht so allzu sehr für die konkreten Führerpersonen, die irgendwo politische Geschäfte führen, sondern die sind im Grunde austauschbar. Der Zeitgeist hat sie halt hervorgebracht. Und dann wird so ein bisschen deren Tagebuche in der Tagesschau erzählt. Aber es ist jetzt nicht so entscheidend. Und das gilt auch für große Ideen. Also er sagt, Nationalismus wächst aus der Gier der Einzelnen heraus. Und dann will man das halt beschützen, einen Zaun bauen, bevor die Nachbarn kommen und so. Und es ist jetzt gar nicht so ein großer politischer Wind, der weht, sondern es ist einfach eine ökonomische Ableitung. Da habe ich so gedacht, ja, das ist...
In der Tat.
Das ist fast wie die Systemtheorie, immer wieder zurückzuziehen auf körperliche Bedürfnisse, symbiotische Mechanismen. Wie genau ist der Körper und zwar nicht als kognitive, sondern biologisches System an die Gesellschaft gekoppelt? Und irgendwie muss ich habe Hunger gesellschaftlich verrechnet werden. Und plötzlich haben wir einen Knappheitsdiskurs, der einfach Profite verrechnet und so weiter und so fort. Finde ich sehr gut. Eine These möchte ich noch vorher...
Wenn ich ja gerade noch anknüpfen kann. Das ist ja so interessant, dass hier nochmal der Nationalismus eigentlich auch entkernt wird. Also wir würden ja immer sagen, aber da gibt es doch dann so Föheton-Fragen nach dem Deutschen oder so. Und er würde sagen, naja, die einen holen sich das, die anderen das raus, was jetzt gerade funktioniert. Aber im Grunde kann man es runterrechnen. Will ich, dass der da im Nachbarland auch so reich ist wie ich? Weiß nicht.
Es ist jedenfalls, du hast jetzt entkernt, das ist genau die Einflugschneise, um zu erklären, ja, ja, das sind schon Ausländer. Aber die wählen halt trotzdem die AfD. Und man denkt sich so, ja, genau. Also warum auch nicht? Die haben ja auch was zu verteidigen. Die haben den Laden aufgemacht. Die haben ihre Biografie hier gestaltet. Das verteidigen die jetzt. Und da kommen halt irgendwelche armen Leute von irgendwo her. Und dann ist doch eine Syrer, der vor 20 Jahren hierhergezogen ist, völlig egal, ob jetzt in Äthiopien oder in Ghana.
Das ist nur so ein Diskurs aus Schnellroder, Benedikt Kaiser. Der will noch mal gucken, wie deutsch ist denn hier jemand? Die Autochtonen Deutschen oder wie das dann genannt wird. Aber das interessiert sonst niemanden.
Und die werden dann plötzlich Notfall-Liebertär. Man denkt sich, was ist das für ein alberner Quatsch? Ich kann sie einfach sagen, dass es die pure Gier und der Ekel vor anderen Leuten ist. Und das war es. Also ganz elementare Gefühle. Außerdem, bevor wir hier groß einsteigen und du mir deine Vorab-Erkenntnisse. Ich fand es sehr gut, wie der Milanović einfach Xi, Putin und Trump als Konterrevolutionäre darstellt.
Ja, ja.
Da lag was in der Luft. Männer wurden geboren. Sie waren gerade im richtigen Alter. 1 plus 1 ist 2. Jetzt zerbrecht euch nicht das Vöhtor-Gehirn darüber.
Ja, ist Trump da eine ganze Besonderheit? Er beschreibt noch mal so ein paar Dinge von Trump, die sehr gut sind. Darauf müssen wir noch mal kommen, wie er diese amerikanische Politikwirtschaftselite schildert und sagt, naja, war der jetzt wirklich so anders als ihr? Glaubt ihr das wirklich? Aber dass er die so in einem Atemzug nennt, könnte jetzt, bei denen, die es nicht gelesen haben, vielleicht im Kopf auslösen, naja, genau, das sind ja alles drei Autokraten. Aber das ist gar nicht so der Punkt bei Milanović jetzt, dass er sagt, das ist die Autokratie gegen die Demokratie, sondern er sagt, sie sind Konterrevolutionäre bezogen auf die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung, nämlich, dass da eine neoliberale Elite entstanden ist, beziehungsweise eine Oligarchienelite oder eine korrupte Parteielite, gegen die man dann mit Rückhalt der Bevölkerung, also populistisch in diesem Sinne, plötzlich solche Figuren hatte aufsteigen sehen. Aber das sei nun einfach eine historische Entwicklung, die das genommen hat und nicht jetzt so ein Sonderfall Trump oder ein Sonderfall Putin, sondern wie du sagst, die waren eben dann zum rechten Zeitpunkt da.
Ja, dass man sich in ihn irren kann, ist eingepreist. Also Trump wollte den Swamp drainen und den Deep State abschaffen. Und dass ich danach herausstellte, dass er das erst richtig etabliert hat, was man vorher kritisiert hat, ist halt so.
Ja.
Aber diese Verwechslung, die Wahl findet halt statt, wenn die Wahl stattfindet und nicht ein Jahr später, wo man das Retrospektiv alles anders sehen kann. Also von daher ist das schon wahnsinnig klug.
Eine These, die ich mitnehme aus diesem Buch, ist, dass wir uns vor globaler Gleichheit eigentlich fürchten.
Das finde ich wahnsinnig interessant, denn wir hatten jetzt erst wieder unsere Ein-Herz-für-Kinder-Gala und so. Und das Jahresende ist ja eigentlich immer so ein Fall von, ja, den ganz Ärmsten helfen wir jetzt nochmal. Also wer jetzt nur fünf Euro hat, dem schenken wir nochmal fünf, dann hat er nämlich zehn. Das ist eine Verdopplung. So, und das gibt es ja auch im globalen Kontext. Also zum Jahresende freuen wir uns nochmal ganz doll, dass auf der anderen Seite der Welt ganz viele ganz Arme aus der Armut ein bisschen geholt werden. So, wenn diese Niveauveränderung aber woanders stattfindet. Ach so, die Leute, die vorher immer in Vietnam Urlaub gemacht haben, machen den jetzt bei mir in Thailand? Im Vier-Stern-Resort? Nee. Plötzlich fallen sie auf, ja. Und das ist natürlich...
Was? Die Inder trinken jetzt auch mit dem Champagner weg? Muss das denn sein?
Genau. Also die Franzosen machen doch nur so und so viel. Das können wir doch nicht alles nach Indien schicken.
Ja.
Ja, aber die bezahlen mehr dafür. Wie? Was? Wo haben die das Geld her? So, ich wollte die doch nur aus der Armut holen, ja. Also das finde ich auch... Vielleicht ist fürchten hier das richtige Wort, ja.
Ja. Dann diese schon angesprochene Homoplutier, also die zum reichsten Dezil gehören, also den reichsten zehn Prozent. Von denen gibt es mehr und mehr Leute, die die reichsten Vermögenden sind und die reichsten Einkommensbezieher.
Also Homo, weil sie beides, beides haben. Gleichwertig Vermögen und Einkommen.
Und dass es dieses Phänomen jetzt gibt, also dass die Reichen auch arbeiten und zwar harte arbeiten.
Also ich würde sagen, nicht hart, aber viel und so auf gewisse Maße intensiv. Ja, sie genau, aber es ist nicht die harte Arbeit.
Es ist Work hard, play hard im Sinne von dieser, wir gucken lieber noch mal eine Runde und machen auch den Freitag ab und durch, bis in den Samstag.
Man pendelt auch nur von Millionenstadt zu Millionenstadt.
Klar.
Fliegt auch nur fürs Glas und so.
Man fasst sonst nichts an außer die Tastatur. Das ist völlig klar. Aber dass diese Homo Plutier eigentlich Umverteilung nahezu verunmöglicht, weil man ja relativ leicht sagen kann, das ist ja leistungsloses Einkommen bei den Vermietern. Aber wenn jetzt da so eine Kaste ist, die auch wirklich arbeitet und eine 80-Stunden-Woche hat, kann die sich viel besser abdichten vor diesen Umverteilungsdiskursen.
Genau. Und Abdichtung ist genau das Wort. Also du hast die Zahlen ja eben schon genannt. Ich will sie hier nochmal wiederholen. Es ist wirklich sehr beeindruckend. Denn normale Menschen machen die Erfahrung, okay, die Auswahl fürs Gymnasium kriegen Eltern noch irgendwie geregelt. Aber das Kind dann wirklich durchs Abitur zu bringen und dann auch durchs Jurastudium und zwar an den drei Top-Unis der Welt und so, das kostet und zwar pro Kind 10 Millionen Dollar. Die einfach als private Investition, um danach die hunderten Millionen und Milliarden weiter zu schützen. Muss man das Kind dann doch, also das Kind muss schon das Jurastudium einmal wirklich machen. Ja, es ist eben nicht das aristokratische, wir schlendern einfach durch Südengland und so, sondern nein, also die Zugangsbeschränkungen sind hart. Wir hatten die Skandale in Amerika mit, wie das mit den Unis ist und wer da nochmal so alles als Sportler eingeschrieben wird in Harvard und so, damit es irgendwie hinhaut. Und das Preisschild lautet 10 Millionen pro Kind.
Er schreibt hier, dass die monetäre Elite selbst gut gebildet und auch hard working, also intensiv arbeitend, einen ganz großen Teil des Geldes ausgeben kann oder generell ein Berg Geld ausgeben kann für die Erziehung und Bildung der Kinder, damit diese sich in diesem elitären System durchsetzen. Er sagt, Meritokratie ist nur ein anderer Weg, um eine herrschende Klasse herzustellen. Da geht es dann nicht mehr um den Geburtsvorteil, dass man einen großen Namen trägt. Das kann mitunter auch helfen. Aber wichtig ist wirklich, dass man educational credentials hat, dass man also Zertifikate hat, die man vorzeigen kann. Harvard, Columbia, Down-Dort-Praktikum gemacht.
Irgendwas in Tokio.
Was auch immer. Das sammelt man alles. Und er sagt dann, und hier kommt er wieder mit Marx, er ist ja nicht ein Anti-Maxist, sondern er liest ja Marx wahnsinnig produktiv und sagt, na ja, von Marx gibt es doch dieses GWG-Strich. Also das heißt, man hat Geld und das investiert man, dann macht man eine Ware. Ja, in Maschinen oder in Kinder.
Jetzt in Kinder. Aber bei Marx hatte ich Maschinen.
Und dann bekommt man mehr raus. Und so lohnen sich auch diese zehn Millionen. Und er sagt dann ja, also diese zehn Millionen kommen so zustande, dass er vergleicht den Unterschied zwischen der normalen Mittelklasse, was die investieren kann in Kindern und das, was die Reichen investieren. Da sind wir bei zehn Millionen Differenz angekommen. Das heißt, das ist nahezu uneinholbar.
Es gibt von Thomas Tom Krebs diese Forschung, die ich ja in der Kinderwüste auch gleich auf Seite eins unterbringe, die wir bei Philippa Siegel-Klöckner im Buch gelesen haben. Eine Investition in Bildung rentiert sich mit 14 Prozent nach elf Jahren. Das Kind kommt nur Arbeitsmarkt an und bringt viel höhere Einkommenssteuergewinne für den Staat mit, als wenn man jetzt in irgendeinem Nied ist, der erstmal aufgepäppelt werden muss. Philippa Siegel-Klöckner übrigens, spektakuläre Instagram-Videos immer wieder zu diesem, sie bringt eine Bildungsstudie nach der anderen und bringt die innerhalb von 30 Sekunden mit der deutschen Volkswirtschaft in Verbindung. Und dadurch wird einem sofort Angst und Bange. Und das große Problem, das habe ich auch mit Humann und Mary besprochen, als Humann so die Nachfrage hatte, warum investieren wir das Geld nicht einfach, warum so viel Rendite? Und das große Problem ist, weil wir sie particularistisch nicht verrechnen können. Alle Deutschen müssen in alle Kinder investieren, damit es allen Deutschen gut geht. Aber das eigene Kind könnte trotzdem unter die Räder kommen dabei. Hier haben wir diese ultimative Bestätigung, dass diese Bildungsrendite tatsächlich da ist und auch radikal knallhart durchgesetzt wird, wenn man sie particular verrechnet, wenn es in der eigenen Familie bleibt. 10 Millionen für das eigene Kind, um später hunderte Millionen und Milliarden zu bewahren. So, da sagt sich jede Familie, die eine Milliarde auf dem Konto hat, also diese 10 Millionen, das zahl ich auf jeden Fall. So, da organisier ich sogar noch. Das lass ich nicht Family Office machen, sondern da hab ich meine eigenen. So, da guck ich drauf, was passiert. So, und das können wir auch volkswirtschaftlich machen. Diese Superreichen haben an diesem Punkt Recht. Wir sollten von ihnen lernen und diese Bildungsrendite für uns alle fruchtbar machen. Und ja, das ist das erste Buch, in dem das so drinsteht. Das ist einfach validiert. Es sind echte 14 Prozent. Man muss sie nur einmal reinstecken, dann kommt man sie auch hinten wieder raus. Aber man muss es machen.
Jetzt werd ich dich noch mit einer These konfrontieren. Ich bin gespannt, was du dazu sagst. Haben wir uns oder nein, ich formulier's wirklich als These. Wir haben uns in den vergangenen Jahren zu viel über Vermögen unterhalten und zu wenig über Einkommen gesprochen.
Widerspruch. Widerspruch aus einfachem Grunde. Der Genie-Koeffizient beim Vermögen ist 0,8. Statistisch gerundet hat in Deutschland eine Person alles und 80 Millionen haben nichts. Statistisch gerundet im Sinne von so ungefähr 150 Familien haben alles und der Rest hat nichts. Beim Einkommen ist der Genie-Koeffizient 0,3.
Ja, ich weiß.
Und zwischen 0,3 und 0,8 liegen dramatische Welten, die ja auch Branko Milanović nicht leugnet. Wir haben dieses neue Phänomen, dass die Superreichen noch mal einen Weg gefunden haben, ihren Superreichtum abzusichern über ihren Nachwuchs und diese Bildungsinvestitionen. Das heißt, diese jungen Leute treten an zu durchschauen und verstehen zu wollen, was mit dem Geld geschieht. Sie sind selber diejenigen, die mit diesem Vermögen arbeiten. Sie lagern das nicht an eine Vermögensverwaltung, an einem Familyoffice aus. Sie arbeiten also. Dadurch generieren sie auch Einkommen. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass deswegen, nur weil die auch mal so ein Jahreseinkommen von 10 Millionen einfahren, während die Familie selbst 40 Milliarden hat, dass wir deswegen jetzt zu viel auf Vermögen und zu wenig auf Einkommen haben.
So meinte ich es auch nicht. Also es gibt dieses Phänomen Homopletier und es wird auch sich zeigen, ob sich das weiterhin so entwickelt. Noch ist es ja nicht so, dass es gänzlich so ist in dem obersten Deziel. Das macht er auch deutlich und er beschreibt das ja auch für fortgeschrittene kapitalistische Länder. Er zeigt zum Beispiel auch auf, dass das in Mexiko nicht in dieser Weise der Fall ist oder auch in anderen Ländern nicht so stark da ist. Da meinte ich es gar nicht. Aber wir haben unglaublich viele Videos auf Instagram gesehen, Texte, Rich unter all das. Und ich bin ja auch grundsätzlich dafür. Ich finde es manchmal noch viel zu zahm formuliert alles. Nur um das schon mal klarzustellen, also ich sage jetzt nicht, ach jetzt lassen wir doch mal den Reichen das Vermögen. Nein, ich glaube aber, indem wir so sehr über diese großen Vermögensberge gesprochen haben, ist uns eigentlich ein anderer Punkt nicht aufgefallen. Nämlich Umverteilung findet ja auch dann statt, wenn ich höhere Löhne einfordere. Und die findet vielleicht auf bessere Weise statt, weil sie im Portemonnaie der Arbeitnehmer landet. Während eine Umverteilung, die jetzt Erbschaftssteuer oder sowas bedeutet, erst mal sagt, die Staatskasse bekommt mehr Geld. Wer weiß, was die damit anstellen. Ich bin generell auch für diese Umverteilung, glaube nur, dass wenn wir jetzt einmal diese Brille aufziehen, die Branko Milanović uns reicht, dann geht es ja wirklich darum, dass es ja seinen Steckenpferd eben nicht wie Piketty Vermögen zu vergleichen, sondern Arbeitseinkommen zu vergleichen. Und diese Arbeitseinkommen im internationalen Vergleich bringen uns eigentlich in die Bredouille, wie eben schon angekündigt, dass wir uns davor fürchten, dass andere zu reich werden. Wir aber plötzlich auch nicht mehr so ganz einfach sagen können, naja, diese Superreichen, die haben diese unglaublichen Vermögensberge, da müssen wir mal ran. Sondern wir müssen auch, wenn wir in einem globalen Verhältnis sehen, eigentlich ganz hart nochmal uns selbst befragen, sind wir nicht im Grunde erbitterte Nationalisten? Dass wir sagen, oh Gott, bevor jetzt wirklich mehr Chinesen so reich sind wie reiche Westler, müssen wir irgendwas dagegen tun, weil ich möchte jetzt nicht plötzlich im Urlaub oder beim Ticketkauf für das nächste Taylor Swift Konzert oder so mit anderen Reichen noch konkurrieren, die dazugekommen sind. Beziehungsweise wir haben ja so viel darüber gesprochen, wo steht man wirtschaftlich, ist eine Frage von Relation. Und auch da zeigt er uns ja, dass wir mit unseren Reallöhnen in Deutschland mal ganz oben in der Welt standen und das höchste war, glaube ich, 1992. Und wie sich das alles jetzt relativiert, damit werden auch Produkte teurer. Die Frage ist also, wird man in zehn Jahren noch sich als Facharbeiter ein iPhone leisten können oder nicht mehr? Ist das dann einfach außer der Welt? Diese Fragen stellen sich da und womit ich nicht sagen will, wir vergessen jetzt die Vermögensungleichheit, aber ich glaube, wir müssen viel mehr den Fokus auf die Einkommen richten, weil man doch darüber noch mal mehr aussagen kann, als wenn man einfach nur sagt, ja, da gibt es Leute, die haben ganz, ganz viel Geld, aber dann kann man sich sehr schön aus der Gleichung rausnehmen.
Jetzt kommt ein Kicker-Argument, geradezu ein Stunt von mir. Ich habe ja bislang sehr, sehr, sehr häufig über Erbschaftssteuer geredet und eigentlich nie über Vermögenssteuer. Ich habe einmal über Vermögenssteuer geredet, als wir im Sommersalon darauf zu sprechen kamen, dass ja die Vermögenssteuer ausgesetzt wurde, als Veronica Grimm usw. und ich sagte, nee, nee, die wurde ausgesetzt, weil die Grundstück- und Immobilienpreise vom Verfassungsgericht damals als, nee, die müssen neu bewertet werden, die werden zum Teil Faktor 10 zu billig verrechnet. Ich finde, jetzt haben wir eine neue Grundsteuerreform, die jetzt auch juristisch durch ist, sozusagen durch das Verfassungsgericht. Also wir können jetzt durchaus sagen, wir haben jetzt wieder eine Bewertungsgrundlage. Also wir können die Vermögenssteuer wieder aktivieren. Aber Achtung, These, die Erbschaftssteuer ist eine Einkommenssteuer.
Inwiefern?
Derjenige, der das Erbe entgegen nimmt, verrechnet es bei sich als Einkommen.
Ja.
Und dann ist das ein Einkommenssteuersatz.
Könnte man so machen.
So. Und von daher, deine These, wir haben zu wenig über Einkommen und zu viel über Vermögen. Ich sage, nee, die Erbschaftssteuer war immer eine Einkommenssteuer. Also es ist immer eine Einkommenssache gewesen. Also sozusagen einfach nur im intergenerationalen Diskurs ist es halt eine Einkommensversteuerung.
Global Transformation ist ja erst mal ein Buch, das so klingt, als ginge es hier um Geopolitik, tut es auch. Aber es ist ein anderer Ansatz, nämlich sich auf die Zahlen zu konzentrieren bei den Einkommen. Wie haben sich da die Volkswirtschaften entwickelt? Wo sind sie gewachsen, gefallen? Es ist ein Mensch, Branko Milanović, der in Relationen denkt. Und wenn wir über Ungleichheit nachdenken, das muss man nochmal betonen, auch wenn es eine Binsenweisheit ist, ist es ja völlig klar, dass wir immer relational denken müssen. Bin ich genauso reich, wenn ich in BMW fahre und mein Nachbar hat ein BMW? Eigentlich könnte man sagen, oder wenn ich ein BMW fahre und mein Nachbar kann nur einen Golf fahren. Macht das einen Unterschied, weil ich fahre ja immer noch den BMW. Aber fühle ich mich ein bisschen besser, wenn das so ist, wenn es diese diese Clouff gibt. Und das ist eigentlich eine Kernfrage, die jetzt Branko Milanović aber nicht so anthropologisch aufmacht. Am Ende ein bisschen, das finde ich auch, da ist die einzige Schwäche im Buch. Aber er will tatsächlich das auf die einzelnen Nationen sehen. Fühlt man sich ein bisschen schlechter, wenn die anderen ein bisschen besser werden. Und wir hatten mal vor vielen, vielen Monaten einen Landsprecht-Podcast, da hatte Precht dieses Wort Subkutan, das sich in Deutschland viele als absteigend erleben. Also was einmal die Realität ist. Aber es ist so Subkutan etwas da, das hier etwas verrutscht in der gesamten Welt. Und dieses Subkutane, das Unterschwellige, wenn man so möchte, wird hier jetzt nach oben gespült von Branko Milanović, weil er die Statistiken zur Hand hat und sie lesen kann.
Ja, also schon der Einstieg ins Buch macht für mich als Neukunde von Branko Milanović, um die ökonomische Diktion gleich mal zu verwenden, also ich habe das erste Mal ein Buch von ihm gelesen. Und dann wird es ja gleich superdeutlich, man wird so ein bisschen an die Hand genommen. Achtung, Achtung, lieber Leser, hier geht es um das große Bild, der große rote Faden. Es gibt also drei globale Veränderungen, die ihr uns vorstellt. Produktion ist nach Asien gewandert, kennen wir soweit als Outsourcing die letzten Jahrzehnte. Sozusagen materielle Grundlage für jedes neoliberale Denken und politische Programm, das wir so haben. Und die asiatische Mittelklasse hat sich aber gesagt, ja, wir bleiben hier nicht nur Wertbank, wir innovieren selbst auch mit Hilfe, zum Beispiel der kommunistischen Partei, die sagte, wenn hier eine Firma kommt, die euch als Werkbank braucht, müssen die immer ein bisschen Research und Development mitbringen. Also gab es einen Aufstieg der asiatischen Mittelklasse, die durchaus in die Spitzenposition der westlichen Mittelklasse sind, wenn auch langsam und noch langfristig. Aber sie sind schon sichtbar und man muss auch immer wieder die Dimension sich klar machen. China ist 15 Mal so groß wie Deutschland. Also wenn da ein ganz wenige, ein ganz kleiner Teil aufsteigt, ist das schon ganz Bayern. Das sind dann nicht so einfach nur so 3 Millionen, sondern da kommen immer gleich so 30 Millionen. Ja. So 40 Millionen sind 3% Chinas. Also wenn man so hört, hört man ja auch später im Buch. Ja, so 3% verdienen jetzt mehr als das Medianeinkommen im Westen. Also 40 Millionen Leute, halt Deutschland. Ja. Das sind schon erstaunliche Veränderungen, die dann doch zu verrechnen sind. Und das hat Unzufriedenheit im Westen zur Folge, die zur politischen Verwerfung führt. Also eine Verknüpfung von drei globalen Veränderungen, die gar nicht zu entknüpfen sind, sondern nur noch zu erklären. Und daran setzt er ja an. Und nicht nur hat sich Marx geirrt damals oder würde heute eine Revision durchaus zustimmen, sondern er kommt auf sich selbst auch zu sprechen. Also er schaute damals und hat so Vergleiche gezogen. Das Ende des Sowjetreiches ist vergleichbar mit 1929 bis 1932, also der Krise im Westen, Kapitalismus, Schwarzer Freitag und so weiter. Und damals, er zieht diese Vergleiche und sagt ja, damals kam so ein bisschen Sozialismus in den Kapitalismus und heute wird ja wohl ein bisschen Kapitalismus in den Sozialismus kommen. Aber der ganze Ostblock einfach sagt, 100 Prozent Sozialismus finden wir blöd, wir machen jetzt 100 Prozent Kapitalismus. Davon war er auch überrascht.
Ja.
Also er zeigt sich hier ernüchtert, verknüpft das noch mit eigenen, ich habe mal jemandem ein Buch geschenkt, wo das drin stand und jetzt alles falsch, blöd.
So ein bisschen, ganz charmant eigentlich.
Jeffrey Sachs hat er getroffen in einem Buchladen, hat ihm dann erzählt, ja ich habe da auch ein Buch über den Zusammenbruch und sowas geschrieben und hat ihm dann ein Buch signiert und hat dort reingeschrieben, To Jeff, Who's Trying To Save Socialism Despite Itself. Und Jeff Sachs schaut ihn an und sagt, ja wie, ich bin doch dabei, da in den Ostblockstaaten zu sein, um den Kommunismus zu zerstören. Und die Idee von Branko Milanović ist, nee, nee, du bringst den so ein bisschen Kapitalismus bei. Und dann wird der Sozialismus auf Dauer gestellt. Dann wird er viel besser funktionieren, weil er tatsächlich in der Krise ist. Und das konnte er nicht ahnen, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, dass der Sozialismus aber dann einfach ad acta gelegt wird.
Warum ist das nicht einfach 50 bis 70 Prozent staatlicher Sektor in einer sozialistischen, also warum dimmt man nicht einfach ein bisschen Sozialismus?
Ja.
Also warum fährt man ihn auf Null? Wir haben kein gemischtes System vorgefunden. China wird immer ausgeklammert, aber spiel ja im Kalten Krieg auch eine andere Rolle als jetzt die beiden Mächte, die sich da gegenüber standen. Und ja, das finde ich sehr gut, dass ein Ökonom einfach sagt, ich hatte so eine Idee und die beschreibe ich euch mal kurz. Und dann kam die Realität. Ja. Das ist sehr groß und sehr ehrlich, finde ich, denn wie eben schon geschildert, man sitzt ja manchmal in Talkshows und mit Leuten, die einfach so Realität gar nicht sehen wollen. So und er beschreibt es eben auch, ne? Also George, also der alte HW. Bush, Michael Thatcher, Reagan, Bill Clinton. Also das geht dann auch über die Parteien hinweg. Da braucht man jetzt gar keine mal so, mal so, das Pendel schlägt hin und her, sondern ne. Das ist einfach ein Gleichschritt der Verkapitalisierung der Welt.
Ja, selbst die Infrastruktur hat man nicht mehr als Staatsaufgabe gesehen. Das kann man auch noch privatisieren. Und das ist nicht nur ein westliches Projekt, sondern 1991 beginnt der Neoliberalismus dann auch in Indien. Dort gibt es dann auch einen Anstieg des privaten Sektors. So ist es dann, dass irgendwann auch China diesem neoliberalen Projekt unterzogen werden soll. China wird ja in die World Trade Organization aufgenommen Anfang 2000. Aber in China entwickelt sich das anders. Darauf kommen wir dann gleich noch mal ausführlich zu sprechen. Jedenfalls hat man da erst einmal den Eindruck vom Westen aus, naja, die werden jetzt auch den Weg, den alle gehen, gehen. Nämlich alles nur noch privater Markt. Warum soll sich der Staat da einmischen? Wir bleiben ein schlanker Staat. Aber genau das ist nicht der Fall. Chinas Erfolg lässt sich eben nicht erklären mit einem neoliberalen Projekt. Beziehungsweise ja, der Neoliberalismus hat China zum Aufstieg deshalb verholfen, weil man hier das Mantra hatte, wir müssen outsourcen, wir müssen günstig produzieren. Eigentlich das, was St. Gerbert Steingart so vor 20, 25 Jahren auch immer gepredigt hat, bedeutete eine westliche Deindustrialisierung, die China sehr geholfen hat, Werkbank zu werten, sodass sehr viel erst einmal an Arbeit da war. Die Produktivität wurde gesteigert, die Waren wurden nachgefragt im Westen, sodass China einen Aufstieg gelang. Aber China ist interessanterweise nicht diesen Schritt mitgegangen, zu sagen, wir brauchen jetzt nur noch einen privaten Sektor, sondern die kommunistische Partei hat nach wie vor das Zeptern der Hand gehabt, ist mitunter ein bisschen losgelassen, aber dann mit Qi ändert sich das Rabiat.
Also diese Textstücke hier am Anfang, kann man eigentlich als direkte Antwort auf Gabor Steingart lesen.
Ja.
Es gibt die ideologische Trinität, Troika aus dieser waschigen Konsensus. Also wir gehen einfach ein und dann wird alles privatisiert und schön und gut.
Freihande.
Wir reduzieren die absolute Armut. Also wir kümmern uns, wenn überhaupt, nur um die Allerärmsten. Und für alle anderen erklären wir einfach Schutz durch Menschenrechte. Da wird aber kein richtiges Programm dran geknüpft, sondern einfach nur so ein dir steht der Rechtsweg offen, wenn du verprügelt wirst oder so. So und das reicht soweit um die, wenn das eben dieser zweite Erfolg des Neoliberellismus wie man schreibt, die Bereicherung der Eliten im Westen. Jetzt kommt aber China und sagt, wir sind nicht nur eure Werkbank im Sinne von Input Output. Also ihr schickt uns Rohmaterial und kriegt dann Wohlstand zurück, sondern ein bisschen Wohlstand bleibt bei uns. Aufstieg der Mittelschicht und so weiter. Was natürlich, wie er dann sagt, zu einem unvermeidlichen Ende des Neoliberellismus führt, diese Art Globalisierung, der natürlich dazu führt oder sich darin äußert, dass die über 40, 50 Jahre profitierenden Eliten des Westens plötzlich in diese Podcasts gehen und die ganze Zeit rumjammern. Ja. Das ist die ganze Erklärung.
Können wir bitte unsere gute alte Zeit wieder haben.
Kann ich bitte wieder haben, dass Leute einfach am Wochenende für mich arbeiten gehen und ich dann meinen Maibach kaufen kann? Ja.
Ja und wenn man das jetzt macht.
Und Leute am Bock auf Wohlstand. Und nicht auf Rente.
Ja. Also wenn man das mal paraffrasieren würde, diesen Podcast, oder wenn man ihn variieren würde. Wir haben da Gabor Steingart sitzen und er würde anfangen mit, ja das ist irgendwie schade, die Chinesen hören nicht mehr auf uns. Die haben das die ganze Zeit so billig produziert für uns. Und das hat doch so gut funktioniert.
Wie beschränken wir unsere Rohstoffe, die wir ja an die exportieren, damit die für uns Sachen draus bauen?
Jetzt machen die das nicht mehr. Können wir da mal einen anderen Kanzler wählen? Nee, Gabor, wir können ja gar nicht in China wählen. Wir sind ja hier in Deutschland. Wir können gar nicht Einfluss nehmen auf deren Politik jetzt. Ja, aber dann muss der Merz schuld sein. Nee, das geht einfach nicht.
Können wir mit den WHO was machen?
Die machen das jetzt in China einfach so. Ah ja, das heißt, wir bekommen hier einfach ein Buch auch aufgeführt. Also oder sagen wir es anders. Diese ganzen Podcasts, die du uns immer wieder vorführst, die Männer Podcasts, die gehen ja die ganze Zeit von wirklich dem handelnden Mann aus. Jetzt muss aber mal einer durchgreifen. Und Branko Milanović sagt uns die ganze Zeit, was wollt ihr denn jetzt hier machen? Was wollt ihr denn machen, wenn die zu Reichtum gekommen sind und nicht mehr für den billig Lohn das produzieren und einfach sagen, wir wollen gerne für euch arm bleiben. Danke, dass wir nicht mehr Hunger, Börche haben, aber mehr wollen wir jetzt nicht haben.
Ja, das ist natürlich eine echte missliche Lage für Leute, die sich dran gewöhnt haben.
Es ist ein Souveränitätsverlust.
Dass Sachen einfach nur laufen, aber sie laufen halt nicht mehr. Tut uns für diese Eliten wirklich leid, dass sie es selber nicht verstehen, aber sich ganzheit als die Wissenden bezeichnen, ist natürlich nur noch humorvoll zu verstehen. Und das Ziel dieses Buches ist nun uns dieses Ende des Neoliberalismus zu erklären. Es ist also genau das Buch, auf das wir gewartet haben.
Ja.
Denn es ist nicht einfach, der ehemalige Kanzler schreibt nochmal ein Buch über den Aufstieg Chinas, sondern, nein, nein, der Aufstieg Chinas hat auch was mit zu tun, aber es ist unser Ende.
Wir müssen uns jetzt über unser Ende mal aufklären, und dass die alten Rezepte, und vor allem das herbeige Jammerre von alten Rezepten, vielleicht nicht mehr funktioniert. Und da kriegen wir hier einfach dieses Buch her. Also, der Aufstieg Chinas und der Erfolg der Eliten im Westen, das war mein Thema. Und das kann man hier auch historisch noch mal beschreiben, aber das ist nicht die Zukunft, auf die wir jetzt setzen können.
Ja. Und nicht nur China, Indonesien ist zu nennen, Vietnam. Also dort gibt es allgemeine Aufstiegsentwicklungen, die ganz erheblich sind, die dann aber bedeuten, Thailand wäre noch zu nennen, Indien sowieso. Wo man also sagen kann, das verschiebt jetzt den Reichtum in der Welt so stark wie damals die erste Industrialisierung. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt wirklich eine Neuordnung der Welt. Und das sieht man, wenn man sich Einkommen ansieht. Wenn man global guckt, wo wird was verdient, dann kann man sehen, wo entsteht eine Elite. Da muss man gar nicht anfangen mit, wie fühlen die sich gerade, sondern die Zahlen sagen es.
Es sind wirklich große Zäsuren, die er hier markiert. 1929 bis 31, der Fall der Mauer und jetzt das Ende des Neoliberalismus. Wir haben zwar nicht so ein historisches Datum im Sinne von, das war dieser schwarze Börsenfreitag oder ja ja, 9. November, die Grenze war offen. Das macht es ein bisschen schwer fassbar. Deswegen kommt er ja mit diesen Zahlen, also in den Statistiken ist es zu sehen. Nur eine Statistik. Also das war auch, ne, diese Proante kann ich nicht erzählen. Das wäre zu indiskret. Aber bei Lanz sind auch wieder Sachen vorgefallen, mit den Gästen, die so ein bisschen kreuz und quer waren. Wenn mal jemand Zahlen auf den Tisch legt. Also ich meine jetzt so ausgedruckte Zahlen, Statistiken einfach. Es gibt so Leute wie, ja ja, das sind ja meine Zahlen, habe ich in meinem Institut gemacht. Und dann gibt es halt Leute, die, das ist ja interessant.
Ja.
Die das erste Mal überhaupt solche Zahlen sehen. Ja und dann fragen, darf ich die mit nach Hause nehmen? Aber wie gesagt, ich will nicht in das Gezeichen, ich nenne dir zumindest keine Namen. Und ja.
Dagegen hat man eine Revolution, du hast es schon angedeutet, also was dann stattgefunden hat, und das ist in der Einleitung schon mal von ihm benannt. Es gibt dann gegen diese neoliberale Elite, die wunderbar jetzt profitiert hat von all dem, so bis 2016, im Westen zumindest, gibt es dann plötzlich Gegner genau dessen, und zwar aus der Bevölkerung, die davon nichts mitbekommen hat. Du hast schon über die Reallöhne gesprochen. Und diese Elite bekommt plötzlich eine Konkurrenz, nicht aus dem Volke direkt, sondern wiederum aus der Elite. Also Figuren, die eigentlich schon zur Elite gehören, wenden sich gegen die Elite. Und da sagt er, in the case of Trump, the counter narrative is directed against the liberal and cosmopolitan establishment. In the case of Xi Jinping, it is directed against the nouveau riche. Who have infiltrated the party.
Also Korruption und so.
And in the case of Putin, it is directed against the oligarchs, who have tried to control the state.
Genau, das ist erst mal counter intuitive. Aber man muss es historisch verstehen. Als Putin kam, waren die Oligarchen eine große Gefahr, weil sie das direkt übernommen hätten. Also hat man jemanden genommen, der so ein bisschen einhegen kann, dass Putin die selber nutzt als Machtabsicherung. Das wissen wir heute.
Wie Trump die Elite nutzt, gegen die er angeblich angetreten ist. Er hat ja immer gesagt, Hollywood, Silicon Valley, das sind diese liberalen Wurken. Jetzt muss er halt die unter Kontrolle bringen und dann werden irgendwann Trump Hollywood-Filme produziert.
Von daher, lieber Herr Gabor Steingart, Vorsicht bei Wünschen nach jemandem, der mal was wieder geregelt kriegt. Ja, es könnte sein, dass du selber das erste Opfer bist, obwohl du ihn mit hofiert hast. Putin wurde auch von den Oligarchen hofiert, bis sie gemerkt haben, wie der Rodorowski, also der Reichste von uns, ist jetzt im Gefängnis. So, es kann nach hinten losgehen.
Und jetzt bezogen auf China ist das, die korrupten Funktionäre werden entmachtet und die bekommen Prozesse gemacht. Und die CEOs, Jack Ma oder so, werden einfach mal weggepackt für eine Zeit, um den anderen auch damit zu zeigen. Hört darauf. Und dann betont am Ende dieser Einleitung Milanović noch, wir sehen dieses Muster überall auf der Welt. Also es ist jetzt so, dass er sich auf die drei konzentriert, aber er sagt, das ist überall. Er sagt, Nationalismus ist jetzt das, was die Innenpolitik prägt. Und eine Narrative von die Politik muss tougher sein. Also das, was wir jetzt eben bei Steingart gehört haben, ist etwas, was absolut jetzt präsent ist und dass die Nation verteidigt werden muss. Nicht nur eine Gruppe, sondern so allgemein die Nation, dass das jetzt das Vokabular geworden ist. Und ich denke, da können wir natürlich alle Parallelen zu Deutschland dann auch finden, ohne dass wir einen Trump haben.
Ja, also Gabor Steingart kann das eigentliche, das ist das eigentliche Ziel, was er hat, nämlich bitte habt Bock auf Arbeit für meinen Wohlstand. Das kann man nur hinter Nationalismus verstecken.
Ja.
Wir sitzen noch alle in einem Boot, das ist unser Schicksal, Deutschland war mal gut, jetzt nicht mehr und so weiter, Deutschland, Deutschland, Deutschland. Zu was Nationalismus führt, wissen wir, wenn man es dann ein bisschen übertreibt. Und die Gefahren, also wenn man so ein Buch hier liest, denkt man sich so, nee, bitte lass Gabor Steingart jetzt nichts zum Führer sagen. Und dann kommt aber wirklich das Schlimmste Mögliche zum Führer von ihm so. Also man sollte wirklich schottiert und alarmiert sein.
Ich habe gerade den neuen Stromberg-Film gesehen, da sagt Lars Klingweih, vielleicht braucht die SPD ein Stromberg.
Ich habe den Film nicht gesehen.
Bin ich auch schon zusammengezogen. Der Film ist sehr schlecht im Vergleich zu der Serie. Es ist nämlich genau jetzt auch so ein komischer Kult.
Man sollte sowieso nicht versuchen, sowas immer zu verdichten in einem Film, was wirklich nur auf Langstrecke funktioniert. Als Running Gag an Running Gag. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man in 90 Minuten einen Running Gag erzählen will.
Es gelingt ja auch nicht.
Bescheuert. So, Kapitel 1. China. Es ist China gewidmet. China ist die zweite Welt. Die erste Welt hat es also geschafft, mit 21 Prozent Weltbevölkerung 62 Prozent des BIP auf sich zu vereinen. Da war China immer nur zweite Wahl. Die UDSSR, die ja vergleichsweise noch ranzieht, ist auch witzig. Also wir haben ja alle noch im Ohr, wie Obama sagte, das eine Regionalmacht. Er sagt hier, ja, also zwei Prozent der Weltbevölkerung, die drei Prozent des BIP-Erwirtschaften sind, eher so ein Beobachter des Geschehens. Ist auch nicht schlecht.
Also wir reden hier vom Jahr 1974.
Ja, also relativ früh, als das alles losgeht, die Welt nach 45 und der Westen. Bis zur globalen Finanzkrise 2008, schreibt er ganz explizit, finde ich auch eine interessante Zäsur. Wir fragen uns ja immer, wenn es losgeht. Also in der Land-Sendung der Herr Peichler diesen Text geschrieben, 1983. Der kommt auch viel auf das Jahr 74 zu sprechen, als so ein Wendepunkt. Und das Forschungsvorhaben ist dann 83 bis 2020 und die Lohnentwicklung. Bis dahin wurde das volksverstärftliche Wachstum in den Löhnen verrechnet. Es gab gar keine überbordende Kapitalerträge, die man dann irgendwie und so. Und das finde ich immer interessant, weil wir jetzt immer kritisieren, dass ja alle DAX-Konzerne zwischen 1870 und 1880 gegründet wurden. Das heißt, 100 Jahre lang hat das eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert, was die relativen Wachstumsfahder und so weiter rückblickend, wünscht sich natürlich keiner die Zeit zurück. Aber es hat irgendwie 100 Jahre relativ stabil funktioniert. Und dann kam plötzlich dieser Washington-Konsensus und überhaupt wollen wir nicht mal hier und so. Und dann wurde plötzlich das volkswirtschaftliche Wachstum in Kapital und Arbeit unterschieden, also relativ spät sozusagen. Und hat innerhalb von 50 Jahren jetzt zu dieser Katastrophe geführt, dass Demokratie wieder zur Rede steht, dass in irgendwelchen Podcasts irgendwelche Leute, die sich nicht so richtig daran erinnern, was in ihren Geschichtsbüchern steht, wieder vom Führer reden. Und lauter solche Sachen, das hat nur 50 Jahre gedauert. Aber eben diese 50 Jahre, die die Babyboomer noch mal die Volkswirtschaft verdoppelt haben, also der Leidensdruck bei Gabor Steingart und seinen Kumpels, der ist wirklich groß.
Ja, er hat ja dann eine Kurve, die er uns da präsentiert und zeigt, wie war das eigentlich zwischen diesen Jahren 64 und 79. Da konnte man in den USA noch sehen, dass also unglaublich viel erwirtschaftet wurde von den unteren Perzentilen. Also nicht erwirtschaftet, das ist jetzt falsch, also per capita growth rate. Die war da hoch. Aber was passiert eigentlich dann mit dem Aufkommen des Neoliberalismus? Und von 79 bis 2019 gibt es unglaubliche Zuwächse bei der Elite. Nach oben, also das oberste Deziel, das schießt nach oben. Aber bei den anderen, da bewegt sich kaum noch etwas. Und das geht eben auf Kosten derer, die dort unten stehen.
Zu diesen Grundbegriffen, ich glaube, da sind die Perzentile gemeint, also noch die Einteilung der 10-Prozent-Blöcke immer. Wo man so eine hockeystickartige bis 90 Prozent ist, alles okay. Und dann nähert man sich so dem letzten 1 Prozent und dann geht die Kurve noch gerade nach oben.
Ja, ja, the top 1 percent benefited enormously from neoliberal policies. It is also noticeable that all income groups except the top percentile had higher real growth in the first period than in the second. Das heißt, für die Menschen 64 bis 79 lief es gut für die meisten, aber das ändert sich dann.
Und hier ist es einfach ganz wichtig, jetzt zu verstehen, es gibt nur eine Welt, eine Volkswirtschaft. Dieses Wachstum in diesem oberen Bereich geht, weil es gar nicht anders geht, nur auf Kosten der anderen Teile der Gesellschaft. Ja, also der Superreichtum hängt direkt zusammen mit der Verarmung in der gleichen Verrechnungseinheit. Und es ist ja hier auf jeden Fall der Nationalstaat, wenn so ein bisschen der Westen, aber in Amerika ist es einfach der Nationalstaat. Also die haben sich selber in diese Lage gebracht und so ausgezehrt.
Ja, und es war dann eine Bewegung, bei der man sich fragte in den 80er Jahren, hätte man dagegen etwas tun können. François Mitterrand wird gewählt, auch auf einem sozialistischen Ticket ist er da unterwegs, aber er führt die entsprechenden Reformen nicht durch. Auch sonst werden sie nicht durchgeführt. Also gegen diese neoliberale Tendenz. Das ist eigentlich das, was vorherrschend ist.
Und wer sich jetzt fragt, was ist denn nun jetzt so langsam mit China? Der Maoismus, der muss doch wichtig gewesen sein. Und da gibt es dann nur so in einem Absatz von ihm zu hören, ja der Maoismus in Peru und Kambodscha, hat er mal eine Rolle gespielt. Und sonst war das höchstens was, wenn man eine Freundin suchte und in einem Pariser Café war in den 70er Jahren, dann hatte man Glück, wenn man sich da mit dem Maoismus auskannte. Sonst spielte der keine Rolle.
So, dann die Zeit schreitet voran. 74, hier nochmal Portugal demokratisiert sich. Das wird ja auch immer gerne übersehen. Ich war auch überrascht, aber in Portugal mit dieser Rosenrevolution und so, das hat ja wirklich wahnsinnig lang gedauert, 74. Also es ist noch zu Lebzeiten aller, die gerade so das Straßenbild prägen. Und er hat sehr interessante Grafiken im Sinne einer Tabelle hier, wann Länder national im internationalen Vergleich ihren relativen Peak am Einkommen hatten. Und es ist super interessant, denn United States 1952. Also 1952 war der Peak Amerikas, seitdem holt die Welt wieder ein bisschen auf. Langsam aber stetig. Thailand, Bhutan, Kambodscha, Indien 2018, 2019, Malaysia auch, Myanmar, Indonesien. Also wir sehen schon, es ist nicht nur China. China 2022, Deutschland und der Rest Europas. So ungefähr immer 1992, Japan 92, Italien 95, Österreich so 99, Frankreich 2001, aber im Grunde auch jetzt 20 Jahre her.
Also das ist genau der Punkt, an dem quasi Deutschland 1992 so richtig fett dasteht im Vergleich zur anderen Welt. Und dann 1993, 94 bis heute sieht man dann, ach so dieser Nachbar, der hat jetzt auch das teure Auto und der hat das teure Auto. Warum bekomme ich eigentlich keinen Werkstatttermin mehr mit meinem Auto? Ach, ich kann mir das neue Auto gar nicht mehr leisten. Das ist also der Punkt. Das heißt, es ist nicht eine Verarmung in dem Sinne, die stattfindet, sondern in der Relation. Und in der Relation zu denken ist so schwer eigentlich. Man kann sich immer so einen Spotmoney blicken und sagen, so viel ist da.
Du hast ja eben schon die Ticketpreise genannt, da sieht man es. Auch bei der Frage, warum macht der FC Bayern in Shanghai ein Fußballspiel? Weil da die neuen Kunden des FC Bayern sind. Und umso reicher die werden, umso häufiger wollen die den FC Bayern sehen. Also es werden zunehmend Heimspiele in München ausfallen, damit die einfach in Shanghai und Peking und so stattfinden werden. Weil die NFL so ein bisschen hierher kommt und so, weil Amerika hat doch nicht mehr. Man braucht aber so die westliche Welt. Also nehmen wir so ein bisschen Deutschland.
Doppelter Kartenpreis dort. Fertig.
Das ist auch die Frage, wenn jetzt Taylor Swift in Singapur spielt, wer fährt dahin? Kriegt man weiterhin Instagram-Videos von lauter Europäern, die sich aufmachen, weil sie da noch ein Ticket gekriegt haben in der weltweiten Lotterie? Oder sehen wir demnächst, ja, ich war jetzt in Gelzen Kirchen bei Taylor Swift, nur Japaner. Also Japaner auch nicht, aber so die Malaysianer, Myanmarer, Indonesierer, Singapur, Bangladesch und so. Das sind die dann einfach so. Und da sieht man an solchen Jahreszahlen, wenn man sich, also wenn man mich jetzt gefragt hätte, ein Buch über Ökonomie, bei der sich, bei der so Sachen erklärt werden müssen. Ich wäre nie auf so eine Tabelle gekommen, wann war in Ländern das Peak Einkommen im Verhältnis zum Rest der Welt und so. Aber es ist dann mal so zu sehen, es ist sozusagen doppelt überraschend in der Form und im Inhalt.
Das zeigt sich ja auch in dieser Grafik davor auf Seite 15. Wir hatten ja eben gesagt, China spielte 1974 keine Rolle. Riesenbevölkerung, aber nur 2% zum Worldbip beigetragen. Das ist 2022 anders. Da macht die Population 19% aus, also in der Welt. Aber die Produktivität, also GDP, BIP, 22% da. Das heißt, es gab dann plus von 20% Punkten. Und somit ist aber dann auch, weil wir das ja wieder in Relationen sehen müssen, der Westen nicht mehr bei der GDP-Rate von 62% global, sondern nur noch bei 44%.
Also man geht ernsthaft ab. Nachher kommen noch diese Dezile, die Dezile-Argumentation. Da musste ich auch erst bei GPT nachfragen, wie meint er das hier? Ich hab's erst gar nicht verstanden. Hier noch ein anderer Wert. Er nimmt mal Italien jetzt explizit. Also wenn wir lesen, Italien hatte 1995 seinen Höhepunkt im Verhältnis Land-Innen-Einkommen zu Rest-der-Welt-Einkommen. Dann wird es hier nochmal aufgeschlüsselt bei ihm. 1995 dieser Höhepunkt. Ein Italiener verdient das 3,5-Fache im Vergleich zum globalen Durchschnittsarbeiter. Es hat 40 Jahre gedauert, um Italien von 1,8-Fach auf 3,5-Fach diesen Peak zu bringen. Heute, nicht 40 Jahre später, nach 1995, sondern so 30, sind die schon wieder bei 2,2 angekommen. So, 2,2 ist immer noch mehr als doppelt so viel wie weltweit. Aber, also hier ist ja absehbar. Wenn das so Tendenzen sind, kann man ja wirklich irgendwann sehen, wann einfach völlig klar ist, in der Toskana rennen demnächst Malasianer rum.
Ja.
Und dann können sich die Italiener beschweren darüber, dass hier zu viel Tourismus ist, so wie jetzt in Sevilla und so schon die Leute verprügelt werden, wenn sie durch irgendwelche Schmallengassen gehen und kein Einwohner da mehr durchkommt.
Ja. Und die können dann nicht mehr sich ein Eis leisten.
Genau. Die stehen dann daneben in der eigenen Straße und die Touristen kaufen einfach ein Abendessen für 150 Dollar. Und zahlen vielleicht auch noch einen Dollar.
Wie wir das jetzt machen.
So wie wir das auch machen. Ja.
Wir gehen irgendwo hin.
Wir sind in Thailand und räumen das Land da leer. Ja. Die United States im Decline. Er macht das noch als Fragezeichen. Er beginnt relativ skeptisch und ich muss sagen, ja. All das, was wir jetzt besprochen haben, gilt so für Amerika. Also der Peak 1953 ist natürlich irre. Aber stetig, wenn auch langsamer als man denkt, passiert es. Und dann webt er immer in die, ja, Amerika geht unter, das Imperium stürzt in sich zusammen, aber ganz langsam, viel langsamer als ihr glaubt sozusagen. Und webt dann da immer wieder diese qualitativen Argumente ein, wie Amerika hat 750 militärische Stützpunkte in 80 Ländern. China nur drei.
Ja.
Russland auch nur drei. China hat gar keine Verbündeten formal. Russland hat Belarus. Amerika hat die NATO. Die NATO ist ums Doppelte gewachsen in den letzten 30 Jahren. Und so weiter und so fort. Also es gibt auch immer wieder eine qualitative Ebene neben diesem Zahlensalat, den wir serviert bekommen, der einen so ein bisschen nachdenklich macht. Was bedeutet es, wenn die volkswirtschaftliche Bedeutung Amerikas schrumpft, aber der Militärhaushalt wächst? Das könnte man ja mal fragen.
Genau. Und die können wir auch beantworten. Dann sieht das eher danach aus, dass das dann kriegerisch gelöst wird, weil man es volkswirtschaftlich nicht hinbekommt.
Genau. Dann sitzt man in Venezuela und ballert auf irgendwelche Schiffe.
Ja. Er fragt, Wann werden die absoluten Zahl der chinesischen Menschen mit dem Einkommen oder höher als das US-Medien-Einkommen die gleiche Zahl der amerikanischen Menschen sein? Wann stehen also mehr reiche Chinesen oder wohlhabende Chinesen den Amerikanern direkt gegenüber? Wird man das verzeihen? Wird man das aushalten? Und selbst wenn die Wirtschaft genauso weiter brummt in den USA, wenn China entsprechend aufholt und zwar nicht zwei Prozent pro Jahr wächst, wie manche prognostizieren, sondern bei vier Prozent ist, dann geht das natürlich schneller. Wird man das aufholen können? Und das bedeutet dann, dass wir also in 15 oder 20 Jahren plötzlich ein ökonomisch so mächtiges China haben, dass dann eigentlich den USA nur noch die Militärstation bleiben, um Macht zu demonstrieren.
Jetzt habe ich hier noch einen Punkt. Es geht also in diesem Kapitel um Amerika.
Ja.
Und hier werden zwei Fakten genannt, bei denen wir uns jetzt fragen müssen, da wir den Autor sehr schätzen und einfach sagen, die Wahrheiten, die er schreibt, sind ja auch so ein bisschen unhintergehbar. Und trotzdem wollen wir ja Realität erklärt haben. Und manchmal ist man sich ja so unschlüssig, was ist jetzt eigentlich, also wer hat so ein kleines Defizit? Ist einfach die Realität unendlich dom oder hat der Autor was übersehen? Und hier können wir ja sagen, okay, wir haben es ja mit dem Autor zu tun, der absolut ernst zu nehmen ist. Und er schreibt also jetzt über die 750 Stützpunkte der Amerikaner, während die China so gar keine offiziellen Verbündeten haben, die Russen so ein. Und da ist also ein Ungleichgewicht. Amerika ist viel größer, als wir es jetzt volkswirtschaftlich so verrechnen. Einfach weil wir so einen Militärhaushalt ein bisschen anders verbuchen müssen, als jetzt, was weiß ich. So. Und das Kapitel zu diesen, die Verbündeten, die großen Netzwerke und so, endet dann unten mit so einem Argument, wo er schreibt, kann man schließlich von einem Rückgang sprechen, wenn die Bevölkerung der USA jährlich um 0,6 Prozent wächst und Millionen von Einwanderern anzieht, von denen angeblich 15 Millionen ohne Papiere im Land leben. So, jetzt haben wir aber eine Nachrichtenlage, die sagt, Amerika selbst baut gerade die globalen Netzwerke aus, die hier als das wichtigste Fundament überhaupt beschrieben werden. Und Amerika schmeißt auch gerade tatsächlich diese 15 Millionen Menschen aus dem Land. Also die Kirstin Nohms hat gestern sechs Boings geordert, damit die amerikanische Regierung selber Abflüge machen kann und nicht länger Charterflüge machen muss. Also ein bislang privatwirtschaftlich organisiertes Ding wird jetzt einfach richtig in politische Obhut genommen. Und das widerspricht natürlich, also da ist einfach die Realität so dumm, dass die Aussage des Autoren, die wir ja als total plausibel ansehen, nicht mehr passen würden. Im Sinne von, und deswegen leite ich diese und jene Wachstums- oder Schrumpfungsentwicklung in Amerika ab, wenn wir sehen, dass ein halbes Jahr Donald Trump sowohl bei der internationalen Verflechtung als auch bei den Migranten im Land einfach wirkliche Zäsuren macht.
Also das werden wir ja, hier wäre es ja wirklich super interessant, wenn Branko Milanović einfach ein Podcast hätte, um sozusagen nicht, ich habe letztes Jahr mal ein Buch geschrieben, da war aber Trump noch Ankündigung und heute mal so Updates liefert zum Thema. Nee, meine Zahlen sind schon richtig. Also wenn die Amerikaner bei dieser Entwicklung jetzt auf die Migration im eigenen Land als Arbeitskräftepotenzial und die internationale Verflechtung als Sicherheit, wenn sie das selber rausnehmen, dann muss ich alle meine Zahlen ein bisschen anpassen. Also hier werden wir wirklich eingeholt von einer Realität, die, das muss man halt sagen, wirklich wahnsinnig dumm ist. Also wenn man sowas hier liest, denkt man sich so, das kann Trump doch, also irgendwer muss doch mitgedacht haben.
Naja, was man ja da vielleicht sehen kann, ist, dass das ein widerstreitendes System ist, innerhalb des, also widerstreitendes insofern, als wir ja eigentlich erwarten könnten, wenn man China als den Systemrivalen ansieht, muss man die Zahlen von Branko Milanović kennen. Heißt, man muss sagen, wir brauchen mehr Migration, denn die Chinesen, die wachsen ja nicht so richtig. Diese Ein-Kind-Politik, da kommen die nicht mehr von los und wir brauchen mehr BIP-Wachstum, um diesen Kampf aufnehmen zu können. Das wäre ja die Rationalität. Aber der Erfolg von Trump beruht ja eigentlich darauf, zu sagen, ich verspreche euch nochmal den starken Nationalstaat, der natürlich alle abschiebt, die hier nichts verloren haben. Also auch die, die wir eigentlich wirtschaftlich brauchen könnten, aber aus ideologischen Gründen mache ich das. Und da schlägt dann die Ideologie das, was eigentlich programmatisch sinnvoll wäre, also eben im Sinne der US-amerikanischen Interessen. Aber wir können ja eigentlich so etwas auch für China erleben. Denn das ist ja auch was, wo Milanović rätselnd davor steht. Und ich habe auch wirklich noch nirgends eine gute Antwort darauf bekommen. Wie konnte man eigentlich eine solch repressive Lockdown-Politik rechtfertigen in China, bei der China sich ja arg verletzt hat, was die wirtschaftlichen Ambitionen anbelangt? Eigentlich hätte man ja eher in dem Kalkül, wir müssen schneller wachsen, um die USA zu überholen, sagen müssen, na ja, wir nehmen das jetzt bald nicht mehr alles so eng, geht wegen mir mit Maske arbeiten, aber ihr müsst arbeiten, wir brauchen Produktivität. Und das war ja auch eine Politik, die sich ja eigentlich dieser Rationalität verweigert hat.
Gut, aber das, also ja, diese Fragen sind da und die, finde ich, beantwortet der Text wunderbar. Es wird ja Xi zitiert, wie er damals diese Rede hält, längst bevor er Parteichef wurde, wo er sagt, das größte Problem der Sowjetunion, ihr Untergang und warum danach nichts weiter geschah, außer so ein...
War, dass sie keine Ideologie hat.
Genau, dass sie einfach keine Idee haben. So, diese Einheit Chinas, die Xi so wichtig ist und die Kontrolle der Bevölkerung übertrumpfen eben das wirtschaftliche Wachstum.
So, aber dann hast du doch die Antwort hier gegeben für die USA.
Ja genau, wenn das so stimmt, muss man sagen, die amerikanische Regierung, der wir gerade immer Dummheit unterstellen, hat eine Ideologie, die anders als Xi, der sie nämlich zu Nutzen weiß, in die Irre führt. Denn es ist ja nicht so, dass Trump gerade in den Umfragewerten besonders gut dasteht. Und die New York Times hat gestern einen Podcast zum Thema gemacht. Ist das nicht ungewöhnlich früh, dass wir jetzt schon von der Lame Duck reden?
Ja, aber das ist ja bedingt durch die Heterogenität, die das republikanische System mit sich bringt, beziehungsweise eine doch vorhandene Demokratie mit sich bringt, während China das viel mehr auf Linie gebracht werden kann. Und wir nicht eine Presse haben, die da so drüber berichtet, ist China Lame Duck. Nee, das gibt es halt nicht.
Vor allem meine Verwunderung nochmal, ich sage es nochmal so ganz explizit, weil ich es auch wirklich bemerkenswert finde, während wir sonst immer sagen, der Sachbuchautor sollte sich schon ein bisschen an die Realität anpassen und uns versuchen zu erklären, was da vor sich geht. Muss man diesmal sagen, es ist so plausibel, was der Autor schreibt, dass man einfach das eigene Urteil über die Realität revidieren muss. Das in Amerika, was jetzt gerade stattfindet, ist noch viel dümmer, als wir immer dachten. Und wir haben schon eingepreist durch Texte von der Zentralbank in Dallas für Texas und so weiter, dass die da gerade auf 10 Billionen volkswirtschaftliches Vermögen verzichten durch diese Migrationspolitik, die sie gerade einfach nur ideologisch erdulden. Aber hier ist noch mal zu sehen, wie schrecklich bescheuert es wirklich ist. Also man wüsste gar nicht, wie ein Gabriel-Steingart-Podcast aussehen sollte, der sich mal mit einer ernsthaften Kritik vor Ort mit so einer Trump-Regierung befasst. Auch diese Zahlen, es ist ja wirklich wahnsinnig beeindruckt. Also Amerika hat ein Medianeinkommen, das heute 4,6 Mal über einem chinesischen Einkommen liegt. Also im Sinne von Mediane ist ja jetzt natürlich Aussage über alles. Also das amerikanische Medianeinkommen liegt 4,6 Mal über dem chinesischen Medianeinkommen. 1988 war das Verhältnis nicht 1 zu 4,6, also 1 zu 5, sondern 1 zu 18. Das sind doch rasante Entwicklungen und wenn hier im Text dann weiterstellt und jetzt kommt diese Zahl, die ich so beeindruckend finde, etwa 3% der Chinesen haben ein Einkommen, das über dem US-Mediane liegt. Nur 3% sind eben 40 Millionen. In Amerika gibt es überhaupt nur 150, 160 Millionen, die Arbeitseinkommen haben. Mit kleinsten, relativen Veränderungen, also wirklich nur kleine Teile des chinesischen Arbeitsmarkts, verändern sich einfach und Amerika wird einfach in den Schatten gestellt. Also wirklich beeindruckend. Beeindruckend zu sehen, solche Zahlen und die sind einfach unhintergehbar. Also hier muss einfach, hieran zerbricht eine politische Realität, wie wir sie in irgendwelchen Wortlauten, Sicherheitsstrategie, hier wird gar nicht erklärt, keine Pressekonferenz, kein Nichts. So zerbricht komplett an solchen Zahlenwerken, wie wir sie hier sehen.
Ja und da die USA noch so weit oben sind, also sie sind im 93. globalen Perzentil mit dem Medianeinkommen. Das heißt also, während Medianeinkommen...
Das ist jetzt das D-Ziel.
Ne, also 93. globalen Perzentil. D-Ziel meint ja 10er-Schritte und Perzentil meint ja 1er-Schritte.
Aber dieser 93%-Wert, das habe ich gestern noch mal angeschaut, heißt, 93% der Weltbevölkerung sind schlechter dran als du.
Genau.
Das ist die Aussage.
Da sind die auf dem 93. Das heißt, es gibt dann noch 7 drüber, aber nicht Nationen, sondern es gibt eben reichere Leute. Aber das heißt, wenn du jetzt ein Medianeinkommen beziehst in den USA, dann gehörst du immer noch zu den Top 10, ja, global betrachtet. Aber wenn wir jetzt diesen rasanten Aufstieg Chinas sehen und andere asiatische Länder, ist die Frage, wie schnell klettert das weiter nach unten und dann hat sich das ganz schnell erübrigt mit den Top 10%.
Da muss sich in Amerika gar nicht viel verändern. Allein die Veränderung im Rest der Welt führt einfach dazu, dass in einer global vernetzten Wirtschaft relativ viele Annehmlichkeiten nicht mehr auf Amerika ausgerichtet sind. Ja. Dann gehen die billigen chinesischen Weihnachtsgeschenke einfach in eine andere Region der Welt. Und dann sitzen die auf dem Trockenen.
Und natürlich auch für Kapitalmarkt und sowas wird das dann viel interessanter.
Ja, es gibt ganz viele Finanzströme, die damit zu tun haben. Aber China ist immer noch Generationen hinterher. Also eine Generation oder eine und eine halbe wird diese Aufholjagd von Ost zu West schon noch brauchen. Wenn man jetzt den Osten mit den OECD-Ländern, zu denen wir ja auch gehören, ist ja natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr Schwungmasse. Und wir glauben ja auch, dass wir es in Europa ein bisschen besser machen als die Chinesen. Aber solange wir nur Gabor Steingarts Podcasts hören, ist das natürlich in Gefahr, dass der Wissende Friedrich Merz uns hier auch noch die Scheiße reitet. Nur gut, also diesen China-Effekt gibt es. Er ist in Zahlen ausgedrückt crazy. Dauert aber noch Generation oder eine und eine halbe, bis da Angleichungen da sind, so das, ja, weiß man gar nicht genau, wie sie in der Welt aussieht, in der China und Amerika dann wirklich auf Augenhöhe miteinander spielen.
Ja, aber es gibt einen generellen Abstieg schon zu sehen. Und zwar nicht immer nur bei dem Medianeinkommen oder bei den bei den Reichsten ist es zu beobachten. Er schaut sich dann zum Beispiel Deutschland an und sagt, das unterste Ziel, also die untersten zehn Prozent, die waren global gesehen immer noch so gut, dass 81 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung unter ihnen waren. Ja, also wenn du wirklich richtig arm dran warst in Deutschland, dann warst du immer noch auf der auf der Gewinnerseite, wenn man so möchte. Ja, also mit den Einkommen da verglichen. Das, Entschuldigung, ich habe ja genau, das war 1993. Ja, deutsche Peak. Jetzt aber 2018, da hat er eine Zahl, sind nur noch 75 Prozent der Weltbevölkerung unter einem, wenn man ganz unten angelangt ist. Also auch aus dieser Perspektive.
Das sind schon Milliarden Menschen. Besser dran als du.
Ja.
Ja, das ist der westliche Abstieg. Dieses Afrika-Kapitel, also was heißt Kapitel, er thematisiert Afrika. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht, ich dachte, es steht besser.
Aber, erstaunlich, ne, das da.
Da ist zwar trotz Bevölkerungswachstum von 1,5 auf 4,5 Milliarden Menschen, das noch zu erwarten ist, relativ wenig los. Und er kommt dann auf Äthiopien als den einen Ausreißer. Aber selbst da, ja, da geht es dann so ein bisschen besser. Und dann kam doch wieder Bürgerkrieg und die Abspaltung Eritrea und, ja, das ist schon dramatisch. Da bin ich sehr gespannt. Er nimmt ja jetzt so Zäsuren, die man nicht wirklich voraus, also klar, die kann man irgendwie so, irgendwann wird es passieren. Und dann, wie es geschieht, weiß man nicht. Aber er ist ja auch davon überrascht gewesen. Okay, es war ersichtlich, dass die Sowjetunion es nicht standhält. Aber wie danach sich die Länder verändert haben und in welcher Geschwindigkeit fand er überraschend. Und ich denke mir, allein die Wachstumsraten in der Bevölkerung afrikanischer Länder zu sehen, müsste eigentlich jemand wie Branko Milanović sagen, alles, was ich hier an Prognosen mache, ist mit Vorsicht zu genießen. Weil wir wissen einfach nicht, welche Schwellen hier überstritten werden und wann hier irgendwelche Kipppunkte oder wie auch immer. Ja. Und in der Ansicht, ja, das liest sich alles nicht sehr vorteilhaft für Afrika. Also es wird einfach grundsätzlich keine Rolle spielen, auch in 100 Jahren nicht und so, sagt er. Aber mal sehen, würde ich sagen. Also ich bin nur ein bisschen, ja, wer weiß.
Schwer anzuschätzen. Dann im nächsten Kapitel liefert er eigentlich so eine Ideengeschichte. Er fragt sich nämlich etwas ganz Simples. Durch Freihandel wird da die Welt friedlicher oder wird sie kriegerischer? Und da geht er verschiedene Ansätze durch.
Wo wir doch bisher so entschieden waren bei der Frage.
Ja.
Wandel durch Handel und ja. Aber er macht das so auf eine Frage.
Und wirklich ganz offen, weil er auch nochmal sagt, wenn man bei Adam Smith nachliest oder bei Montesquieu, aber das ist hier mal nicht, weil jetzt denken manche Leute, Stefan hat sich doch kürzlich aufgeregt, dass immer in Podcasts irgendwelche Philosophen sitzen, die sagen, ja, aber Montesquieu. Hier geht jemand ja ganz tief in den Text rein und destilliert dann unter der Fragestellung, die er aufmacht, heraus, was darüber zu denken ist. Es geht jetzt nicht darum zu sagen, ich habe mal so ein paar Autoritäten hier, die ich zitieren kann, damit du beeindruckt bist, ich habe Adam Smith genannt.
Der freie Handel, der Frieden zwischen den Nationen. Und dann kommt nicht der ganze andere Kram noch. Das ist ja schon mal gut.
Lenin schaut da nach, Rosa Luxemburg. Er sagt es ja um das Film.
Ja, also dieses Montesquidding ist ja hier interessant, weil es wirklich inhaltlich verargumentiert mit, der Frieden wird nicht direkt durch Handel erreicht, sondern weil Menschen, die an diesem Handel teilnehmen, anders kalkulieren. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn wir alle auf den Marktplatz gehen, macht es gar keinen Sinn, aus Wut diesen Marktplatz zu zerstören, sondern wenn, dann beschränkt sich doch ein Konflikt immer auf die Markt teilnehmen, aber nicht auf den Marktplatz selbst. Und das kann man natürlich historisch wunderbar verargumentieren. Und es ist für mich auch wieder ein Premiumargument, weil so wie er später den Nationalismus aus der Gier heraus erklärt, finde ich, wird hier auch wieder so eine Scheu abgelegt zu sagen, ne, wir beschreiben doch hier gerade das Globale, die Geschichte, das ganz Große, das können wir doch nicht auf so kleine persönliche Sachen zurückziehen. Und ich sage, doch, mach das mal.
Jaja.
Nicht immer diese falsche, ne, wir spielen hier nur globale Bundesliga, die Champions League und so, ja. Sondern ne, ne, ne, so hängt alles mit allem zusammen. Und Leute haben Hunger und deswegen gibt es eine globale Wirtschaft. Und jetzt muss einfach nur eins plus eins gerechnet werden.
Rational durchgedacht würde man ja sagen, wer in China investiert, aus Amerika wird als Amerikaner ja nicht darauf hoffen, dass es einen Konflikt mit den Chinesen gibt, denn dann wäre ja vielleicht das Investment nicht gut aufgehoben. Genau. Und die Chinesen wiederum denken hoffentlich gibt es keinen Konflikt mit den USA. Wir haben doch unser Geld in Dollar geparkt. Das soll ja auch nicht angetastet werden.
Man hätten Wolkenkratzer.
Oder so dann direkt jetzt für die vermögende Klasse natürlich auch so gedacht. Aber so einfach ist es nicht. Denn er liest dann Schumpeter. Schumpeter hält eigentlich Imperialismus für ein atavistisches Prinzip. Da kommen so Sachen wie Ehre, Stolz. Das sind alles keine rationalen Motive. Und deswegen ist das für Schumpeter irgendein Überbleibsel aus längst vergangenen Tagen. Und um in der modernen Volkswirtschaft anzukommen, muss man sowas ablegen. Dann aber liest Branko Milanović Schumpeter nochmal gründlicher und sagt, der Schumpeter kommt eigentlich aus so einer neomarxistischen Imperialismustheorie sehr nahe, die ja doch eher nahe liegt. Na nein, wenn die Nationen sich konkurrenzhaft gegenüberstehen, dann steht Krieg auch plötzlich auf dem Felde. Denn Schumpeter sagt, worum es gehen muss, ist, innovative und effizienter zu werden. Und das sei generell die Entwicklung, wenn man eine erfolgreiche Volkswirtschaft anstrebt. Aber was denn eigentlich, wenn man das nicht nur auf der nationalen Ebene so betrachtet, sondern auch auf der internationalen Ebene, Wettbewerb, meint eigentlich, dass man Gewalt hat. Also Schumpeter plädiert für ein kompetitives Mindset, sagt aber dann, wenn es auf die globale Ebene geht, ja da ist das irgendwas atavistisches. Und dann sagt Milanović, nehmen muss nicht, denn so ein kompetitiver imperialistischer Ansatz, so ein imperialistisches Mindset, deckt sich ja total mit der Idee von Schumpeter, dass nur so Entwicklungen stattfinden können.
Also ich kenne jetzt Peter Thiel's Zero to One Buch nicht.
Ja, das ist ja von Schumpeter gesträgt ist.
Ah ja, weil ich habe nämlich hier so gelesen, was Milanović schreibt. Also der normale Kapitalismus ist ja natürlich auf Monopolkapitalismus. Also die sozusagen Konkurrenz und Marktwirtschaft wird schon hinter sich gelassen. Und sobald ein Land einem wirtschaftlichen Monopol ausgeliefert ist, im Sinne von, das ist der einzige Player, das ist einfach too big to fail, also das ist zum Erfolg verdammt, muss das international eben kriegslustig durchgesetzt werden, dieses nationale Monopol. Das sieht man ja in Amerika auf jeden Fall. Vielleicht ist auch die amerikanische Regierung, wo sie auch ins Amt kamen mit zum Ticket, wir beenden alle Kriege und wir machen den großen Friedenspräsident, aber jetzt wird die ganze Zeit vor Venezuela rumgeschossen und so, weil man als größter Ölproduzent der Welt doch nicht einfach das Land mit den meisten Öl vorkommen. Das ist klassischer Schumpeter und Petertier, denke ich, die wir da gerade sehen.
Oder wir hatten das ja auch im Podcast angesprochen, warum wird dann eigentlich nicht von Microsoft und Google gesagt, die Russen können nicht mehr unsere Netzwerke nutzen, nicht mehr unsere Infrastruktur, unsere Digitale. Na ja, wenn man in Form von Monopolkapitalismus denkt, dann würde man ja seine eigene Monopolstellung erheblich schwächen. Oder Google ziemlich schaden, wenn die jetzt nicht mehr in Russland agieren können oder Microsoft. Weshalb man dann lieber sagt, dann lass mal die Ukrainer da kämpfen. Aber wir müssen hier auch unsere Monopole schützen.
Genau, ist ja auch die Chip-Diskussion, darf Nvidia jetzt in China verkaufen. Und der Diskurs läuft, ne, weil die Chinesen entwickeln gerade eigene und es wäre ja nicht so gut, wenn wir da Nvidia-Konkurrenz plötzlich haben. Und mittlerweile ist ja so, dass die Chinesen ihrerseits ihren Herstellern von neuen Technologien verbieten, Nvidia-Chips zu kaufen. Also es gibt sozusagen das doppelte Verbot. Amerika verbietet, dann zu exportieren. Und China verbietet jetzt explizit, bitte nicht über Singapur kaufen und lautes Blödsinn machen. Da kann man schon sehen, ja, dieses schumpeterische, pädatilische Denken ist viel tiefer drin, als wir Gabriel Steingart, die Marktwirtschaft und so weiter immer glauben.
Die Beziehungen zu China und Amerika sind für beide gut und für beide schlecht, so könnte man es zusammenfassen. Also wenn man in dieser staatlichen Konkurrenz denkt, die USA sind das entscheidende Land, das es braucht, damit Investments stattfinden. Also China ist auf die USA als Investor angewiesen. Zugleich ist China darauf angewiesen, in die USA zu exportieren, die Waren, die produziert werden. Und die USA sind darauf angewiesen, dass sie chinesische Waren bekommen. Denn sonst ist es so, wie dann Trump sagt, ja dann gibt es statt 30 Puppen nur noch eine für das Kind. Aber bei Puppen ist das vielleicht noch verschmerzbar, bei vielen anderen Dingen dann eher nicht. Und interessant ist, dass er hier nochmal auf Henry Kissinger eingeht und auf sein Buch On China. Kissinger hatte ja schon diese Öffnung mit vorbereitet oder war entscheidend dann zu der nächsten Ära, der die Öffnung zu China vorbereitet hat. Der aber dann auch eigentlich an so einem Punkt ist, wo nicht mehr so ganz klar ist, wie er sich das vorstellt. Er hat dann, obwohl er ja immer in Freund und Feind dachte, plötzlich so eine Equilibriumtheorie, vielleicht können wir uns da gegenseitig helfen, aufpassen oder so. Aber vielleicht auch, weil Kissinger dann doch nicht gesehen hat, was das einmal bedeutet, wenn China wirtschaftliche Macht hat, die auf Augenhöhe stattfindet für die USA. Also es war ja zu der Zeit Mörschheimer, der ja heute viel zitiert wird im Zuge von Ukraine. Der war ja einer der ganz wenigen, der auf keinen Fall den Aufstieg Chinas wollte. Und er war dann mit diesen ganzen Neoliberalen da und den ganzen Falken. Also er saß mit lauter Falken dort, ich glaube sogar mit Brzezinski, auf Podien und hat dann immer so eine Anti-China-Haltung vertreten, die er bis heute vertrete, also die ich nicht teile, das will ich nur sagen, aber das war immer seine Haltung. Und er sagte, und plötzlich fand er sich als der Falke wieder unter Falken, weil die alle sagten, hey, mit China ist das irgendwie anders, das wird anders werden.
Ja, da hat man einfach Hoffnung, Wunschdenken geradezu. Er teilt ja diese Beziehung zu China in diese Phasen ein und markiert knallhart diese Innenpolitik-Probleme im Wahlkampf 2016. Also Donald Trump bedritt die Bühne und fängt plötzlich an mit diesem, ja ich weiß, damals bei Opa habe ich Japan gesagt, aber jetzt ist es China. Ich übernehme das gleiche Argument, China ist unser Gegner, die beuten uns aus. Dann kommt das Coronavirus und er nimmt wieder die Gelegenheit wahr, so hart auf China reinzukloppen. Also es gibt sozusagen diese diplomatische Schauseite, diese Beziehung plötzlich nicht mehr. Plötzlich wird alles knallhart verrechnet, was ja jetzt eskaliert zu, ja wir machen jetzt Handelsdiskurse und da geht es dann darum, dürfen amerikanische Studenten in China studieren und was ist mit den Sojabohnen und so. Und Amerika sagt einfach, also verbietet sozusagen allen Produzenten von irgendwelchen Produkten mit Sojabohnen, ihr kauft nicht in Amerika. Ja. Und dann bleibt das einfach bei Null, so Nullkäufe. Während man in der ersten Trumps Amtszeit noch so, ja okay, wir kaufen das jetzt über Indien und wie auch immer und so. Und dann macht man so ein paar Deals, aber jetzt einfach so gar nicht. So es gibt diese Diplomatie, bei der man das noch so ein bisschen, gibt es aber nicht mehr. Es wird nur noch unterm Strich zähle ich. Jetzt wird Knall halt bilanziert.
Aber wir sehen da eigentlich ganz gut, Soja-Bohnen, das betrifft also alle, die sich noch ernähren. Und das andere ist schon wieder ein Elitendiskurs. Was ist eigentlich mit den Unis, wie können die sich weiter finanzieren, wenn die chinesischen Studenten wegfallen? Und da muss man sich klarmachen, es geht nicht primär darum, dass China die USA geografisch jetzt bedroht und die bald da einmarschieren, sondern es stellt sich hier die Frage, wird die Hegemonie der politischen Eliten der westlichen angetastet dadurch, dass China selbst Eliten hat, die wirkmächtig in der Welt vertreten sein können. Und zugleich, wenn wir von Kontarevolution durch Trump sprechen, hat Chinas Erfolg ja, so schreibt Milanović, zu einer Teilung der USA geführt. Der eine Teil, das ist der kleine Teil, der hat von dem Aufstieg profitiert, nämlich alle, die Outsourcing treiben konnten, die an den Börsen reich geworden sind, Mensch, neue Märkte entstehen. Und auf der anderen Seite, und das sind erheblich mehr und damit auch erheblich mehr Wähler, das sind die, er zitiert das mehrfach, die Hillary Clinton Deplorables bezeichnet hat, also die Abgehängten, die in Zuständen leben, wo sie nicht sagen können, naja, aber ich habe jetzt günstig was noch aus China bekommen, sondern sie haben, was die Löhne anbelangt, und so überhaupt nicht davon profitiert und sterben jetzt diesen Tod aus Verzweiflung, auch das wird ja hier nochmal direkt zitiert. Und dabei geht es dann nicht mehr nur ums Geld, sondern auch um so etwas wie Würde, Respekt oder wie auch immer man das nennen möchte.
Da dieser Tod aus Verzweiflung so häufig zitiert wird, fast wie Triggerpunkte, wir haben uns ja damals uns aktiv dagegen entschieden, auch weil ich so dachte, oh ne, wir können nicht dran an Seiten Depressionen lesen, aber vielleicht müsste man es doch nochmal nachholen.
Ich hatte es ja mal kurz mitgebracht mit so ein paar Thesen, also du sollst auf jeden Fall mal reinschauen.
Also bei ihm ist es wirklich interessant, wie er nochmal nicht national denkt, sondern in Arm und Reich im Sinne von, in Amerika war völlig klar und es prägte eben diese vorherige Phase, also die erste Phase des amerikanisch-chinesischen Verhältnisses, dass die Wähler davon nicht behälligt werden. Ja, das in China die Werkbank Amerikas ist, das findet einfach statt. Und dann kam plötzlich Trump und hat das zum Thema gemacht. Und die Eliten haben festgestellt, der Gegner ist gar nicht China, bei dem wir immer glauben, wir kriegen das noch irgendwie hin, da müssen wir halt über die WHO und hier so Elitendiskurs machen, sondern die amerikanischen Eliten haben plötzlich festgestellt, dass die amerikanischen Wähler nicht mehr alle vier Jahre durch falsche Ideologie mobilisiert werden können, um irgendwas zu machen, um als, Zitat, Wahlmaschine gebraucht zu werden. Sondern nein, die haben plötzlich so einen inhaltlichen Punkt gemacht und gesagt, wir mögen das nicht mit China und Trump ist unser Mann. Und dann schreibt Milanović, mussten sich die amerikanischen Eliten entscheiden, ob sie jetzt diesen Einweg weiter durchkämpfen, der aber gerade scheitert, Globalisierung, oder ob sie ihre Macht, ihre Elitenmacht einfach abgeben an Trump und sozusagen zurückgefahren werden auf, ja du bist zwar superreich, aber du hast keine Adresse mehr in Washington. Du kannst ja nicht mal einfach anrufen und sagen, also da muss man dann schon mega, mega, mega superreich sein.
Ja.
Und Tim Cook-artig mit so einem goldenen Ding und einem Presse-Termin. Und dann haben die auch ein offenes Ohr in Washington und sagen, ja, okay, für iPhones haben wir jetzt einen extra Zoll, so. Aber wenn man nur so halb oligarch ist, geht es halt nicht. Und dann wurden die Eliten wirklich aus dem Spiel genommen durch, ich würde sagen, eben neue Eliten. Also ist ja die ganze Trump-Riege da. Oder man passt sich halt da einfach an und steht dann aber im Feuer.
Wobei auch die Kontinuität der Anti-China-Politik von der Biden-Administration mit übernommen wurde.
Genau, da gab es keinen Weg mehr zurück. Also das sollte man auch nicht. Das ist jetzt verspielt. Also die amerikanischen Wähler machen das jetzt immer zum Thema. Die wollen das jetzt hören, wie geht es in der Weile mit China. Und jetzt ist sozusagen die Katze aus dem Sack.
Und auch weil die politischen Eliten nochmal andere sind als jetzt irgendwelche Hedgefonds-Manager, sondern die politischen Eliten generell sagen, ja wir wollen aber weiterhin die Vormachtstellung haben in der Welt und alles diktieren können, auch mit dann entsprechender Moral angefüttert und so etwas. Wir sehen das ja im deutschen außenpolitischen Diskurs, ob das jetzt bei Baerbock oder Badefuhl ist, in gleicher Weise. Und das hat sich da wahnsinnig verfestigt. Was die aber eigentlich für einen Kampf austragen, das macht ja Milanović schon später nochmal deutlich, ist nicht, ja hier stellen sich mutige Demokraten gegen die Autokratie. Das war ja die Rahmenung, die Joe Biden vorgenommen hat, um zu sagen, wir als politischer Westen kämpfen dagegen. Also wir Demokraten gegen die Autokraten. Nein, es ist dann tatsächlich eine Konkurrenz, wie sie Schumpeter beschrieben hätte. Nämlich eine der ökonomischen Vormachtstellungen. Wer soll sie erhalten? Weshalb man ja auch jetzt nicht sagt, wir bomben China kaputt. Oder man sagt doch nicht, die sollen wieder arm werden, sondern die sollen bitte so aufsteigen, dass es nicht mehr Hunger gibt, nicht mehr große Armut. Aber sie sollen nicht dazu in der Lage sein, eigene tolle Autos, eigene fortschrittliche Innovationen anzubieten. Milanović sagt an einer Stelle, während das schnelle Wachstum der Realeinkommen in China dazu beigetragen hat, die Einkommensunterschiede zwischen den Ländern und auch die globale Einkommensungleichheit zu verringern, könnte es gleichzeitig zu einer Stagnation der Reallöhne, zum Verlust von Arbeitsplätzen und zur Entstehung einer prekären Arbeitnehmerschicht im Westen geführt haben. Allesamt Phänomene, die die Einkommensunterschiede in den reichen Ländern vergrößert haben. Das ist dann die berühmte Angleichung.
Es ist wirklich wahnsinnig interessant, da wir ja alle Betroffene sind. Wie diese geopolitische Spannung, die wir ja jeden Abend jetzt im Fernsehen immer sehen, Ukraine hier, China da, Pipapo, immer auf innenpolitische Verwerfungen zurückzuführen sind. Also es gibt eine superreiche Elite, die top 1 Prozent, die hat ein ökonomisches Ansinnen, Geld sparen, billiger produzieren. Sie haben die ärmere Hälfte nicht mit im Boot, müssen also ein Propaganda-Gebäude drum herum bauen. Das hält aber nicht ewig. Dann stehen sie ohne da. Aber es muss ja trotzdem eine Geschichte erzählt werden. Dann kommt ein politischer Konkurrent, der mit dieser Elite nichts zu tun hat. Die greifen das dann auf. Also er schreibt richtig schön diese Kette von Ereignissen auf, wie diese Unzufriedenheit eben dazu führte, dass es jetzt plötzlich zu diesem, ja vielleicht gibt es dann doch wieder die schießende Auseinandersetzung mit China. Und dann schreibt er von zwei ausgeschlagenen Alternativen. Das eine wäre eben eine Umverteilung. Also die zurückgelassenen Deplore-Bills eben nicht so zurücklassen, dass sie sich dann doch wieder organisieren können. Und sei es als Wählerhomogenität hinter einem Kandidaten wie Trump. Und das haben wir ja bei Precht und so auch gehört. Die Geschichte ist ja mehrfach beschrieben, wie die Arbeiterbewegung eigentlich zugelassen wurde, damit die Arbeiter, die vielen Arbeiter, die wenigen Kapitalisten nicht kurzum klein schlagen. Also es war ein Einhegungsprojekt und kein wir gönnen euch Projekt. So und wenn man das Einhegungsprojekt nicht mehr macht, weil man glaubt, ach das mit den Gewerkschaften, ne man muss sich halt wieder einhegen. So und ja dann hat man da ein Problem. Also das ist das Umverteilungs Ding, ein Weg, der nicht gegangen wurde. Er hatte auch eine Literaturempfehlung. The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Markowitz. Lohnt sich sicherlich dem nachzugehen. Und das zweite ist Migration. Man kann nicht beides machen. Also die eigenen Leute so fallen lassen, dass man da nicht weiter kommt und gleichzeitig das Land abschotten. Wie er es beschreibt?
Er hat ja da einen sehr unkonventionellen Ansatz. Das ist nicht das erste Mal, dass er darüber schreibt. Er hat die Idee, dass man ein Zwei-Klassen-System einführen könnte. Das klingt jetzt erstmal für uns nicht besonders gut, weil wir dann sagen, aber wir wollen ja gerade nicht Menschen in zwei Klassen einteilen. Ist das nicht eigentlich das, was die Rechten wollen? Das ist auch nicht so, dass er das als ideal ansieht und sagt, so stelle ich mir die perfekte Welt vor, sondern er fragt sich, was wäre zu tun, um Migration zu ermöglichen und gleichzeitig eine höhere Akzeptanz für diese zu erhalten. Erst einmal ist er ja durch diese Zahlen, die er präsent hat, global sich sicher. Migration kann dazu führen, dass Menschen reicher werden. Menschen können ihren positionalen Status verbessern, indem sie woanders hin fliehen. Für ihn gibt es hier auch gar nicht die Diskussion über fliegen vor Krieg oder fliehen vor Verfolgung, sondern er findet erst einmal Wirtschaftsmigration gut. Das ist nicht irgendwas, wo man sagt, da sind wir aber dagegen, wir wollen das nur humanitär. Das heißt, der Status verbessert sich enorm für Menschen, gerade aus afrikanischen Ländern. Du hattest ja eben gesagt, wie desaströs das immer noch da ist. Deshalb fragt er sich, ob es möglich wäre, ein Zwei-Klassen-System zu machen, dass also die, die kommen, sehr viele Rechte nicht genießen können in dem jeweiligen Land, in das sie einwandern. Aber dadurch erleben sie auf jeden Fall einen starken Aufstieg zu dem, woher sie kommen. Also das heißt, für sie ist es zwar dann nicht eine gleichberechtigte Situation, aber sie können sich so sehr verbessern, also zum Teil wirklich verzehnfachen, von dem, wenn wir wissen, wie reich der Westen ist. Und das wissen wir ja. Und zugleich könnte man durch dieses Zweiklassensystem der Bevölkerung sagen, die sind ja aber auch nicht so gut wie ihr gestellt. Deswegen müsst ihr vor denen gar keine Sorgen haben. Im Gegenteil, die bringen uns Wohlstand, den ihr doch eigentlich haben wollt. Das ist ein ganz instrumenteller Ansatz. Und man kann jetzt da mit Idealismus nicht rangehen. Das ist aber auch hier nicht der Versuch, sondern es ist jetzt die Sache, die eigentlich utilitaristisch ist. Wie kann man möglichst vielen Leuten doch das Leben etwas besser machen? Und das wäre ein Ansatz.
Ja, also wenn man und vielleicht kann man es ja. Also ich fand es überraschend, das so zu lesen, aber ich finde es schlüssig und es macht auf jeden Fall Sinn in einem Buch, das eine Gedankenwelt von globalen Relationen argumentiert. Einfach zu sagen, nein, nein, der äthiopische junge Mann, der dort weder vorgefertigte Biografie durchleben kann, noch überhaupt einen Ausbildungsstaat, kann natürlich erst mal als Oberfahrer hierherkommen. Dann geht es ihm besser. Plus der im Abstieg begriffene deutsche Fast Rentner kann sich dann auch noch mal eine Beförderung leisten. Und das ist so gesehen schon Win-Win. Nur von Elitenseite aus muss man sich halt überlegen, entweder zahlen wir den Deutschen genug Einkommen, sodass sie sich einfach gegenseitig so einen Dienstleistungssektor unterhalten können. Also dass ein Industriearbeiter so viel verdient, dass er sich selbst einen deutschen Taxifahrer leisten kann. Das hat man nicht gemacht. Diese Alternative wurde ausgeschlagen. Oder man hätte Migration strukturell richtig zulassen müssen, damit die verarmten Industriellen dann noch mal den etwas ärmeren afrikanischen Zuwanderer haben, der ihn befördert. Beides hätte die Probleme abgefedert. Beides wurde nicht gemacht. Also müssen sich die Eliten im Podcast jetzt damit rumschlagen, dass wir gegen China verlieren. Und das finde ich schon. In der Kürze und in diesem Pragmatismus kann man das ruhig mal einfach so aussprechen. Entweder Migration oder ihr holt die Unterschicht in die Mittelschicht. Aber ihr könnt nicht beides ausschlagen und dann im Podcast rumjammern. Dieser Rawls spielt hier eine große Rolle. Ich kannte ihn nicht. Ich habe kurz nachgelesen, was das für ein Autor ist.
Gerechtigkeitstheoretiker.
Genau. Er hat dieses zentrale Argument gemacht, dass es einen Schleier des Nichtwissens geben sollte, bevor man eine Gesellschaft konzipiert. Weil wenn niemand weiß, welchen Platz er später in diesem Gefüge einnimmt, wird niemand groß benachteiligt. Wenn aber jeder von sich glaubt, naja, ich werde ja in diesem System der König, gibt es natürlich nur einen König und lauter Bettler. So. Und dieses super schlüssige Argument, sagt er jetzt, hält ja einer globalen Wirklichkeit nicht stand. Das kann man ja nur national denken. Also gehe ich ganz kritisch damit um. Und das finde ich natürlich wieder gut. Da wird man ja einmal richtig, da kriegt man so eine Glöhe gezogen.
Also Wolf hat dann seine Theorie erweitert und wollte so eine globale Theorie der Gerechtigkeit schreiben. Hat aber dann zum Beispiel schon so interessante Widersprüche aufgetan. Er findet, dass es gut wäre, wenn die armen Länder sich international Geld leihen dürfen, um dann aufzusteigen, um investieren zu können. Aber es sollen sich jetzt nicht arme Leute national Geld leihen können. Das wiederum nicht. Und dann fragt Branko Milanović, warum denn nicht? Also wenn du das da ausschließt, auf der nationalen Ebene, aber bei der internationalen, ja. Naja und dann wirft er eigentlich John Rawls vor, dass er sagt, ja mit Interventionen im Ausland ist schwierig, es sei denn, man gehört zum politischen Westen. Also es ist eigentlich so eine Philosophie, die sagt, wegen Menschenrechten wollen wir jetzt mal folgenden Krieg haben. Das sagt man so nicht, sondern wir müssen natürlich Leute befreien und was auch immer. Und dann hat man eigentlich so eine Welt, bei der man sagt, ja wir sind wirklich die Guten und die anderen müssen sich dem unterordnen. Und da sagt er, das war so eine typische Denkweise der 90er Jahre, die lange vorherrschend war. Und damit kommt man natürlich nicht an einen Punkt, wo man wirklich eine geopolitische Ordnung beschreiben kann.
In diesen ganzen Denkebeuten können die Armen immer nur als die anderen stattfinden. Ansonsten geht das nicht auf. Dieses große Kapitel oder ganze Teil des Buches, die Eliten, ist sehr gut. Es überhaupt mal so auszuflacken. Wir reden jetzt hier mal nicht über und so weiter, sondern die globalen Superreichen, bei denen wir bitte keinen Diskurs führen oder allenfalls auf so einer pragmatischen, programmatischen Ebene, ja, verlassen jetzt alle dann die Schweiz. Wenn wir da eine Reichesteuer oder was auch immer einführen und man fragt sich, wo sollen sie denn gehen? Das sind halt globale, also wo die ihr Geld verbuchen, ist dann egal. Die sind reich. Das ist der Punkt. Und das mal so ernst zu nehmen. Und das macht er ja häufiger, dass er grundsätzlich auch bei diesem Kapitel zu Rawls und so, dass er einfach sagt. Und hier fällt mal wieder auf, dass die westliche Klassifizierung, die wirtschaftliche Seite der Angelegenheit außer Acht lässt. Man sieht einfach irgendwelche Politiker, die machen irgendwas. Und dann hat man so eine Meinung darüber. Aber dass man sich einfach mal Zahlen anschaut. Also schaut man einfach nur auf die Zahlen, muss man sagen. Also hier gibt es ungefähr drei Prozent der amerikanischen Bevölkerung sind einfach eigene Art. Das sind einfach andere Leute, die haben mit uns nichts zu tun. Die finden auch nicht in unserer Welt statt, sondern das ist diese neue Homo Plutia, die also sowohl als aus Arbeit als auch aus Kapital ihren Lebensunterhalt bestreitet und unanfechtbar ist.
Ja, das ist eine imprägnierte Elite. Sie ist deshalb unanfechtbar, weil sie nach dem meritokratischen Prinzip ja funktioniert. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man sagt, habe ich alles ererbt und sonst liege ich in der Sonne, bin Lebemann, sondern man geht arbeiten und hat alle Zertifikate. Die Zertifikate sind quasi die Legitimierung des eigenen Status. Und wer will was gegen Zertifikate haben, wenn du die Segeurkunde oder die Erneurkunde bekommen hast, dann hast du sie doch.
Es ist ein bisschen so, für Deutschland gilt es so nicht, wie er das schreibt.
Ja.
Also wir brauchen hier schon neue chinesische Unternehmen, die seit 30 Jahren was mit Technik, was mit E-Mobilität, also Firmen, die es vor 30 Jahren einfach nicht gab. Genau wie in Amerika, Invidia ist nicht 1880 gegründet worden. Genauso wenig wie Google, Facebook, Meta und der ganze Kram. Also es braucht schon diese Gründer geführten Unternehmen, die dann ihrerseits, also von Seiten des Gründers, der eigentlich sich aufs Kapital beziehen könnte, immer mal wieder die Finger mit drin hat und so mit entscheidet, macht es jetzt der Pichai oder wer auch immer, wer fühlt jetzt hier die Geschäfte, wem übergebe ich die Verantwortung, derjenige stellt dann wieder direkt selbst nach Einstellungsgesprächen Leute ein, denen er 10 Millionen Jahresgehalt zahlt und so was. Also das sind schon...
Genau, aber die, denen er das dann zahlt, die gehören jetzt zu homo-plutischen Eliten.
Genau. Und in Deutschland ist das ja noch so ein bisschen anders. Also die Eigner dieser Firmen in Deutschland, die Familie Porsche, die Familie Pich und alle.
Die würde er wahrscheinlich auch nicht dazuzählen. Die meint er nicht. Er meint jetzt eher Leute, die zum Beispiel aus einem Haushalt kommen. Vater hat eine Zahnarztpraxis, Mutter hat schon geerbt von irgendwas und ist Professorin. Das heißt, man hat noch ein Ferienhaus in Italien und ein Haus am Starnberger See. Man hat also ein paar Millionen im Hintergrund, studiert dann IT und bekommt den Deutschland-Topjob bei Google.
Ja, genau sowas.
Und verdient also selbst 800.000 im Jahr.
Ja, und da ist natürlich schnell Vermögen da auch.
Genau, und hat damit Vermögen, dass man anhäufen kann und hat aber auch schon die entsprechenden ETFs, die angespart wurden seit dem ersten Lebensjahr. Und so haben wir genau diese Homopletier, die sagt, ja, wir können gerne über Umverteilung reden, aber ich arbeite ja 80 Stunden.
Genau, und jetzt ist so, das steht hier in diesem Buch drin. Und relativ viel, wenn ich alles von dem, was ich da lese, ist für mich neu. Es bezieht sich aber auf die Literatur von James Burnham, 1941, The Managerial Revolution. Ja. So, dieses Buch ist von 1941 und beschreibt schon, wie diese Art Kapitalismus, in der also diejenigen, die ihn verwalten, auch besonders viel verdienen und sich da festsetzen, aus dem Feudalismus gewachsen sind, sie haben also ein Lehen übertragen bekommen, so wie halt der Eigner einfach sagt, du bist jetzt mein CEO, du bestellst jetzt mein Feld. Also, eize, eize. Das ist also Wissen, das ist länger her als das Ende des zweiten Weltkriegs. Warum findet das im deutschen Diskurs nicht statt? Wo es doch einfach alles so funktioniert?
Ja, ist eine große Frage. Also, er verpasst ja dem Burnham dann ein Update, der sagt jetzt nicht, genau so ist es.
Nee, genau.
Aber er sagt, dass das Management immer wichtiger wird im Kapitalismus. Und er sagt auch, dass gar nicht so dieser Diskurs so wichtig ist, wie Volker ist Professional Managerial Class. Das ist ja gar nicht was, worauf er sich übermäßig einlassen will, sondern er sagt vielmehr, ja, so wird der Kapitalismus geregelt. Er wird gemanagt. Und diese Management-Klasse bringt eben hervor, dass da sehr schnell auch Kapital angehäuft werden kann. Ja, im Sinne von, ich habe so viel verdient, ich lege es mal auf die hohe Kante. Oder dass die Leute, die diese Funktionen ausführen, aus einer Elite schon kommen, aus einer Familie, die reich ist.
Genau. Also du sagst, es weicht ab. Genau. Also Bernheim bezieht sich da auf Marxismus, weicht aber wieder davon ab, dass diese, diesen Lehn, dieses Feld, das man da bestellt, ja gar nicht vom Staat kommt, dass die Partei dir irgendwie sagt, du besitzt hier Stadthalter und so weiter, sondern dass es eben private Vermögen sind, wie auch immer. Aber es ist doch wahnsinnig interessant, dass hier einfach in diesem Buch nochmal darauf Bezug genommen wird, dass ja der Bernheim selbst Ende der 40er Jahre schon sich die Frage stellte, warum melden sich eigentlich so wenig freiwillige Rekruten im britischen und im US-Militär um beim Zweiten Weltkrieg mitzuhelfen? Das ist genau der Diskurs von heute. Und wieder ist die Antwort dieselbe. Da sind einfach arme Leute, die sich fragen, Großbritannien ist das Land, in dem ich lebe, zu dem habe ich keinen Bezug. Das hilft mir hier gar nichts, ich lebe mein Leben. Und wo sollte genau der patriotische Gedanke herkommen? Ich brauche Brot. Und das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Aber die sollst du dich einfach ausfechten, weil die Managerial Class will natürlich nicht an die Front.
Du gehst bitte für mich arbeiten, damit mein Wohlstand, und du gehst bitte für mich kämpfen, weil mein Land. Und das ist natürlich, ja, also hier wiederholt sich einfach Geschichte. Es ist erschreckend, muss man ehrlich sagen.
Ja. Wir sollten noch kurz darüber sprechen, wie das mit den chinesischen Eliten ist. Da hat er nämlich auch eine sehr interessante Zahl. Und zwar sieht das heute so aus, dass mehr als die Hälfte der chinesischen Elite, und das sind also die fünf Prozent der Reichsten, nein, also die fünf obersten Prozent. Diese Elite, von dieser Elite sind mehr als die Hälfte im privaten Sektor tätig. Vergleicht man das mit dem Jahr 1988, dann hat sich da wahnsinnig viel entwickelt. 1988 war von dieser Top-Five-Prozent-Elite nur fünf Prozent im privaten Sektor. Was wir also da sehen können, ist, ja, der Staat spielt noch eine wichtige Rolle und die Partei, aber mehr als die Hälfte findet schon im privaten Sektor statt. Das heißt, da wird richtig Geld verdient. Wie ist es jetzt mit den Zertifikaten in China? Natürlich gibt es da auch Elite-Unis und so etwas, aber ganz wichtig sind da die CPC Credentials, so nennt er das, also die Zertifikate durch die Partei. Welchen Status hat man in der Partei? Das spielt da eine große Rolle, um Ansehen zu haben. Genau. Und da ist noch mal interessant, wie Xi vorgegangen ist. Er hat ja eine massive Korruptionsbekämpfung gemacht.
Damals schon als Bürgermeister in Shanghai werden wir darüber gelesen.
Und dann ja auch, als er Präsident wurde. Und wenn Milanović kommt dann einfach auf sehr gute Ideen und sagt, ich muss mal gucken, wann sind denn eigentlich die Jetzt der Korruption Angeklagten oder in den vergangenen Jahren der Korruption Angeklagten in die Partei eingetreten? Sind das eher alte oder junge Leute, die jetzt gerade angeklagt werden? Und es stellt sich heraus, der überwiegende Teil sind da fast bei 90 Prozent der Angeklagten während der Xi-Ära sind vor 1992 in die Partei eingetreten. Also gegen diese alte Elite, das ist die alte Elite in den USA, gegen die Clinton-Elite tritt der Trump an, Xi gegen diese alte Partei-Elite und macht denen allen den Korruptionsprozess. So wie auch Trump immer zu Clinton sagte zu Hillary, wenn ich im Amt bin, kommst du in den Knast. Und der Xi kann das machen.
Also die hat sie während Parteitagen von der Bühne abführen lassen. Da kamen einfach zwei Soldaten, haben jemand mitgenommen.
Heißt aber, dass das die Alten betrifft und die Jungen offenbar, da wirkt schon diese Anti-Korruption, die stehen nicht vor Gericht. Da gibt es viel, viel weniger Fälle. Irgendwie zehn Prozent. Bedeutet also, da ist der, also der alle Angeklagten sind zehn Prozent nach 92 eingetreten in die Partei und alle anderen davor. Bedeutet also, Xi's Anti-Korruptionspolitik ist ziemlich erfolgreich.
Ja, genau. Ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass da wahrscheinlich Xi auch viel Korruption hat. Sicherlich. Mal sehen.
Oder? Meinst du? Er ist nervst, stimmt. Du hast eigentlich recht, weil er wird ja hier auch nochmal so als ganz klarer Ideologe gezeigt und die Ideologen zeichnen sich ja dadurch aus, dass sie nicht korrupt sind eigentlich.
Ja, also die China-Kapitel sowieso wahnsinnig interessant.
Ja, auch wie er das nochmal so alles beschreibt, wer wie regiert hat. Ja, also in China, wie eng auch da die Elite, auch wenn jetzt Xi dort aufräumt, nach wie vor miteinander verbunden ist. Also man hat die ganze Zeit miteinander zu tun gehabt. Und dann beschreibt er das Verhältnis von Clinton und Trump und sagt auch, naja, die haben sich ja die ganze Zeit gekannt und Trump hat ja auch eine Zeit lang sogar mal Geld gespendet an die Clintons für einen Wahlkampf. Das heißt, man ist also immer noch unter sich, auch wenn man ein anti-elitäres Programm gerade durchzieht.
Bevor es um dieses China-Ding gilt, an die ich auch gleich noch mal anknüpfe, wird dieses Homo Plutarch Kapitel natürlich noch mit diesem Bildungszeilen abgeschlossen. Wir hatten sie ja vorhin schon genannt. Da steckt auch noch so ein Argument drin, also es sind diese zehn Billionen Euro. Er zitiert da den Daniel Markowitz, der Meritocracy Trap, also die Falle, die da drin steckt. Denn diese Leute verbuchen ja diesen Geburtsvorteil, also die Geburtslotterie geht zu ihren Gunsten aus und dann unterfüttern sie das mit diesen Bildungsinvestitionen. Und dadurch, dass die so fleißig an ihrer Uni sind, zu der sie natürlich hingefahren werden, danach Hilfelehrer kommen zu ihnen nach Hause und so. Ja, es ist schon eine bequeme Sache, aber ja, die Abschlüsse wurden natürlich errungen. Wird natürlich dieses ganze Prinzip, du schaffst es doch auch, weil ich ja auch, ich bin dein Vorbild, nochmal viel härter, als wenn wir jetzt einfach nur das aristokratische Vermögen, das die ganze Zeit im Urlaub ist. Also wir haben es hier auch mit Herausforderungen, was umso mehr dazu führt, zu sagen, liebe Linke, die uns hier zuhören, wenn jemand sagt Bildung, nicht per se sagen, ne, das geht eh nicht oder so, sondern ja Bildung ist der Weg, wir sehen es ja bei den Superreichen. Und dieses Geld muss jetzt grundsätzlich für alle fließen. Es sind echte Qualifikationen, die da errungen werden. Es ist echtes Wissen, was da erlangt wird. Wir können es also nicht einfach und diese Argumentation kenne ich ja aus meinen Diskussionen, wie lange mir erzählt wurde, ach Fachkräftemangel, das ist doch nur diese Industrieideologie, wenn es weniger als sieben Bewerber auf einer offenen Stelle gibt. Und dann sagt man irgendwann, nein, das ist nicht mehr so. Die Zeit ist fünf Jahre fortgeschritten. Und so ist das hier bei der Bildung auch. Also wir können nicht länger, nur weil jemand in der Diskussion, Markus Söder oder so, dann mal wieder, aber die Bildung, dann einfach sagen, nee nicht die Bildung, das funktioniert nicht. Deutschland ist ja abgeschottet, wie auch immer. Sondern nee nee, ja stimmt, die Bildung. Zehn Millionen pro Kind, das ist das Preisschild, das da dran muss. Der Weg der Bildung muss und das ist eben bezahlt werden.
Kommen wir zum Kapitel National Market Liberalism.
Ja, also China, du hast es angesprochen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, da ich mir falsche oder nicht ausführlich genug die Zwischenüberschriften gemacht habe. Ich habe mir hier eine Notiz gemacht zum Thema America First aus Verlegenheit. Dass das eigentlich nur die zweite Wahl war. Dass America First eigentlich ein ganz großes Schwächerargument ist. Es kann nur der Plan B gewesen sein, auf America First zu gehen. Das finde ich wirklich wahnsinnig gut.
Denn der Plan A wäre gewesen, dass man sagt, wir sind so stark, dass wir natürlich hegemon bleiben. Da brauchen wir uns gar keine Sorgen machen. Wir sind die Besten. Aber da man gesehen hat, das wird man nicht sein können, weil China so erfolgreich ist und andere asiatische Staaten, musste man sagen, dann ziehen wir uns so auf unsere Grenzen zurück und beschäftigen uns isolationistisch mehr.
America First ist Isolationismus. Das ist der ganz, ganz kleine Bruder des Imperialismus. Wenn man sagt, America First ist das keine Kampfansage an die Welt, sondern es ist die Kapitulationserklärung. Wir sind kein Imperium mehr. Und das fand ich in dieser Deutlichkeit, das hier mal zu lesen, wirklich bemerkenswert, da trumpt das natürlich immer mit dem Wir und so. Und umso schlimmer finde ich auch die Unterwerfungsgesten meines Bundeskanzlers.
In der Tat.
Sich einem Imperator zu unterwerfen, okay.
Ja, muss man halt.
Aber sich einem Isolationisten zu unterwerfen, das ist dumm. Das macht auch gar keinen Sinn, weil wir haben ja gar nichts davon, der will sich ja isolieren.
Ich würde mir überhaupt wünschen, dass jetzt nochmal ein europäischer Ökonomen einfach alle Zahlen von Milanović nimmt und alle Vorgehensweisen und das nochmal nur auf Europa beschreibt.
Ja.
Ja, weil Europa hier stiefmütterlich bewusst behandelt wird, beziehungsweise ja wir auch da kaum Aussagen treffen können. Was ist denn da jetzt überhaupt, wenn der eine sich für Abschottung entscheidet oder zumindest sagt, wir müssen uns auf unser Kernland konzentrieren. China das interessanterweise ja nicht macht. Also es ist ja auch eine Frage, die Milanović einmal so stellt. Warum konzentrieren die sich eigentlich nicht viel mehr auf die Binnenwirtschaft? Warum sind die viel mehr exportgetrieben, als es vielleicht sein müsste? Aber das ist noch mal ein anderes Thema. Aber dass man fragt, wo ist dann eigentlich Europa da? Wichtig ist festzuhalten, der Neoliberalismus, der darf strukturell geschwächt werden und mehr nationale Imperative kommen dann. Aber als Ideologie, sagt Milanović, bleibt dieser Neoliberalismus schon erhalten, nämlich auf der nationalen Ebene und bei Gabor Steingard haben wir eben alles dazugehört, was man da wissen muss, weshalb dann man von einem National Liberalism sprechen kann oder National Market Liberalism. Die unipolare Weltordnung ist vorbei. Jetzt geht man mit so einem merkantilistischen Prinzip, also mit Zöllen und all dem, den Welthandel an. Damit verwandelt man den Welthandel nicht mehr in so einer harmonischen Denkweise, sondern behandelt ihn oder handelt in ihm als einen permanenten Kampf. Woraus sich dann auch ergibt, dass eine Politik der Mauern überall entsteht. Er sagt das ja noch mal ganz klar. Trump will die Mauer bauen. Die EU gibt sich zwar weltoffen rhetorisch, tut aber ja im Mittelmeer genau das Gegenteil, hat da ihre Mauer.
Genau, wir bauen die selber Mauer. Diesen ewigen Kampf oder wie er schreibt, der ewige Krieg für den ewigen Frieden. Das finde ich auch noch mal sehr bezeichnend, denn er beschreibt ja hier, also wenn du Imperialismus als politisches Projekt pflegst, musst du die ganze Zeit Sonntagsreden halten.
Ja.
Für Veranstaltungen sorgen. Da muss halt der amerikanische Botschafter in Berlin echte Sommerfeste veranstalten und alle einladen und hier und da und alles so toll. Und schaut mal, was wir wieder haben und dann werden große Messen veranstaltet und so weiter und so fort. Wenn du in der America First Isolationismus machst, dann gehst du ganz spezifisch auf einzelne Seewege, die du dir freischießt, weil du sie gerade noch so brauchst. Und dann ist der ganze kulturelle Überbau einfach nicht vorhanden. Und da würde ich es auch sehr viel ernster nehmen, wie Trump jetzt da immer so rumbombadiert. Also zuerst wird gegen die Huttis da so ein bisschen der Suesskanal freigeschossen und dann ist es so ein bisschen vor wie eine Zuehler Aschermützel. Und mal sehen, wie das so weitergeht. Also die Kriegsgefahr wird doch relativ größer, als wenn es jetzt einfach hieße, wir machen keinen Krieg. Wir zeigen dir nur unsere Waffen mit einem Tom Cruise Film. Und wenn dann einfach alle sagen, oh Amerika, ihr habt uns den Frieden und die Demokratie gebracht, ihr seid unser großer Bruder, alles ist so toll, dann schießt halt keiner. Aber wenn es einfach nur heißt, ihr seid uns so scheißegal, aber diesen kleinen Weg nach Stuttgart da bitte freihalten. Ansonsten kommt halt wirklich so der Secret Service und sagt, ja, morgen ist der amerikanische Präsident zu Gast, er möchte auf seinem Golfplatz Golf spielen, können Sie uns mal Ihren Ausweis zeigen? Und dann wird es im 1 zu 1 geklärt. Und das will man natürlich nicht, würde ich mal sagen.
Trump schreibt, er hat den Vorhang gelüftet. Jetzt ist nicht mehr mit, wir reden mal über Werte, meinen was anderes.
Das ist jetzt vorbei. Jetzt wird scharf geschossen.
Also eine Politik der Wahrheit, wenn man so möchte, oder nicht mehr der Heuchelei. Er hat dann noch so eine Passage, selbst die Familienmitglieder und sonstigen Trump-Anhänger beziehungsweise Begleiter verhalten sich doch wie Trump. Er sagt seine engen Vertrauten und Familienmitglieder, die ihn verraten haben um millionenschwere Verträge für Enthüllungsbücher abzuschließen, haben ein Verhalten an den Tag gelegt, das Trump selbst gezeigt hat und gut geheißen hätte. Und das deutlich macht, welche ethischen Standards in diesem Umfeld vorherrschen. Nämlich, jetzt ist es egal, ach so ich kriege eine Million, dann sage ich das auch gerne. Er sagt auch hier deutlich, ich glaube das ist nochmal ganz wichtig, wir sollten uns das merken und auch hin und wieder mal anbringen, wenn wir darüber reden, weil dieser Faschismusbegriff mir ein bisschen zu viele Munde geführt wird. Er sagt, das ist nicht faschistisch. Also Faschisten sind gerade nicht korrupt. Das zeichnet sie eigentlich aus und hier sehen wir aber, Korruption ist an der Tagesordnung beziehungsweise transparent und er sagt noch etwas zu dem Wort Faschismus, denn wenn jetzt hier so protaktionistisch und so gehandelt wird mit Zöllen, mit mercantilistischen Elementen, dann ist das auch nicht unbedingt Faschismus. Er sagt ja, es teilt ein nationalistisches Element mit dem Faschismus, aber nicht mehr als die mercantilistische Politik im Allgemeinen. Im Inland jedoch meidet es jegliche sozialistische Elemente, ja lehnt sie ja sogar ausdrücklich ab und in diesem Punkt kommt es dem Neoliberalismus nah oder ist von ihm nicht zu unterscheiden. Das heißt, das was in politisch passiert, ist gerade nicht der Faschismus, der ja sagt, wir bringen jetzt Arbeit für alle, wir machen ein sozialpolitisches Programm, das natürlich auf Krieg und all das ausgelegt ist. Aber das ist gerade nicht das Programm, was wir bei den Faschisten in den USA und schon gar nicht bei AfD-Leuten beobachten können.
Aber das ist in dem Moment egal, wo du es von der Opferseite siehst und einfach Leute morgens bei dir klingeln, dir Facial Recognition ins Gesicht halten und sagen, du kommst jetzt mit, dann bist du eingewrappt und es betrifft halt Millionen. Von daher ist jetzt gerade egal, welcher ideologische Überbau oder ob überhaupt, wir haben ja eben schon darüber gesprochen, dass es auch einfach dumm ist. Es ist einfach eine grundsätzlich dumme Politik, die zu extrem viel Leid führt, die einfach stattfindet und bekämpft werden muss, egal ob das jetzt als Faschismus wie im Buche steht oder nicht. Was ich nur so bezeichnet finde, dass er manchmal hier auch einfach so harte Urteile spricht. Also, America first aus Verlegenheit. Eigentlich wollte man Imperialismus machen, geht aber nicht. Und damit geht Amerika den gleichen Weg wie zuvor. Und er zählt einfach auf. Die Ägypter, die Römer, das christliche Reich von Byzantz, Karl der Große, die Hunnen, Napoleon, Hitler, die UdSSR und jetzt halt Amelkas Trump. Okay, gut, habe ich verstanden, das Argument. Einmal auf die 12.
Ein Unterschied ist noch wichtig. Beides in China wie in den USA könnte man ja als Staatskapitalismus begreifen. Aber Milanović sagt, wir müssen unterscheiden zwischen Staatskapitalismus im Sozialismus und Staatskapitalismus im Kapitalismus. Das klingt sehr widersprüchlich, weil im Sozialismus Staatskapitalismus. Aber ja, China hat ja eine lange Preiskontrollenpolitik. Isabella Weber wird ja auch hier zitiert, hat darüber geschrieben, China arbeitet mit diesen Joint Ventures, hat aber die Vorherrschaft weiter, kann die CEO sofort in den Knast stecken, wenn was nicht so ist wie gewollt. Und setzt in ganz anderer Weise auf die Präsenz des Staates, als das im Staatskapitalismus, im kapitalistischen Staatskapitalismus ist, wo man ja viel mehr laissez faire hat und eher so eine komische Verbindung hat von Trump. Ich bin ein bisschen korrupt, ihr seid auch ein bisschen korrupt, dann machen wir doch was zusammen.
Das sind alles ihre eigenen Lehnherren, während in China nur ein Lehnherr da ist und das ist die Partei.
Und das zeigt sich an einer Szene, er versucht es dann auf ein Bild zu bringen, er ist 2019 in China und da ist er in so einem Block, wo ganz viele BMW fahren, Mercedes fahren, also da ist die Elite, fährt da gerade so.
Auf zweispurigen Autobahnen.
Und dann sind da ein paar Soldaten.
Drei, ganz junge, zurückhaltende, schüchternde Soldaten, aber halt in Uniform, unersichtlich. Das ist die Partei, die gerade die Straße überquert.
Und die gehen einfach über die Straße, ohne zu gucken, in einer unglaublichen Gelassenheit. Und alle Autos bremsen. Es ist auch niemand, regt sich über irgendwas auf und er beobachtet dann noch mal später, wenn die Soldaten da weitergehen über eine weitere Straße, prophylaktisch alles hält an, wartet. Hier geht jetzt gerade der Start über die Straße.
Genau.
Und wir haben zwar ist in diesem Start so was gemacht, wir fahren nämlich alle Mercedes und BMW hier, aber wir werden uns mit diesem Start nicht anlegen.
Genau. Er sagt, da sitzen Leute in super teuren westlichen Autos, von denen wir sehen, die sind superreich, aber sie haben keine Macht. Und das ist halt, wie er sagt, nur in China so. In Amerika ist es anders. Also wenn da die Kolonne kommt und es ist klar, hier fährt gerade und so weiter, dann wird da gut durchgefahren. Ja, das ist alles sehr eindrücklich. Ich finde es sowieso immer gut, wenn ein Buch, von dem wir sagen, das lebt vor allem von seinen Zahlenwerken, immer wieder das Leben einfach reinbringt, um das zu verplausibilisieren.
Ja, er geht dann auf diese Rede von Präsident Xi ein. Das ist nochmal hochinteressant. 2013 hält Xi eine Rede und fragt sich, woran ist eigentlich die Sowjetunion kaputtgegangen? Könnte das jetzt daran gelegen haben, dass man ja vielleicht sich verrannt hatte in Ideologie?
Ideologischer Nihilismus, sagt er.
Nein, es war ein ideologischer Nihilismus. Das heißt, man hatte keine Ideologie mehr. Branko Milanović kennt sich auch hier in der Literatur aus. Er hat das Buch gelesen von Andrei Kosyrev. Das war der pro-amerikanischste Minister unter Jelzin. Da ist ihm aufgefallen, der zitiert in seinem Buch, kein einziges theoretisches Werk, nichts.
Es gibt keine Ideologie mehr. Weil die Bücher, die über Jahrzehnte vorher hergestellt wurden, bestanden zur Hälfte nur aus Präampel.
Ja.
Und dann plötzlich...
Marc Star, Lenin Dort und so weiter. Nichts da. Nur irgendwie so ein paar tagespolitische Artikel oder so. Nichts davon. Das heißt, es gibt keine Ideologie mehr. Und das, so Schießtese, hat die Sowjets kaputt gemacht. Es waren also nicht demokratische Revolutionen dann auch im Übrigen. Ich würde sie nach 89 übrigen, das will Milanović unterstreichen. Das wird viele hier, die wir hören aus den NATO-Tingtangs, die alle Aust-Europa-Experten sind, sehr freuen, so was zu lesen. Er sagt, das waren keine demokratischen Revolutionen, sondern nationalistische Revolutionen.
So, ein Punkt wird hier noch genannt, bei dem ich mir dachte, wow, das widerspricht gerade allem, was ich höre. Und er macht es trotzdem ganz explizit. Es gibt ein enormes Missverständnis. Der Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion wurde von den neuen russischen Eliten, die dann so ideologiefrei irgendwie versucht haben, klarzukommen, als freiwilliger Verzicht Russlands angesehen. Und die öffentliche Willensbekundung, wir möchten uns dem liberalen Kapitalismus anschließen.
Ja.
Wir haben ja eben schon besprochen, dass relativ viele Länder selbst zu seiner Überraschung total schnell den Switch gemacht haben. Ja. Nur Russland nicht. Ja. Die haben nach dieser kleinen Jäzchen-Turbulenz plötzlich Putin gehabt, der, wie wir heute wissen, wieder so ein mega-ideologisches Programm fährt. Vielleicht sollte man auch im Widerstand gegen Talkshow wissen und was wir sonst als Vibe gerade haben, sich diese 89 bis, sagen wir mal, 95-Zeit wirklich nochmal genauer anschauen und hinterfragen, ob das stimmt, wie wir es immer sehen, dass nämlich Amerika die Sowjetunion plattgemacht hat, dass es da eine Niederlage gab, dass sie Verlierer zurückgelassen wurden und wie auch immer. Sondern vielleicht hätte man auch wirklich anschließen kann an so einen Vibe, den es gab. Die Ostdeutsche nahmen sich auch nicht als die Verlierer gesehen, sondern die sind offenen, armes, ihr seid keine Gewinner, ihr seid unsere Freunde, wir wollen mit euch Staat sein und so. Und vielleicht gilt das, nachdem es ja für wirklich alle anderen Länder galt, vielleicht galt es auch einfach für Russland. Und wenn dieses Missverständnis heute dazu führt, dass wir so einen völlig außer Rand und Band Putin, der nämlich sagt, ja gut, also dann nehmen wir doch wieder diesen erfolgreicheren Weg. Die Bücher bestehen bitte wieder zur Hefte aus Präampel und so.
Also er sagt ja auch, dass Russland sich nach 89 dann doch gewünscht hätte, eigentlich eine Einflusszone wiederzubekommen, um ein bisschen auch Macht zu spielen. Wie jetzt sagt der Frankreich in Westafrika. Aber genau das hat man verwehrt, dass die Ukraine als Ort für beide Mächte, Russland wie USA, der Austragungsort ist, wo ja dieser Kampf ausgetragen wird, stellvertretend beziehungsweise einfach es um Ressourcenzugang zur Macht geht, um die hegemoniale Stellung in der Welt, verweist Branko Milanović auf Brzezinski. Der hat das zur US-Administration zugehörig alles so aufgeschrieben und gesagt. Exakt so ist es gekommen.
Und was haben wir Deutschen davon profitiert, dass Westdeutschland einmal als Aushängeschild, als Schaufenster des Westens, trotz Hitler und so weiter, komplett aufgemöbelt wurde. Also das wäre heute immer so als wir die Friedensmacht, uns wurde die Demokratie geschenkt und so. Das hätte man auch nach 89, nicht nur nach 49, sondern auch nach 89, so organisieren können. Stattdessen wollte man irgendwie so einen Schandfleck global etablieren.
Und für Russland ist es echt schwierig, denn er überlegt dann, könnte sich dann Russland einfach ganz vom Westen weg bewegen. Und es gibt natürlich die Tendenz hin zu China, aber er sagt nochmal die räumliche Nähe allein zu den Metropolen Europas ist eben eine ganz andere wie zu den Metropolen Chinas. Das macht einen Unterschied, ob man 12 Stunden Flug erstmal hat, um mit jemanden da vor Ort zu reden. 90 Prozent der russischen Produktion funktioniert, steht hier auch nochmal drin, mit westlicher Software. Ist interessant, bei diesen ganzen Sanktionspaketen, haben wir diese Zahl mal gehört?
Nein, wir haben immer nur gehört, was so alles nicht sanktioniert wurde.
Ja, und welche Handtasche noch hinschieben soll.
Das 19. Paket immer noch was offen war zum sanktionieren.
Und der Britta-Sport-Schokolade in Russland verkauft, so ein Kram, darüber hat man diskutiert.
Na gut, wir haben natürlich das Gejammer der Sachsen, dass jetzt ihre Äpfel nicht verkauft werden könnten und so, aber das sind ja diese Zahlen. Wirklich alles wird mit Russland gehandelt. Jeder kleine Apfel, der in Sachsen gepflückt wird, ist nochmal da relevant.
Na ja, aber 90 Prozent der russischen Produktion funktioniert über westliche Software.
Ja, wer baut denn Software? Also unsere ist zu 100 Prozent.
So, ja, deswegen aber wir reden die ganze Zeit jetzt. Jetzt haben wir es aber endlich mal mit dem Gas abgestellt oder so. Und dann wissen wir zugleich, dass das ist doch zutiefst verlogen.
Wir schaffen es, dass Trump den internationalen Gerichtshof wegsanktioniert, aber in Russland mal ein paar Sachen auszuschalten, von denen wir glauben, damit machen die bestimmt Krieg. Das geht natürlich nicht.
2045 dann könnte das BIP von China zweimal so groß sein wie das der USA. China hätte eigentlich gerne auch so Milanović ein unipolares System, zwar nicht über die ganze Welt, aber so für Asien, dass sie da die Vormacht haben. Es ist jedenfalls so, dass man jetzt gar nicht so ideologisch rangehen muss an die Sache, wie das ja immer so erscheint. Demokratie vs. Autokratie. Er sagt einfach, China, aufgrund seiner Größe und seiner Macht, zieht andere Staaten an, die aus verschiedenen Gründen nicht zum politischen Westen gehören wollen. Und damit ist er eigentlich das gesagt. Es geht nicht darum, ob China demokratisch ist oder nicht. Er sagt nämlich, die USA würden niemals ihre Macht teilen wollen, auch nicht mit einer Demokratie. Also wenn wir uns jetzt vorstellen, ab sofort liberale Demokratie in China, würde man dann sagen, dann ist alles super. Dann wären ja alle die Zahlen noch immer genau so da, wie die, die Milanović beschrieben hat. Das Einzige, was so ein Kalkül wäre bei einer Demokratisierung, das beschreibt er ja da, dass China zerfällt in vier Einzelteile oder so. Aber er sagt, die einnendenden Bewegungen in China ist ja ein uralter Konflikt, wie groß ist China und wie kann eine Einheit hergestellt werden. Die sind immer da und die werden auch nicht überwunden werden. Das wäre völlig verrückt, wenn man glauben könnte, das geht so. Deshalb wäre also auch ein demokratisches China nicht das, was gewünscht ist vom US-Hegemonen.
Nee, genau. Und jetzt sagst du immer noch US-Hegemonen. Ich würde ja sagen, America First bahnt auch schon Möglichkeiten an, für Amerika zu sagen, ja, wir nehmen das jetzt nicht so krumm, dass da ein anderer da ist. Wir haben ja eh keine imperialistischen Ambitionen mehr.
Ja, zum Schluss noch mal so eine Reflexion darüber, über den freien Willen. Denn wir wählen ja Politiker und wir beschäftigen uns die ganze Zeit mit den Spitzenköpfen. Was uns in der Geschichte bekannt ist, bezeichnen wir als Gesetze der Unvermeidbarkeit. Was uns nicht bekannt ist, bezeichnen wir als freien Willen. Der freie Wille ist für die Geschichte nur ein Ausdruck für den unbekannten Rest dessen, was wir über die Gesetze des menschlichen Lebens wissen. Noch mal ganz geschichtsphilosophisch.
Ja, ich meine, wie vorhin schon angemerkt, dieses alles noch mal runterbrechen auf auch individuelle philosophische Fragestellung, Bedürfnisse, wie auch immer, bahnt dieses finale Argument an, warum Nationalismus? Ja. Warum wollen wir nicht einfach mal alle für alle global und so weiter denken, Sachen verrechnen? Die Wirtschaft ist nun mal global. National gibt es ja nur noch in der Politik. Und jetzt sagt er, das muss ja gar nicht sein. Also den Nationalismus politisch denken und das heißt eben auch moralisch aufgeladen. Also Politik immer als die Sphäre da, wo droht, dass jemand eine Sonntagsrede hält, die eigentlich nur so aus dem Ärmel geschüttelt wird, aber plötzlich bedeutet die irgendwas und dann oh nee, das können wir doch nicht mit dem und dem das machen, weil so und so. Und dann schreibt man ja nochmal dieses neue Fundament. Den Nationalismus können wir ganz einfach oder was heißt einfach ein bisschen zügiger vielleicht überwinden, wenn wir uns darüber aufklären, wie er mit Gier zusammenhängt. Und gegen Gier haben wir schon ganz gute Argumente.
Und hier würde ich einhaken und meine einzige Kritik an diesem Text äußern. Er sagt nämlich, Gier ist in diesem System so präsent und die Gier sorgt dafür, dass man sich vergleicht, dass man in nationalen Kategorien denkt, dass wir ja diese geopolitischen Verwerfungen haben. Da ist was dran. Aber ich würde auch, und er bezieht sich ja auch auf dieses abstrakte Hedonismus, nennt das Marx, also so eine Gier, dass man einfach mehr haben will. Aber wir wissen ja schon auch, dass das kapitalistische System nicht auf Gier basiert, sondern auf der Verwertung von Kapital. Und das weiß ja Milanović eigentlich auch, mindestens genauso gut wie ich. Nämlich, dass es ja nur dann sich lohnt, Kapital zu investieren, wenn man mehr rausbekommt. Und das hat ja erst mal gar nichts mit Gier oder sonst was zu tun. Ich glaube, hier werden zwei Dinge miteinander vermischt. Und das will ich nur gerade aufschlüsseln. Einmal würde ich sagen, der Kapitalismus ist nur mit Wachstum möglich. Wachstum ist nur möglich, wenn aus investiertem Geld mehr Geld wird. Das hat mit Gier erst mal nichts zu tun, sondern das ist dann die Rationalität des Systems. Aber auf die Konsumenten und auf die Bürger geblickt, kann ich natürlich über positionale Bestimmungen nachdenken, wie das, der wird ja nur einmal, glaube ich, erwähnt, den Wepplen tut. Nämlich, dass ich darüber nachdenke, bin ich einfach nur ich oder stehe ich in Relation zu anderen und vergleiche ich mich? Nochmal das Beispiel BMW oder Golf, was hat man in der Garage stehen? Und da kommt natürlich so ein Modus der Gier mit hinein. Und diese Gier, glaube ich, ist es dann auch, mit der man dann, so würde ich ihm recht geben, sagen kann, wird der Nationalismus begründet, der Nationalismus beziehungsweise wird damit nicht begründet, sondern der Nationalismus wird mit irgendwas gefüllt, was gerade da ist. Die einen machen das auf antisemitische Weise, die anderen machen das auf eine antimuslimische Weise oder so, wie man gerade den Nationalismus nähern kann. Aber das eigentliche Grundgerüst dahinter ist, dass der Gier das notwendigerweise unterscheidet in wir und die anderen und dann das einfache Angebot nimmt, auch wir machen es mal auf Deutsch-Nicht-Deutsch oder so.
Na gut, du hast natürlich voll recht. Und vielleicht habe ich einen Schritt zu viel gemacht, in dem ich sagte, da wir über Gier ganz gut Bescheid wissen und seit der Bibel auch Literatur haben, die sie uns versucht auszutreiben, könnte man diese Sachen mobilisieren, um auch gegen Nationalismus endlich mal ein bisschen zu machen. Er sagt ja selber, das ist erst mal nur eine kleine Aufklärung. Wir könnten den Nationalismus zumindest mal entmoralisieren, um ehrliche Diskurse zu führen, nämlich unterm Strich zähle ich. Wir machen hier einfach ein ökonomisches Argument usw. Und was ich mir wünsche jetzt von ihm, weil er ja wirklich wahnsinnig klug ist, ich gebe zu, er ist zu Recht ein von dir gefeierter Ökonomie-Professor, der uns Bücher schreibt. Er hat, kurz bevor er über Nationalismus und Gier schreibt, führt er ganz kurz an, es gibt ja heute viel mehr zu verteidigen. Also wir haben überall heute Leute, die sagen, ich habe etwas, das mir gehört und sei es nur was auch immer, und das muss verteidigt werden. Plus, und das ist, was mich jetzt wahnsinnig interessiert, wir haben immer mehr eine gewichtslose Wirtschaft, immer mehr immaterielle Güter. Wie z.B. ich habe kein eigenes Large Language Model in meinem Keller, aber ich habe eine Lizenz, die, finde ich, also wirklich verschwindend gering kostet dafür, was sie mir bringt. Wo sollte jetzt, und ich weiß nicht genau, was sie in Deutschland als Ökonomie lehren, aber ich höre immer nur, dass das Univissen nicht ganz zu dem passt, was Realität ist. Wo kriege ich eine ökonomische Aufklärung darüber, die ich plausibel und nachvollziehbar finde, die mir diese Bedeutung meiner, ich habe eine Lizenz gewichtslos an einer Software, auch gewichtslos, die mein Leben bereichert. So. Und ich habe aber das Gefühl, das prägt nicht nur mein Leben, sondern es geht ganz vielen so, die einfach zu Hause gemütlich durch Netflix scrollen und sich drei Stunden am Tag und damit ungefähr 20 Prozent ihrer Lebenszeit, also doppelt so viel wie Arbeit, mit gewichtslosen Gütern befassen, die ihnen nicht mal richtig gehören, sondern denen sie halt so partizipieren dürfen, weil sie gerade gestern die 7,99 Euro für Netflix bezahlt haben. Und das wünsche ich mir als Ausarbeitung für das große neue Branko Milanović-Buch, wie uns die gewichtslose Wirtschaft, nachdem wir jetzt gelernt haben, wie wichtig Wirtschaft ist, die gewichtslose Wirtschaft in ihren Bann schlägt in diesem Jahrhundert und was das so insgesamt bedeutet.
Weiß nicht, ob er bei ihm seinen Einkommensschwerpunkt hat. Er macht ja hier einige Äußerungen zu dem Digitalen und dem Eigentum.
Das basiert direkt auf dieser Einkommensfrage. Das Finanzamt fragt mich, haben Sie diese und jene Ausgabe denn mit Gewinnerzielungsabsicht ausgegeben? Und ich so, ja, ich habe Anthropic 100 Euro im Monat genau dafür gezahlt und Gemini 150 Euro im Monat, Google, und CPT nochmal so 20 Euro im Monat und dann nochmal 15 Euro an Mid Journey.
Aber das ist eher eine Frage für Katarina Pistor. Die hat ja schon das Buch der Code des Kapital geschrieben.
Hauptsache, es ist klug am Ende?
Jaja, das ist ja klug und da geht es ja in diese Richtung, also wie das eigentlich wie eine lizenzierte Welt aussieht und wie das aus dem Urheberrecht kommt.
Es droht schon wieder so ein politischer Einschlag mit, sollten wir nicht die Bücher selbst besitzen dürfen, damit wir sie verschenken können oder so. Das interessiert mich ganz wenig. Mich interessiert ganz viel, weil er eben diesen Bogen spannt aus einem ganz kleinen, individuellen, undurchdachten, persönlichen Bedürfnis, bei dem wir ganz weit weg davon sind, wie du eben die Kritik eingeführt hast mit, nee, das muss schon verrechnet werden und hier und da, da machen sich Kapitalisten Gedanken und ich sage mir, nee, mir geht es um die 99 Prozent der Teilnehmer, die Konsumenten, die machen sich keine Gedanken, die machen auch keine Excel-Tabelle zu irgendwas auf, sondern die sind einfach triebgesteuert und gucken halt Netflix-Filme und wissen gar nicht, dass im Hintergrund so ein großer Kampf zwischen der eine bietet 108 Milliarden und der andere bietet 80 Milliarden und so, dass da solche Kämpfe stattfinden.
Ja, was festzuhalten ist, wir müssen lernen, in Relationen zu denken und wir müssen uns fragen, müssen wir das Spiel der herrschenden mitmachen, die sagen, ich will aber stärker sein, ich will aber weiterhin den Führungsanspruch haben. Das Buch endet damit, dass er sagt, so wächst der Nationalismus auf dem Tarant des nie zu stillen Überflusses und der Gier und dem Wunsch, dass diese Fülle, die aufgrund der Gier immer eine relative Fülle bleibt, das heißt Fülle im Vergleich zu Fülle anderer, für immer erhalten bleibt. Kriege sind unser Weg, um dieses für immer zu erreichen. Und das für immer wird in Anführungszeichen gesetzt. Das heißt, wer in dieser Logik bleibt, bleibt eigentlich im ewigen Krieg.
Ja, das ist sehr gut alles. Du bist ja ein kluger Mann. Ist er noch jung?
Nee, er ist ja schon pensioniert.
Schade.
Ah, da ist ein Bild.
Na ja, ein paar Bücher wird er schon noch schreiben.
Bestimmt. Und die anderen unbedingt auch lesen. Es ist ja ganz viel von ihm schon ins Deutsche übersetzt. Das lohnt sich alles. Auch wenn es ein paar Jahre alt ist, kann man alles wunderbar lesen. Der Ökonom Branko Milanović schreibt in seinem Buch The Great Global Transformation, wie sich die Weltwirtschaft und die Weltpolitik wandelt. Es läuft zu auf einen nationalen Marktliberalismus in einer multipolaren Welt. Es ist ein sensationelles Buch, das uns auch vor Augen führt, dass wir uns eigentlich vor mehr globaler Gleichheit fürchten. Es ist ein Buch, das uns zeigt, dass America First keineswegs eine imperiale Geste ist, sondern eigentlich einen Rückzug ankündigt. Es ist ein sensationelles Buch, das sich mit dem Verhältnis des Westens zu China auseinandersetzt, die neun Eliten beschreibt, die mal gerade so zehn Millionen Dollar investieren, um ihre Sprösslinge weiter an der elitären Position zu halten. Es ist ein grandioses Buch, das man gelesen haben muss.
Jetzt hast du Sprösslinge im Plural gesagt. Die zehn Millionen gehen pro Kopf in diese Rechnung ein. Wir erlernen Unglaubliches. Es ist ein Buch, das einen ganz fantastischen Auftrag, den wir alle in uns spürten, mal wirklich erfüllt. Was hat diese Wirtschaft mit mir zu tun? Wir kriegen immer so viel Aufklärung über, was irgendwer, von dem wir sehen, er hat davon profitiert. Dann treibt er uns zur Arbeit. Dann ist der Podcast zu Ende und das war's. Diese Erklärung hier hat unmittelbar mit uns zu tun. Unser Schicksal wird hier verhandelt. Und zwar im globalen Maßstab und selten auf diesem knappen Raum so viel erfahren. Ich glaube, wir haben noch nie so lange über ein Buch gesprochen, weil es da so viel zu besprechen gibt. Also das ist wirklich eine Empfehlung.
Und 1992 sah es super aus in Deutschland, erfahren wir auch. Ja, ja, ja. Tja, ich bin im Mai 2022 aus der evangelischen Kirche ausgetreten, bekanntermaßen, weil ich sah, dass dort der Pazifismus offenbar kaum noch einen Platz findet. Jetzt hat die evangelische Kirche, die EKD, ein 150-seitiges Papier, eine Denkschrift vorgelegt, der neu verhandelt wird. Die evangelische Kirche Deutschlands. Das heißt, da sind dann die Landeskirchen verbunden. Also, EKD-Vorsitzende war ja auch mal Margot Käßmann. Von Margot Käßmanns Position hat man sich weit wegbewegt, wie wir gleich sehen werden. Diese Denkschrift, 150 Seiten lang, habe ich komplett gelesen. Ich dachte erst, ich überfliege das und hole ein paar Punkte mal raus. Und dann dachte ich, nee, man muss das ganz grundsätzlich durchgehen. Es ist entsetzlich. Es beginnt erst mal damit, dass man sagt, die Welt ist in Unordnung. Jetzt sehen wir schon aber Gewichtungen, die vorgenommen werden. Der völkerrechtswidrige russische Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine geht ins vierte Jahr. Seit dem Terrorakt der Hamas auf Israel am 7. Oktober 2023 verschärft sich die Situation im Nahen Osten immer weiter, mit grausamen humanitären Folgen. Einmal benennt man Ross und Reiter, beim zweiten Mal, da gibt es irgendwie und lassen wir mal.
Ist umstritten.
Ist umstritten. Was möchte man? Man möchte über gerechten Frieden reden. Also die FAG-Kirche hat sich ja nicht zum ersten Mal mit Krieg und Frieden beschäftigt und man geht also nicht von einem gerechten Krieg aus, sondern einem gerechten Frieden. Natürlich wissen wir an Orwell geschult, gerechter Frieden, gerechter Krieg. Naja, man kann natürlich nicht sagen, mehr heute als Kirche, wir wollen einen gerechten Krieg. Deshalb will man einen gerechten Frieden. Und dieser entsteht dort, heißt es im Papier, wo neben Waffenruhe auch Freiheit, Gerechtigkeitsperspektiven und ein friedensfördernder Umgang mit Pluralität aufscheinen. Damit ist aber ja schon gesagt, wo also nicht Freiheit, Gerechtigkeitsperspektiven und Umgang mit Pluralität aufscheinen, hätte man ja eigentlich schon ein Anrecht, da erstmal für gerechten Frieden zu sorgen. Das wird so nicht explizit gemacht, aber das schimmert ja damit drin. Zumal man ja überlegen kann, wenn dort steht, man möchte einen Abbau von Ungleichheiten, müsste man dann nicht den gerechten Frieden erstmal in diesem Land hier durchsetzen. Die Aufrüstung wird als richtig beschrieben. Gewaltfreiheit ist für Christinnen und Christen ein ethischer Grundsatz, der nicht an politische Zweckmäßigkeiten geknüpft ist. Dennoch ist Gewaltverzicht nicht in jeder Lage zwingend. Das liegt daran, dass wir zwar im Horizont der von Gott gegebenen Friedenshoffnung, aber zugleich in einer erlösungsbedürftigen Welt leben. Das heißt, man spaltet auf, ja grundsätzlich gibt es da das Reich Gottes. Wir haben von Gott gegeben diese Friedenshoffnung, aber die Welt ist ja noch nicht erlöst. Und solange die nicht erlöst ist, kann also Gewaltverzicht nicht die Lösung sein. Ja, okay. Zur Durchsetzung des Rechts kann Gewalt nötig sein, heißt es dann. Diese Gegengewalt wird in der Figur rechtserhaltender Gewalt gefasst. Rechtserhaltende Gewalt ist an sehr strenge Bindungen gebunden. Sie darf nur als Ultima Ratio angewendet werden, also dann, wenn alle gewaltfreien Mittel erschöpft sind. Sie muss darüber hinaus verhältnismäßig und mit friedenssichernder Absicht erfolgen. Das klingt so, als würde man sagen, naja, eigentlich schließen wir Gewalt aus bis auf. Aber gerade dieses Öffnen hin zu Ultima Ratio, also als letztes Mittel ist es möglich, lässt uns natürlich fragen, wer definiert denn das letzte Mittel? Wenn man jetzt Putin fragt, der wird auch sagen, ja, ich habe mit Engelszungen auf alle eingeredet, aber jetzt musste ich leider als letztes Mittel in die Ukraine einmarschieren. Das heißt, jeder sagt natürlich immer, es ist das letzte Mittel. Alle wollen Frieden, aber leider hier war es dann anders nicht möglich. Dieses Papier setzt sich mit dem christlichen Pazifismus auseinander, sagt dann auch gleich, als allgemeine politische Theorie sei das ethisch nicht zu begründen. Der christliche Pazifismus wird hier runtergedampft auf einen Ausdruck individueller Gewissensentscheidung. Aber dann kann man auch sagen, dann brauche ich den Pazifismus ja gar nicht. Dann kann ich das ja ganz mit mir alleine irgendwas ausmachen. Dann brauche ich das große Wort ja nicht, weil man ja offenbar nichts politisch davon ableiten kann. Es gibt kein Wort in diesem ganzen Text zum Verhältnis Individuum-Staat im Sinne von, dass die Staatsinteressen möglicherweise nicht die Interessen eines jeden Bürgers sind, dass die unterschieden sind. Also die erwünschte Pluralität, die wird hier gar nicht gesehen, sondern Staat und Individuum beziehungsweise Bürger. Das ist alles eins.
Wir.
Das sind wir. Das ist Frank-Walter Steinmeier. Es gibt vier Grundsätze über Gewalt und Krieg. Erstens, Jesus Christus hat den vollständigen Verzicht auf Gewalt gelehrt. Aha, da wäre ja eigentlich schon fast alles mitgesagt. Zweitens, sein Gebot der Nächsten und Feindesliebe ist ein ethisches Leitbild. Also auch das, sogar der Feindesliebe. Drittens, jeder Mensch ist ein gleichberechtigtes Geschöpf Gottes. Bedeutet also, ich kann mich nicht über dich stellen und geschweige denn dich umbringen. Viertens aber jetzt, wir leben in einer unerlösen Welt. Also ich brauche diesen ganzen theologischen Salat, wenn ich mich mal so ausdrücken darf. Natürlich nicht, wenn ich dann mal sage, ja, aber hier ist es dann anders.
Ja, das finde ich vor allem witzig. Hier gibt sich ja die Kirche offensichtlich einer weltlichen Lage geschlagen und packt dann aber ihr Repertoire der Erlösung da oben drauf, statt einfach zu sagen, ja, also das Eingeständnis, wir müssen hier schon auf was verzichten. Stattdessen macht man sich jetzt plötzlich diese weltliche Zwangslage zu eigen. Wohl wissentlich, dass man sie gar nicht durchblickt und dass es alternative Erklärungen gibt.
Friede bleibt Gabe Gottes, sein Gelingen liegt letztlich in Gottes Hand. Das heißt ja dann, der Mensch muss gar nicht unbedingt friedlich handeln, denn dass es dann Frieden gibt, das liegt in Gottes Hand. Dann kann man sagen, ja, dann war das offenbar nicht in Gottes Hand, da mussten wir jetzt noch mal ran.
Also das ist wirklich kurz vor, er hat sich für dich geopfert, jetzt opfer du dich auch für ihn.
Ja, dazu kommen wir gleich noch.
Ja?
Ja, ja, also nächsten, liebe, mal ganz neu gedacht. Dann wird das Individuum mal beschworen. So verstanden, bringt der Begriff der Sünde zum Ausdruck, was die Quelle von Hass und Gewalt bildet. Die Weigerung des Menschen, sich selbst und jeden Mitmenschen als Geschöpf Gottes zu achten. Auf so einer individuellen Ebene wird das jetzt gerade gesehen. Es wird aber dann so getan, als sei der Mensch nicht der Bürger. Weil als Bürger muss ich ja plötzlich, wenn ich jetzt in den Krieg ziehen soll, meinen Mitmenschen nicht mehr als Geschöpf Gottes betrachten, beziehungsweise muss dieses Geschöpf Gottes dann ja abknallen. Es wird aber dann so getan, als schätze der Staat grundsätzlich seine Bürger. Er tut es aber ja nicht, wenn wir sehen, dass zum Beispiel dann Männer nicht ausreisen dürfen. Und hier heißt es, die unterschiedlichen pazifistischen Traditionen in der Kirche haben eine wichtige Funktion. Da heißt es, die Haltung kategorischer Gewaltfreiheit hält die christliche Hoffnung auf das Kommen von Gottes Reich als einem Reich des Friedens präsent und lässt sich so als eine Zeichenhandlung verstehen. Das Zeichen ist einfach schön. Gut, dass wir das noch haben, so als Horizont. Aber bei der Abwehr gegen eine Besatzungsmacht und insbesondere bei der Verteidigung von Staatsgrenzen sind die Erfolgsaufsichten gewaltfreier Widerstands jedoch empirisch kaum zu belegen. Dass möglicherweise das Absichern von Staatsgrenzen vielleicht gar nicht der Wunsch eines Jedem ist, kann gar keine Rolle spielen und die Interessen des Staates müssen auch mit Gewalt durchgesetzt werden. Freiheit wird auch hier ganz klar an die Nation geknüpft. Da heißt es, Freiheit meint keine selbstbezogene Willkür, bei der das Individuum tun und lassen kann, was es möchte. Freiheit setzt immer eine soziale Welt voraus. So weit ja richtig, wir sind in Abhängigkeit zu anderen. Niemand kann für sich allein frei sein. Die Förderung von Freiheit bezieht sich daher von vornherein auf das Zusammenleben in der Gemeinschaft, sowohl national als auch international. Was passiert jetzt hier? Der Staat wird jetzt hier als Gemeinschaft beschrieben, aber international sind wir auch noch alle Mitmenschen. Das heißt, man vermengt hier argumentativ alles, um grundsätzlich Rechtfertigung zu können. Ja, wir müssen ja zusammenstehen, dann meistens aber erst mal als Nation. Ungleichheit hatten wir eben mal ja gehört, das ist ja auch ein Thema, aber über Steuern und Löhne lesen wir natürlich in dieser Schrift nichts.
Nee, geht ja auch nur um Außenpolitik, was?
Jetzt haben wir bei Milanović gesehen, mit dem politischen Westen ist es nicht immer so gut bestellt. Für die evangelische Kirche ist nach wie vor klar, das Leitbild sind hier unsere Werte. Die machen eigentlich noch mal den Rawls. Die machen einfach noch mal John Rawls, hier steht. Allerdings können die Förderung von Freiheit und der friedensfördernde Umgang mit Pluralität wohl nur in Staaten mit einer liberalen rechtsstaatlichen, auf Grund- und Menschenrechten aufbauenden Ordnung verwirklicht werden. Wenn ich das aber ernst nehme, muss ich sagen, dann sind hier alle anderen ein Problem. Und vielleicht muss ich da auch mal Frieden schaffen gehen. Es geht dann darum, dass man sich vor Gewalt schützen muss. Diejenige Bedrohung körperlicher Integrität, die von der aggressiven Infragestellung staatlicher Ordnungen im Falle eines Angriffskriegs ausgeht, ist dabei mit eingeschlossen. Hier ist schon kein Wort dazu, ob man vor Krieg fliegen darf, aber da kommen wir gleich zu. Kein Wort auch zur Gewalt gegenüber der eigenen Bevölkerung, denn im Staat wird man ja dann gezwungen, im Ernstfall zu kämpfen. Es wird so getan, als sei der Staat nur feindlich gegenüber den Bürgern, wenn der Bürger das Recht verletzt. Und solange das Recht nicht verletzt wird, ist der Staat gegen seinen Bürgern gegenüber im Recht laut der EKD. Nun haben wir aber ja den interessanten Fall, dass wir ein Kriegsrecht ausrufen können, bei dem wir dann einfach sagen, du darfst jetzt nicht fliehen. Dann hält der Staatssicher vollkommen an das Recht. Und dann würde er auch hier aus der EKD sagen, ja, dann ist ja gar kein Problem. Er hat sich doch ans Recht gehalten. Schlimm wäre nur Willkür. Wenn jetzt der eine rausgezogen wird, der andere nicht oder so, dann wäre das ein bisschen korrupt. Das wäre nicht rechtens. Wie ist denn mit diesen ganzen Begriffen, die wir überall hören, kriegstüchtig? Könnte man nicht jetzt wenigstens sagen, wir machen mal so eine Sprachkritik. Pass auf. Sprache kann das Denken in Kategorien des Krieges befördern oder eben ihm entgegenwirken. Daher sollte Kriegstüchtigkeit nur als eine erläuternde Bestimmung von Verteidigungsfähigkeit gebraucht werden und auf keinen Fall ungekehrt. Also wir können weiter auch kriegstüchtig.
Warum glaubt die evangelische Kirche, sie müsste jetzt entschuldigungsschreiben für CDU-Sprachwahl.
Für Ruderich Kiesewetter? Ja. Es ist mir ein Rätsel. Also ohne Not machen alles. Die machen alles. Also die gehen ja drohnen. Drohnen werden nicht abgelehnt. KI-Waffensysteme, wird nur mal alles so leicht problematisiert. Da heißt es dann, wenn Maschinen enorme Datenmengen erfassen und auswerten, kann unklar werden, wer für militärische Entscheidungen, konkrete Handlungen, Verantwortung trägt. Das ist besonders bedrohlich, wenn Entscheidungen über Leben und Tod automatisiert vorbereitet und sogar durch eine KI getroffen werden. Das wird in der Konsequenz für die Klärung von Schuldfragen und dann auch für Versöhnungsprozesse nach militärischen Konflikten bedeutsam werden. Also man sagt, na so ganz ist das vielleicht blöder, aber es ist nun mal so, wie es ist. Aus friedensethischer Sicht müssen alle sicherheits- und rüstungspolitischen Maßnahmen dem Ziel dienen, Frieden zu sichern und internationale Kooperation zu fördern. In allem müssen sie letztlich die Sicherheit der Menschen zu Maßstab haben. Deshalb darf Sicherheitspolitik niemals ausschließlich auf militärische Stärke setzen. Ja wer setzt denn ausschließlich auf militärische Stärke? Also selbst Putin und Kim Jong-un setzen nicht ausschließlich auf militärische Stärke. Das ist ja so offen gehalten, da kannst du ja alles mitmachen. Es wird gesagt, dass Verhandlungen nur dann gut sind, wenn sie nicht aufgezwungen sind. Nun wissen wir aber ja aus der Geschichte, dass man ja nicht verhandelt, weil man sagt, Mensch, das war mal ein schönes, eine nette Idee von dir, dass wir mal verhandeln.
Ich fühle mich gerade so stark, jetzt verhandle ich.
Sondern Verhandlungen sind natürlich aufgezwungen. Nämlich demjenigen, der in einer schlechteren Position ist. Weshalb da ja Trump Recht hat, wenn er immer wieder betont, die Ukraine hat keine guten Karten mehr in der Hand oder gar keine Karten in der Hand. Das ist so. Hier heißt es dann, aufgezwungene Verhandlungen sind kein Weg zum gerechten Frieden. Verhandlungen, die lediglich dazu dienen, die Ergebnisse militärischer Kriegsführung abzusichern, sind abzulehnen. Ja, dann fragt man sich, wo soll es stattdessen hingehen? Kleiner Exkurs, Fake News.
Ich meine, die Kirche klärt uns jetzt über Fake News auf.
Genau die Pointe wollte ich machen.
Okay, gut. Ich bin gespannt, was da steht. Trag vor.
Ja, also die Kirche, wo alles ja immer genau wissenschaftlich abgesichert ist, auch das mit dem lieben Gott. Also ich bin ja gläubig, aber hier verlieren wir den Glauben an vielem jetzt. Ganz gezielt werden durch falsche Informationen und oder Deepfakes eine Polarisierung der Gesellschaft vorangetrieben, machtvoll einseitig Stimmungen beeinflusst und macht ausgeübt. Also so würde ich ja hinzufügen wie bei Gabor Steingart. Ja, daher gilt es auf der einen Seite die friedensgefährdenden Nutzung des Raumes einzuhägen. Das heißt, wir brauchen jetzt Regulierungen, welche wird dann nicht gesagt. Aber dann würde ich sagen, ja, dann muss man erst mal so eine Denkschrift verbieten. Also könnte ich jetzt auch sagen, das gehen wir jetzt nicht mehr mit. Es ist möglich, dass unter zur Hilfenahme der sich ständig weiter entwickelten Techniken auch wirksame Optionen bestehen, um der hybriden Kriegsführung begegnen zu können, etwa durch digitale Tools, die Falschbehauptungen zu identifizieren helfen. Diese digitalen Tools programmiert dann die EKD und sagt, da haben sie aber falsch gelegen.
Manche Sachen sind prinzipiell ausgeschlossen sehr man sie sich auch wünscht, wie zum Beispiel mal ein Zeichen von Gott zu bekommen, gibt es dann einfach nicht. Eigentlich findet man damit einen guten Umgang. Ich weiß nicht genau, warum das jetzt nicht mehr klappt.
Ich finde es auch immer schade, dass nicht alle meiner Meinung sind, aber ich habe damit gelernt zu leben. Multi-Polarität, die Stärke des Rechts droht durch das Recht des Stärkeren ersetzt zu werden. Nein, wir haben bei Branko Milanović gesehen, das Recht des Stärkeren war auf Seiten des politischen Westens. Jetzt verschiebt sich das alles. Und jetzt gibt es...
In Äthiopien macht es gerade keinen Unterschied, ob wir die Regeln machen oder China. Ja. China bringt halt noch Geld mit, statt nur Sonntagsrede. Da ist ein Unterschied. Aber ansonsten...
Atomare Aufrüstung, das war ja... Oh! Also ja, du... Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Ich kenne ja deine Position dazu.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt.
Ich will es nur in einen Kontext setzen. Die evangelische Kirche und die Anti-Aufrüstungsbewegung, anti-atomare Aufrüstung, überhaupt die Anti-Atomkraft-Bewegung. Das hängt alles sehr eng zusammen. Ja, also alles ganz eng. Hier heißt es jetzt, hinsichtlich der nuklearen Abschreckung und der nuklearen Teilhabe lassen sich keine eindeutigen, ethisch begründeten Vorgaben treffen, sondern lediglich die genannten Dilemma festhalten. Diejenigen, die als Volksvertretung diese schwierige Abwägung vornehmen müssen, denjenigen ist in dieser Entscheidung zur Seite zu stehen. Also wir Bürger sollen, egal was der Fritz jetzt macht, sagen, zu Weihem Gott helfe. Das ist einfach die Sache.
Wir stehen an deiner Seite.
Ja.
Darf ich den Knopf drücken?
Präventivkriege. Wissen wir eigentlich, geht nicht.
Also jedes Mal, wenn jetzt ein Thema aufwerfen, habe ich Angst, dass sie nur wieder irgendwas begründen wollen, was ich für unbegründbar halte, wenn jetzt sagst du Präventivkriege.
Ja. Also du hast ja hier viele Clips damals mitgebracht, Israels Angriffe auf den Iran. Wir lesen das mal jetzt vor diesem Hintergrund. Allerdings, also ganz viele Sätze fangen mit allerdings an. Man muss sich das so vorstellen, immer drei Seiten der Pazifismus, eine lange Tradition und Jesus Christus. Allerdings kann die Eigenart der abzuwendenden Gefahr eine Rolle bei der Anwendung der anerkannten Kriterien für rechtmäßige Selbstverteidigung spielen, also insbesondere der Unmittelbarkeit des bevorstehenden Angriffs sowie der Notwendigkeit und Verhältnismäßigkeit militärischer Abwehrmaßnahmen. Das hängt mit den kaum vorstellbaren Folgen eines eventuellen Gebrauchs nuklearer Waffen zusammen. Daher kann sich in Extremszenarien die Frage stellen, ob bei der Entwicklung von Massenvernichtungswaffen durch einen Staat bereits dann eine unmittelbare Angriffsgefahr vorliegt, wenn Trägesysteme und Einsatzbereitschaft absehbar sind, ohne dass ein konkreter Angriff direkt bevorsteht.
Okay, verstehe.
Heißt, alles richtig gemacht in Sachen Iran?
Also, ja. Steht da auch drin, wo genau man in China hinschießen muss, um deren Atomwaffen zu treffen? Natürlich nur präventiv.
Weiß ich nicht, da muss ein Bischof nochmal anschreiben oder so.
Die scheinen sich ja wirklich Gedanken gemacht zu haben.
Jaja, die gehen da alle möglichen Dinge noch durch, die ich jetzt hier nicht mitbekommen habe. In einer Kleinteiligkeit, bei der man denkt, wofür wollt ihr jetzt nur noch mal beweisen, dass ihr eigentlich auch die NATO leiten könntet und so. Also, das ist ganz verrückt. So, jetzt aber das große Finale mit dem Thema Wehrdienst.
Ah ja, ist ja noch offen.
Wir kennen ja dieses Gebot, du sollst nicht töten, aber im Krieg allerdings ist das anders. Sie kommen wieder auf diese individuelle Gewissensentscheidung zu sprechen. Und jetzt ist aber das interessanterweise umgedreht. Also, man darf aus ethischen Gründen ja verweigern, aber es ist nur noch, eigentlich bist du in einem Rechtfertigungszwang, dass du verweigerst.
Ja, klar.
Weiterhin gilt es zu klären, ob die Verweigerung des Dienstes mit der Waffe in einer gewaltvollen Welt mit einer Ethik resoniert, die sich dem Schutz vor Gewalt, dem Eintreten für Recht und Gerechtigkeit und somit dem Dienst an dem Nächsten verpflichtet fühlt. Das heißt, du musst dich als derjenige, der den Kriegsdienst verweigert. Noch mal besonders prüfen, ob du nicht gegen die Nächstenliebe verstößt. Nicht umgekehrt. Nicht diejenigen, die sagen, ja, aber es muss trotzdem sein, sondern du bist in der Pflicht.
Naja, immerhin steht da schon drin, dass ich nicht für das deutsche Vaterland, sondern für meinen Nachbar, der leider schon zu alt ist für den Kampfkämpfer.
Das ist natürlich hier alles eins. Dein Nachbar ist das deutsche Vaterland und so weiter.
Na klar.
Wehrpflicht sagen sie ja, aber doch vielleicht nicht nur für Männer. Besser wäre sowieso erstmal eine Dienstpflicht für alle, denn da könne man dann auch christliche Nächstenliebe leben. Und dann hätte man auch gar nicht mehr so diese Debatte um Männer oder Frauen hier zum Wehrpflicht. Aber das finden sie ein bisschen problematisch. Das ist wahrscheinlich der Bischöfin zu wenig inklusiv.
Das ist die evangelische Herangehensweise. Wir haben ja die Frauen hier immer ernst genommen und natürlich auch dabei.
Gefragt wird dann mal so zwischendrin, kann ich verpflichtet werden, mein Leben aufs Spiel zu setzen, und zwar auch gegen meinen Willen und wenn ja, unter welchen Bedingungen und für welche gesellschaftliche Ordnung? Die Antwort, ja, da muss man sehen, dass man das Urteilsvermögen schärft.
Ja, Medienbildung halt vorher.
Einfach EKD-Texte lesen und dann weiß man, ob man sein Leben aufs Spiel setzt. Selbst wenn man dazu gezwungen wird, also dann brauche ich mir die Frage ja auch nicht mehr zu beantworten, wenn ich dafür gezwungen werde. Dann kann ich ja nichts anderes machen, als dann mein Leben zu opfern. Aus der Tradition der evangelischen Ethik heraus ist gut begründbar, dass sich Einzelne für die Sicherheit des Gemeinwesens in die Pflicht nehmen lassen, gerade dann, wenn dieses sich dem Recht und der Sicherheit aller Mitglieder verpflichtet weiß. Diese Pflicht lässt sich als eine Konkretion der Nächstenliebe verstehen, indem man sich für das Gemeinwesen als Ganzes einsetzt. Das heißt also, der Zwang wird hier einfach als eine Konkretion von Nächstenliebe umgeschrieben. Deswegen finde ich das ja alles viel schlimmer, als was von, wie heißen sie alle, wie Marcella Claudia Major oder Mark Rutte kommt. Die gehen ja einfach machtpolitisch daran und sagen, du hast es ja zu tun. Aber die verkaufen, die bieten ja noch den religiösen Überbau hier mit. Also erst der richtige Christ stimmt gezwungenermaßen der Verpflichtung freiwillig zu.
Ja, das ist die Gabor-Steingart-Taktik, die es dir nochmal einreden möchte, dass du es aus eigenen Stücken, weil der Wohlstand und dann wird ja befreimdigt, dass es gar nicht da ist.
Jetzt fragt man sich aber, also wirklich Pflicht oder Freiwilligkeit? Erstmal sagen sie, Pflicht zur Musterung ist gar kein Problem. Also das steht gar nicht in irgendeinem Konflikt, das gewährleistet im Prinzip die freie Entscheidung. Dann, damit ist aber zugleich auch deutlich, dass eine solche Pflicht zunächst als eine individuelle, selbst empfundene Verpflichtung zu sehen ist. Also du musst sie erst mal selbst verpflichten. Eine Rechtspflicht ist dem gegenüber aus evangelisch-ethischer Perspektive stets als nachgeordnet zu betrachten. Sie ist nur dann begründbar, wenn nicht genügend Freiwillige zur Verfügung stehen.
Ja, schlagend, treffend, logisch.
Ja, also wenn sich nicht alle ein Herz nehmen und die EKD-Schrift nehmen und dann sagen, so muss es sein, ich verpflichte mich, wenn das nicht gelingt, dann muss einfach Zwang her. Und dann ist es auch gut. Das ist aus evangelischer Perspektive toll. Sie haben dann so einen Lapsus drin. Sonst ist natürlich also ganz vorsichtig formuliert, aber Sie haben so eine Sache drin. Da sprechen Sie nämlich über den Mensch eigentlich als Ressource für den Staat. Da heißt es, ein Gemeinwesen muss nicht nur über Ausreichende, sondern vor allem auch über bedarfsgerechte Ressourcen verfügen. Das gilt auch für diejenigen, die sich für die Belange der Gemeinschaft in die Pflicht nehmen lassen. Die Bedürfnisse des Gemeinwesens setzt der Wahlfreiheit des Einzelnen, die sich für andere engagieren, grenzen.
Wie konnte das denn passieren?
Ja, wir sind einfach, ja Sie haben dann Menschenmaterial ist man im Prinzip für die evangelische Kirche. Und das haben Sie jetzt einmal hier transparent gemacht. Und noch sehr schön dieser Satz, die Bedürfnisse des Gemeinwesens setzt der Wahlfreiheit des Einzelnen, die sich für andere engagieren möchten, grenzen. Das heißt, mit der Wahlfreiheit, da müssen wir schauen.
Also ich glaube, hier fehlt die Einsicht, dass das Argument gilt, was ich immer im Fernsehen höre, nämlich dass Vladimir Putin dieser Krieg überhaupt nur möglich ist, indem man Leute in diesen Krieg hinein, in diesen Krieg hinein trickst. Also entweder über so einen krassen staatlichen Befehl, der dann auch weitergegeben wird im Sinne von Kim Jong-un schickt auch ein paar Leute und die sind dann plötzlich irgendwo keine Ahnung und müssen halt so ein bisschen durch den Wald rennen. Oder aber man geht so in die Provinz und verheimlicht das aber den Leuten in Moskau, dass da gerade groß rekrutiert wird und so weiter und so fort. Und warum glauben die, dass das woanders anders wäre? Also es ist doch derselbe Krieg.
Ja, die machen gegen alle Halter freiwillig. Machen die alle, sagen die Ho-Raa.
Man könnte ja fast sagen, die deutsche Wirtschaft ist wenigstens nicht so verlogen, den Leuten kein Gehalt zu zahlen, weil Jesus Christus. Da kriegt man einfach ganz normal ein Gehalt, bei dem man selber dann ein bisschen aus freien Stücken sagt, okay, ich mache es jetzt für 14 Euro die Stunde. Ich habe ja jetzt zumindest Feierabend. So, und wenn jetzt jemand eine Dienstleistung haben möchte, und da sollten auch alle Beteiligten sehr aufpassen, denn so langsam zieht mich auch Ole auf seine Seite der Argumentation. Also was ist nochmal genau mit Solidarität und Staat gemeint? Wer ist das? Warum soll ich dem einfach, nur weil schöne Worte gesagt wurden, folgen? Das ist doch absurd. Niemand macht das. Das funktioniert vielleicht bei Dreijährigen in der Erziehung. Dass man sagt, komm, jetzt zieh die Schuhe an. Ansonsten können wir nie Riesenrad fahren. So, ja? Da klappt das vielleicht. Aber ansonsten werden Sachen bitte hier verrechnet und verhückert. Und wenn jemand ein Leben haben will, dann muss er halt wie Putin in den sauren Apfel beißen und der Familie schon vorher sagen, falls das hier schief geht, 100.000 Dollar.
Stefan, du denkst natürlich wahnsinnig egoistisch. Das ist nicht christlich. Hier heißt es nämlich, christlich gesehen kann es nicht um die Durchsetzung persönlicher Vorlieben gehen, sondern um die Bereitschaft, sich gemäß der eigenen Gaben für andere und für das Gemeinwesen einzusetzen.
Ja, da würde ich sagen, jeder macht es bitte. Ich möchte hiermit sagen, ich halte mich einfach für einen sehr guten Dampfplauderer. Meine Gabe ist der Podcast. Zum Glück bin ich in der richtigen Zeit geboren. Es gibt jetzt Podcasts, also mache ich Podcasts. Bin leider nicht zu gebrauchen.
Fürs Gewehr.
Ich kann nur Leute totquatschen.
Ich meine, die ganzen Pfarrer und so, vielleicht wollen die sich ja eine Grundausbildung unterziehen. Das ist wirklich der reine Wahnsinn, dass hier wirklich dem Individuum gesagt wird, du bist am Ende null und nicht dich, und dann immer vom Gemeinwesen gesprochen wird, wo man einfach staatliche Macht meint. Man meint hier nicht die Kirchengemeinde, in der jetzt der eine sagt, ich mache einen Kuchen, mach du einen Salat und dann treffen wir uns morgen Abend. Nein, das geht hier um den Staat. Und jetzt wirklich das Letzte dazu. Also ich finde interessant. Ich meine, dieser Text existiert jetzt seit drei Wochen, glaube ich. Es gibt natürlich irgendwelche Pressemeldungen dazu. Aber dass es da keinen Aufschrei gibt innerhalb der evangelischen Kirche, dass da nicht jetzt die Leute scharenweise austreten, finde ich unglaublich, wenn man das hier liest. Oder wo sind eigentlich die Journalisten, die das mal kritisch begleiten? Das kann man doch nicht einfach nur sagen. Evangelische Kirche ändert ihre Haltung zu atomarer Aufrüstung. Und das ist dann die Meldung. Nee, hier steckt noch ein bisschen mehr drin. Also das ist Wahnsinn. Und jetzt der letzte Satz habe ich wirklich jetzt, ich fasse es nicht mehr, weil wir ja Debatten hatten seit 2015 darüber, Asylrecht von Kirchen. Oh, ja. Dass die Kirchen sich ja so...
Was mit den Kirchen asylieren?
Nee, darüber reden sie jetzt nicht, über das Kirchenasyl. Aber wir haben darüber ja gesprochen, dass wir sagen, wir schützen diese Menschen. Vor Abschiebungen, die bleiben hier in den Kirchen. Da haben sich ja doch einige wahrgemutig hervorgetan. Also war damit immer klar, dass man vor Krieg fliehen kann. Das war absolutes... Also das war das erste Gebot, wenn man so möchte. Jetzt steht hier, wenn es der angegriffene Staat nicht ermöglicht, sich an der rechtmäßigen Verteidigung des eigenen Landes anders als mit einem Dienst, mit der Waffe zu beteiligen, ist aus ethischen Überlegungen heraus die Gewährung von Asyl unverzichtbar. Bedeutet also, man wird nicht mehr einfach vor Krieg fliehen dürfen, solange der Staat dann sagt, naja, also wir haben jetzt auch noch was anderes dir hier anzubieten. Du musst nicht an die Front, aber du kannst jetzt hier das und das dann tun. Dann ist auch selbst das nicht mehr möglich.
Du hast ja bei mir schon ein Interesse an Christentum jetzt mitbekommen. Und mir ist ja die Rolle des Gottes nicht so wichtig. Mir ist auch die Kirchentrennung zwischen katholisch und evangelisch nicht so wichtig. Soll ich langsam, glaube ich, ich bin einer dieser neun Christen, die das alte Zeug hinter sich lassen.
Ja.
Und ehrlich gesagt, die lassen es ja auch hinter sich. Also ich lese hier auch das Ende einer Zeit, als das Christentum so und so verhandelt wurde. Und ich will daran erinnern, das Christentum war nicht, ach ja, Gott, Jesus kam auf die Erde, wurde geboren von irgendwie, keine Ahnung und so. Und jetzt bauen wir mal eine Kirche. Sondern die ersten 400, 500 Jahre bis dann zur großen Wende im Rom und wir haben eben bei Milanović schon, das ist dann das christliche Reich in Buzhans, also heutiges Istanbul und so. Die ersten 400 Jahre war das einfach so eine Sekte, die sich so ein bisschen in irgendwelchen Höhen getroffen hat. Und das Christentum wird auch überleben, um jetzt noch mal wieder neu geboren zu werden aus so einer 400-jährigen Sekte- und Höhlezeit, in der man noch mal in Geschichtsbüchern nachlässt, wie die letzten Christen, in Anführungszeichen, das in Grunde boden gerammt haben, was dann als Erbe eigentlich da war. Also in der Ansicht, ja, das ist ein sehr gutes Comedy-Programm, was du uns gerade dargeboten hast. Die evangelische Kirche ist so ein bisschen...
Ja, mit Christentum hat das nichts mehr zu tun. Also es ist völlig verrückt und hier Hardcore...
Also die CDU heißt auch christlich Demokratische Union. Nur weil die evangelische Kirche irgendwas mit christlich heißt, die Distanzen sind entsprechend da.
Also ich erwarte wirklich, dass das jetzt mal medial noch aufgegriffen wird und das kann doch nicht so durchgehen. Also ich bin wirklich fassungslos und ich...
Das ist dein Warten auf Godot jetzt.
Ich würde gleich noch noch einmal austreten, wenn ich könnte. Man spart doch viel Geld.
Ja, das habe ich gehört. Misstrauensgemeinschaften heißt das Buch von Aladin Elmar Falani. Es beginnt mit folgendem Szenario, dem wir alle nachvollziehen können. In den vergangenen Jahren hat er mehrfach die Erfahrung gemacht, dass Menschen ihn persönlich vertrauen. Aber sobald er in Rolle des Wissenschaftlers spricht, kommt doch Skeptis auf. Und dann wird selbst ihm, dem gestandenen Wissenschaftler mit Publikationsgeschichte, Lehrauftrag und so weiter, ein TikTok-Video oder ein YouTube-Video untergejubelt mit der Beigabe, ich glaube da ist was dran, vielleicht kann ich dich damit überzeugen. Und aus dieser Erfahrung heraus hat er gesagt, ich mache mal eine Vorlesungsreihe, also eine Vorlesung der Wissenssoziologie in Dortmund und aus den intensiven Diskussionen mit den Studenten hat er jetzt folgenden Band vorgelegt, 128 Seiten, so grob 100 zum Thema Vertrauen und Misstrauen. Und es geht in diesem Text also um das Misstrauen, das inzwischen ganze gesellschaftliche Teilbereiche, wie er schreibt, erreicht hat und zu diskussionswürdigen Veränderungen führt. Seine soziologische Perspektive schreibt er hier explizit, es handelt sich um eine soziologische Perspektive, bei der sozioökonomische Ungleichheiten nicht im Vordergrund stehen. Und ich denke mir, du bist ein Soziologe und hast dir gerade das Thema Vertrauen rausgesucht. Vertrauen ist zum einen Semantik für die evangelische Kirche, um Sonntagsreden zu halten. Zum anderen ist es eins zu eins ein funktionales Äquivalent für Geld. Wer Geld hat, muss nicht vertrauen, da kann sich einfach Sachen kaufen und wenn es nicht klappt, Rechtsweg und so weiter. Das heißt, man kann nicht über Vertrauen reden, abhandeln, ohne Geld und damit auch soziale Ungleichheit, ökonomische Schieflagen, was auch immer, halt Asymmetrien. Es geht ja um Asymmetrien. Jemand hat Unsicherheitserleben, jemand merkt, die Welt, in der ich mich bewege, ist viel größer als ich selber. Also wie gleiche ich das jetzt aus? Wie komme ich hier zurecht? Und da einfach zu sagen, ja, sozioökonomische Ungleichheiten nehme ich jetzt mal nicht mit in den Blick. Ist irgendwie schräg. Da fragt man sich auf Seite eins dann, was kommt denn jetzt 99 Seiten? Also, wir machen mal nur die eine Seite der Medaille. Eine Unterscheidung hat auf jeden Fall schon mal eine interessante Seite und die andere lassen wir einfach weg. So, ja, das ist irgendwie total komisch. Nun gut, ich finde ja Vertrauen, wenn man es ernsthaft als regulative Situation geprägt von Unsicherheit vorstellt, ja, was machen wir dann die ganze Zeit? Genau das mit Geld bewältigen. Nun gut, die Möglichkeit, dass individuelles Versagen ursächlich für Misstrauen sein kann, wird nicht verneint in seinem Text, aber auch nicht als wesentliche Erklärung angesehen. Vielmehr geht es um strukturelle Veränderung, Krisenerscheinungen und so weiter. Jetzt haben wir zweieinhalb Stunden über einen Text uns gebeugt, der sagt, bitte in Relation denken, bitte bilanzieren. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wenn der Soziologe hier das individuelle Versagen als ursächlich für Misstrauen beschreibt. Was ist der Maßstab für individuelles Versagen, wenn nicht Strukturen und Krisenerscheinungen?
Habe ich individuell versagt, wenn ich von meinen Eltern nicht 10 Millionen für eine gute Ausbildung bekomme? Oder gibt es dann strukturelles Versagen?
Ja, also über Vertrauen reden, aber Geld ausblenden. Individuelles Versagen, ursächlich für Misstrauen in den Blick nehmen, aber strukturelle Veränderungen und Krisenerscheinungen außen vor lassen. Das geht doch gar nicht, würde der kleine Kevin im Laden fragen, wenn ihn die Frau fragt, bist du sieben, bist du hier alleine? Nein, meine Eltern sind da drüben. Das geht doch gar nicht sonst. Ja. Ich weiß auch nicht, das ist ein Stolperstein nach dem anderen. Dann wird natürlich, das ist ja dann auch die Einschlage, die Einflugsschneise für so evangelische Texte, wie wir es eben hatten. Die liberale Demokratie steht halt zur Disposition, also muss jetzt darüber geschrieben werden, ist ja klar. Die Soziologie ist eine Disziplin, die wie keine andere Krisen, sozialen Wandel und nicht intendierte Nebenfolgen verstehen und erklären kann. Vielleicht macht der folgende Text das erkennbar. Naja, er hat es bis hierhin nicht erkennbar gemacht. Und wenn du so eine Präampel vorausbringen musst, würde ich sagen, die Kommunikation von Aufrichtigkeit führt zu Zweifeln. Wir wollen ja gerade plausible Argumentation, die diese Präampel nicht braucht. Gerade beim Thema Vertrauen, aber ich finde grundsätzlich bei allen soziologischen Arbeiten. Denn wir haben ja kein Labor, wo es einfach heißt, das ist die Tabelle der Ergebnisse, wenn du sie nicht verstehst, dein Bildungsdefizit. Sondern das findet halt hier in Gesellschaft statt. Und Vertrauen ist überhaupt nur interessant, weil Leute Vertrauen haben oder eben nicht. Und wenn man denen dann einfach sagt, aber jetzt glaub mir doch, dann fehlt das irgendwie in die Irre. Wem Vertrauen Misstrauen? Das ist natürlich, im Grunde wollte er einfach nur ein Tweet schreiben, mit diesem besonderen Hinweis. Vertrauen wird nur noch aufgebaut, weil Leute zeigen, dass sie misstrauen. Und die Misstrauen bilden dann eine Gemeinschaft, nämlich die Misstrauensgemeinschaft gegen die Vertrauenden.
Und die kommen dann irgendwo alle zusammen, oder was ist mit denen?
Ja, also das kann man als Bild, glaube ich, so aufmachen. Aber die Argumentation, da muss man sich dann wirklich Mühe geben, weil es wird dann so ein bisschen heikel. Wie zum Beispiel, wenn er dann schreibt, stellen wir uns kurz vor, jeder Mensch würde allen anderen Menschen vertrauen. Dieses wechselseitige Vertrauen würde uns enormen finanziellen, zeitlichen und nervlichen Aufwand sparen. Und ich sage, nein, gerade nicht. Denn Vertrauen ist ja von Definition her, und hier kommt bei ihm auch eine Verwechslung von Vertrauen und Vertrautheit, kommt aus dieser Vertrautheit. Also stellen wir uns vor, wir würden allen anderen Menschen vertrauen.
Das ist ja wie das kleine Kind, das mit jedem mitgeht. Das will man hier gerade nicht.
Genau. Das kleine Kind, also selbst das kleine Kind, hat ein Urvertrauen den Eltern gegenüber. Aber sobald es den Fremden sieht, kriegt es so hinter das Bein der Mutter und guckt erst mal so. So, selbst das ist nicht einfach so gegeben. Es gibt Kinder, die würden mit allen mitgehen, aber das ist dann auch schon wieder so eine, würde man pedagogisch sofort sagen, ups und so um es mal an. Also diese Idee davon, wenn wir uns alle vertrauen würden, könnten wir uns ganz viel sparen. Das stimmt ja nicht, weil das Vertrauen wäre nur denkbar, nachdem wir ganz viel Zeit investiert haben, um Vertrautheit herzustellen. Und sobald jemand Unbekanntes die Bühne betritt, ist wieder Unsicherheit da. Wer ist das denn? Dann muss das wieder ewig aufgebaut werden und so. Dieses ganze Bild gibt es so einfach gar nicht. Das ist sozusagen eine totale Verwechslung der Grundbegriffe, weil man kann nicht einfach sagen, mit Vertrauen meine ich jetzt, was wir in Sonntagsreden meinen. Aber das Eigentliche, nämlich, dass wir uns vertraut sind, das blende ich mal aus, dass das ganz viel Anbahnung und vor allem Ressource Zeit verbraucht. Nicht ohne Grund sagen wir ja später, wenn wir erwachsen sind, Zeit ist Geld und verrechnen das, weil da kann man das verrechnen. Aber beim Vertrauen an sich nicht. Also wenn wir Geld sozusagen außen vor lassen, müssen wir Zeit investieren. Ansonsten können wir keine Vertrautheit aufbauen. Also hier schon Schieflagen.
Zumal man ja auch mit manchen Leuten einfach kein Vertrauen aufbauen will. Oder ich kann dann höchstens darauf vertrauen, dass Gabriel Steingart auch nächstes Jahr wieder Unsinn reden wird.
Ja, das ist hier eine implizite große Stolperfalle, diesen Text, dass Vertrauen und Misstrauen dieselbe Funktion haben, nämlich Erwartungen zu stabilisieren. Und ich dann einfach sage, dir vertraue ich, mir dir bringe ich gern meine Zeit, also schnell abgehandelt. Herr Steingart, ihn vertraue ich nicht, mit ihm verbringe ich nicht gern meine Zeit, auch schnell abgehandelt. Das war das Vorzeichen anders. Und man würde die Sonntagsrede drumherum auf der Semantikebene anders schreiben. Aber strukturell gesehen ist das ja genau dasselbe. Da wurde einfach nur Vertrauen gegen Misstrauen ausgetauscht. Aber wir haben es nicht mit funktionaler Äquivalenz zu tun, wie wir tauschen Vertrauen gegen Geld und haben dann wirklich eine andere Gesellschaft. Plötzlich können wir mit Millionen Unbekannten einfach Handel treiben, was halt einfach nur mit der Unterscheidung Vertrauen, Misstrauen nicht geht. Weil wir können nicht auf den Markt gehen und sagen, dir vertraue ich nicht, ja dann ist die Konsequenz, dann handle ich nicht mit dir. Also dann tausche ich nicht mit dir. Also das ist einfach komplett durcheinander. Und dann denkst du, wenn ich das lese, ist das einfach nicht gut. Vertrauen. In wen und in was? Er hat natürlich dieses Vertrautheitsbild, also wir begegnen uns als Menschen und vertrauen uns da nicht. Und wenn wir Christian Drosten im Radio hören, dann ist das auch, das ist eine Person, also vertrauen wir dem jetzt oder nicht? Und ich denke mir so, nee, das Thema Vertrauen ist erstmal nicht eine Sache, die sich unbedingt auf spezifisch anderes richtet, sondern auf so eine eigene Einstellung von mir, nämlich, also können wir jetzt philosophisch auf die Spitze treiben, aber vertraue ich eigentlich mir in dem Glauben, dass das jetzt gut geht, gehe ich das Risiko ein, oder muss ich danach, was weiß ich, für Ressourcen aufwenden? Alles wieder aufräumen, wenn vertrauensvoll am Wochenende doch die Wohnung mit einer Party zerstört wurde, obwohl alle sagten, wir machen hier keine Party, oder brauche ich irgendwo Geld oder irgendwas und so. Holt mich wirklich jemand ab, oder muss ich mir jetzt ein Auto organisieren? Dieses Vertrauen beginnt in die eigenen, was weiß ich, Handlungsmöglichkeiten, wird es reichen, wie auch immer. Vertrauen ist ja einfach nur Person A, Person B. Dann kommt natürlich später dieses, ach ja, das System Vertrauen. Luhmann schrieb ja vom System Vertrauen. Er greift aber von dem Vertrauensbuch wirklich nur den, Luhmann macht selber mal einen Scherz darüber, dass man ohne Vertrauen gar nicht leben kann. Stellen sie sich vor, sie wachen morgens auf und sie vertrauen niemanden. Sie führen ja ein ganz ängstliches, einsames Leben. So, dass Luhmann seine Texte am Anfang mit einem pointen Einstieg, um alte Denkweisen abzuholen, eröffnet und danach eine Entfaltung macht, des neuen Denkens, ist ja eigentlich soziologisches Standardwissen. Weshalb man nicht einfach nur die erste Seite zitieren sollte, in seinem eigenen Buch zum Thema, also das alte Denken, ohne dann das neue Denken aufzugreifen.
Ja, das hätten wir ja auch ohne Luhmann gewusst.
Luhmann schreibt ja genau am Anfang das, was alle wissen, weil sie mal kurz intuitiv, ach ja, vertrauen. Und danach wird man soziologisch überrascht, durch eine Aufklärung, die man vorher für nicht denkbar hielt. Bis dahin kommt man gar nicht. Stattdessen hier Thesen. Die erste These, dieses Buch ist schnell erzählt. Ein subjektiv rationales Verhalten ist dann, man vertraut anderen Menschen, die misstrauen, also diese Misstrauensgemeinschaften, die sich bilden. Er nimmt dieses Corona-Beispiel. Christian Drosten, wen sonst? Eine Person, man braucht natürlich einen Protagonisten. Also wir sind hier voll in dieser journalistischen Denke. Das hat mit Soziologien nichts zu tun. So, Christian Drosten wird hier also vorangestellt, das ist ein Wortlaut, es lässt sich aus dieser spezifischen Perspektive als rational begreifen, dass bestimmte Menschen während der Corona-Krise, etwa Christian Drosten, wesentlich weniger vertrauten oder gar misstrauten als einer wildfremden Person, die weder Funktion noch Qualifikation hat, sondern einfach sagt, Ile Mask hat hier was getweetet, guck das mal an, ist doch auch plausibel. So, ich denke mir so ein bisschen, oder auch, ob er hier schreibt, es ist reine subjektive Rationalität, dass Menschen so ein Vertrauensverhalten haben. Und ich denke mir, nee, hier kommt was ganz anderes im Bild. Christian Drosten ist eine austauschbare Schifre, von der ich jetzt immer sage, der Herr Hegemon. Denn Christian Drosten wird ja nicht als Person misstraut, sondern man weiß, dass Christian Drosten viele Leute zuhören, die wiederum Christian Drosten vertrauen und sogar kollektiv bindende Entscheidungen daraus ableiten. Ich spreche nämlich von unseren Politikern, die sich beraten lassen in einer Unsicherheitssituation. Das heißt, es geht gar nicht um Christian Drosten bei diesem Thema, sondern Menschen mögen die Folgen auf ihr eigenes Leben nicht, die aufgrund von kollektiv bindender Entscheidungen, bei denen sie nicht angehört wurden, die zu eilig getroffen wurden, was auch immer. Und man nimmt sich dann die Einflugschneise Christian Drosten, weil man weiß, die haben eine kollektiv bindende Entscheidung getroffen, die sie nicht in der Lage waren, selbst zu treffen. Sie haben sich inhaltlich beraten lassen von Christian Drosten.
Ja.
Nun.
Und bestrafen Drosten noch gleich mit dafür, was sie schon zehn Jahre er tragen mussten unter dieser Politik.
Genau. Dann stehst du drei Jahre später auf so einem Campingplatz, siehst Christian Drosten und beschimpfst ihn.
Ja.
So.
Aber eigentlich ist man sauer, dass man 2015 in Sovenz anmelden musste.
Und hier muss die Frage geklärt werden, Misstrauen, Vertrauen, Wen und Was gegenüber. Und hier sollte man sich, das habe ich ja schon beim Thema Glauben, die Welt, ich selbst, das unbekannte Es in mir, was auch immer. Da sollte man jetzt keine Angst davor haben, das so zu benennen, weil das ist der soziologische Kern, um den es hier geht. Und das verstehe ich einfach gar nicht. Wenn man hier so, ja, die haben Christian Drosten einfach rein subjektiv, das ist auch rational total erklärbar, misstraut. Ich denke mir so, nee, also das ist hier so dreifach, tausendfach über Bande gespielt. Vor allem dann noch diese Idee, alle, die Christian Drosten in dem Podcast hören, Angst davor haben, dass er schon wieder von Schule spricht, weil dann wird ja schon wieder die Schule zugemacht, weil die Kollegen ihn zuhören. Und diese Idee, Jahre später oder schon währenddessen zu haben, sozusagen alle, die jetzt Christian Drosten zuhören und über eine nachvollziehbare im Alltagsdenken, aber eigentlich verwirrende, nicht nachvollziehbare Misstrauenslogik jetzt hier Ressentiment aufbauen, dass die eine Gemeinschaft bilden, ist ja ein total wahnsinniger Gedanke. Die bilden ja gerade keine Gemeinschaft, sondern von denen, die Christian Drosten vertrauen, werden sie als Gemeinschaft angesehen. So wie die Politik immer dieses Vehikel aufbaut. Ja, also bei Indymedia ist jetzt irgendwas publiziert worden. Wir wissen, dass da im Grunde jeder publizieren kann. Man schickt einfach in die E-Bilder eine Adresse und dann zahlt er auf der Seite auf. Wir erklären euch jetzt mal zum Verein, weil dann können wir euch verbieten.
Ja.
So, dass diese Vereinsgründung rein fiktional ist, um einen...
Ja, das ist einfach das. Da war vielleicht jemand ein bisschen viel auf Twitter, denn das war doch dann immer Hashtag Team Drosten, Hashtag Team Lauterbach, dass man sich immer so als Team gleich versteht.
Es gab mediale Lagerbildung. An einem Hashtag organisiert. Das ist weder Organisation noch Netzwerk noch sonst irgendwas. Das ist einfach nur massenhaftes Erscheinen von individuellen Handlungen, die natürlich antizipieren, dass sie zurechenbar sein wollen, die also von sich aus einen Hashtag wählen. Ja. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass da irgendwer irgendwie einen kennt oder so. Also es ist wirklich verrückt. Weitere Thesen, also diese Misstrauensgemeinschaft steckt dann hier drin. Natürlich die digitale Infrastruktur, bei der ich schon wieder denke, ja, das ist so ein bisschen, wenn jetzt Leute, die sich digital äußern, erkennbar machen mit Ich bin nicht die Tagesschau. Und dann verbietet man ihnen gleich das Wort, weil sie sind ja nicht die Tagesschau. Während man aber krasse Sachen auch in der Tagesschau oder den Deckmantel der ARD oder die Swötthaut druckt mal irgendwas und so. Also, dass man sozusagen erst eine Adresse braucht, so ein Schirmherren der Publizität, der sagt, ja, so wenn du das jetzt bei uns unter fremden Federn auf seine Neuen Politik schreibst, dann geht das. Aber als Tweet ist es nicht ernst zu nehmen. Diese Art von Klassifizierung wollen wir ja gar nicht. Dagegen wenden wir uns ja recht.
Ja genau, weil man dann ja in den Punkt kommt, an dem man sagt, ja, also du kannst natürlich jetzt vieles gegen Gabor Steingart sagen, aber das ist ein ganz erfolgreicher Medienmann in Deutschland. Der hat immerhin da sein eigenes Schiff. Und der war früher Handelsblatt-Chefredakteur. Wieso kannst du jetzt einfach da kommen, als kleiner Podcaster aus Frankfurt, das zu kritisieren?
Es gibt ja auch diesen Professor Röder, der im Grunde immer wieder das AfD-Lied singt, aber halt unter, ne, ich bin ja eher 21 irgendwas und so. Und im letzten Podcast fährt Frank Staus auch aus der Haut, um Hajo Schumacher zu sagen, jetzt komm nicht immer mit dem Röder unter, ja, das ist noch so eine publizistische, der ist ja Professor und so weiter, der ist in dem Lager.
Ja, ja, ja.
So, ja, und das muss man dann irgendwann auch mal, also diese Elefanten-Runde finde ich, dieser Kontrast zwischen diesen beiden, der ist irgendwie sehr gut. Hier sind so ein paar Stielenblüten, das ist wirklich wunderschön. Also, nicht ohne Grund handeln Menschen, sobald sie dem Geld nicht mehr vertrauen, mit Gold oder anderen Währungen. Ich will den Text mal auf Deutsch übersetzen. Nicht ohne Grund handeln Menschen, sobald sie dem Geld nicht mehr vertrauen, mit Geld.
Ja.
Fällt das nicht auf? Beim Schreiben schon? Kann das vorher einer lesen, der irgendwie sagt, andere Währungen sind auch Geld? Also, es ist doch irgendwie, es ist sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr schräg. Ich möchte aber die konstruktive Wende gleich einwenden, aber vorher, ich weiß, wir sind bis knapp in der Zeit, aber ich muss dir Textstellen vorlesen, die wirklich, wo ich mir denke, das geht so einfach nicht. Und es muss man noch mal durchdenken. Also, die zunehmende Migration, die globale Verbreitung kultureller Produkte und ein umfassender Wertewandel haben zu einer deutlichen Ausweitung kultureller Pluralität geführt. Moderne Gesellschaften ermöglichen eine Vielzahl unterschiedlicher Lebensstile, Wertorientierungen und Identitätsentwürfe. Während diese Diversität ein großes Potenzial für Kreativität und Innovationsfähigkeit in sich birgt, geht sie zugleich einher mit Herausforderungen hinsichtlich sozialer Integration und der Aushandlung gemeinsamer normativer Grundlagen. Konflikte um Fragen kultureller Anerkennung, Identitätspolitik und Zugehörigkeit sind daher Ausdruck gesteigerter gesellschaftlicher Komplexität.
Ja, bin jetzt fast eingeschlafen und was erfahren wir damit Neues?
Das ist inhaltsfreier Text. Man ist dümmer, nachdem man das gelesen hat. Und auch diese Dreiklänge, das immer A, B oder C, also das zuchtzieht den ganzen Text. Die Informationsflute erobert neue Kompetenzen der Selektion, Bewertung und Integration von verfügbarem Wissen. Falsche Informationen, Desinformationen und Verschwörungsideologien expandieren genauso wie Informationsaustausch und Wissensaneignung. Nicht nur die Gesellschaften werden immer komplexer, sondern auch die Informations- und Wissensbestände über die Gesellschaft. Und damit werden die Deutungsangebote vielfältiger, widersprüchlicher und polarisierender. Ich bin wirklich wütend, dass uns das als Soziologie verkauft wird.
Ja, es wird alles unübersichtlicher, aber auch übersichtlicher.
Also hier ist so ein Satz, da habe ich mir dran geschrieben, da hat jemand wirklich keinen Bock auf Soziologie gehabt. Es lässt sich häufig nicht mehr genau bestimmen, wann und warum Misstrauen entsteht. Aber es ist davon auszugehen, dass es bestimmten Grenzen bzw. Schwellen gibt, an denen die Kraft des Vertrauens endet und abrupt in Misstrauen umschlägt.
Ab wie viel Zentimeter dann oder ab wie viel Pfund wird es dann anders?
Ich schlage doch das Buch auf, weil ich genau das hören möchte. Wo ist die Schwelle? Selbst wenn ich jetzt sage, Vertrauen und Misstrauen sind nicht so... Also was ist auch die Schwelle?
Ist das eine monetäre Schwelle?
Ich lese ja hier das Ende. Wichtig erscheinen positive Zukunftsideen und damit positive Zukunfts-Erwartungen, die wie ein Kompass auch in kritischen Zeiten wirken und Vertrauen stärken. Insbesondere für Menschen in ohnehin prekären Lebenslagen sind negative Zukunftsaussichten regelrecht der Horror. Ich denke mir so, du hast auf Seite 1 gesagt, das spielt keine Rolle, diesen ökonomischen Verwerfungen. Und jetzt am Ende holst du sie plötzlich mal wieder so ins Boot, weil es ist ja auch wichtig, über dir auch mal was zu sagen.
Macht die evangelische Kirche auch, wird auch immer mal noch mal gesagt. Aber vergessen wir auch nicht die im globalen Süden.
Eine positive Zukunft besteht aus Versprechen. Die liberale Demokratie war in den vergangenen Jahrzehnten getragen von der Aussicht auf Wohlstand, Fortschritt und Sicherheit. Es bedarf Veränderung, um das Bestehende zu bewahren. Die Demokratie muss, will sie bestehen, dieses Vertrauen in die und damit in ihre Zukunft erneuern. Das ist wirklich ganz schlimm.
Ich glaube, so kann man nur denken, wenn man mit Emphase demokrat ist, im Sinne von jetzt brauche ich noch drei Sonntagsreden und dann ist wieder alles super. Die meisten Menschen, und wenn ich jetzt auch schaue, wie ich sozialisiert bin, ich bin in einem recht unpolitischen Umfeld groß geworden. Und wenn ich das so familiär im Bekanntenkreis sehe, ja, da war da nicht viel mit Politik. Man war aber überhaupt gar nicht in dem Sinne auf irgendwas aggressiv eingestellt, sondern man sagte sich so, ja, die machen ja doch, was sie wollen da oben. Und dann entscheidet man sich so kurz vorher, sollen wir überhaupt wählen gehen? Und noch kürzer vorher, wen wählen wir? Mit dieser Emphase, wie das hier beschrieben wird. Das ist so der Modus, in dem, weiß ich nicht, Michel Friedmann auf dem Podium noch mal eine Rede hält. Aber das ist ja überhaupt nichts, was irgendwo bei Normalbürgern da ist. Also wenn ich das jemandem im Koblenz erzähle und das Versprechen der Demokratie, das müssen wir doch erneuern, dann gucken die mich an. Wenn ich sage, wir brauchen hier doch mal eine Umgehungsstraße, dann würde ich sagen, ja richtig, das sage ich ja schon seit zehn Jahren. Darüber kann ich mit Ihnen sprechen.
Ja, also ich will jetzt meine Gegenargumente, was ich mir wünsche in einem Verbuch zum Thema Vertrauen und Misstrauen, was absolut notwendig und echt desiderat ist. Ich will nichts länger von ach hier und ja Verluste und so und Vertrauen, sondern hier finden doch Verlagerungen statt. Die Leute haben Trump vertraut und ihn deswegen gewählt. Er hat ihnen ein Angebot gemacht. Nicht einfach, als sie haben den anderen Misstraut. Und das war halt das kleinere Übel. Ich möchte, dass der Strukturwandel der Öffentlichkeit, dass jetzt Millionen konkurrierender Medienstars einfach so wie wir auch einen Podcast machen, so diskutieren und jetzt möchte ich eine Angst schildern. Ich weiß ja von Elmar Falani, der ist so ein bisschen berühmter. Der wird also auch von Leuten mal eingeladen, die sagen, ich wurde hier gerade gewählt, kannst du mal fünf Kumpels mitbringen und mich beraten. Wenn so einer eine Beratung abgibt, die in einem Podcast in der Nachfrage mündet, du meinst jetzt nicht mich, oder? Bei Matze. Dann habe ich Angst. Also ich will keine politische Beratung oder irgendwas. Das ist irgendwie eine Idee. Strick mit, mit dem Vertrauen, das ist ja echt im Argen jetzt. Vielleicht sollten wir ein paar Podcasts aussortieren. So ein paar Schranken hochziehen, ein paar Schwellen einrichten. Nicht gut. Spezifische Fragen. Wahlen und Rechtssystem müssen ganz spezifisch, wenn ich sage, wenn wir inhaltlich Misstrauens- und Vertrauensverhandlungen haben, dann sollte eins klar sein. Das ist der Wahltag und eine Mehrheit besteht aus 50 Prozent plus eins. Wenn dann im Fernsehen jemand auftritt und sagt, das mit dem Wahltag ist nicht so wichtig, wir machen einfach sieben Jahre. Und diese parlamentarische Entscheidung, die dann auch mit Mehrheit durchgehen muss, nee, gib den nochmal drei Schüsse frei. Dann ist das für mich ein Vertrauens-Ting. Dann muss das ganz konkret, dann muss einfach klar sein, da müssen wir jetzt nochmal nachlesen bei, wer auch immer der Soziologe ist, der das Buch dazu geschrieben hat, vertraut er dem System nicht, der Schirach? Wie gehen wir damit um, dass jetzt plötzlich Wahldaten verschoben werden? Das ist doch so. Zweitens, ein Argument, das man mal machen muss, was bei Malvalani gar nicht vorkommt, die Welt wird nicht immer komplexer und es ist alles kompliziert oder so, sondern es wird einfach in Sachen Vertrauen sogar einfacher. Egal, wo du bist, ob im Restaurant, in der Bahn, im Ausland, wie auch immer, du hast ein Vertrauen in Gerichte, dass die schon auffangen, was ansonsten nicht funktioniert. Also es gibt ganz wenige Instanzen, auf die man das Vertrauen Münzt. Das ist zum Beispiel die Polizei. Egal, was dir passiert, du kannst immer die Polizei rufen und damit ist ein Dritter im Bunde, der klärt dann Sachen. Wenn ich aber auf TikTok und Instagram nur noch Polizisten sehe, die auf die Bevölkerung einkloppen, von hinten in den Rücken springen oder sonstiges, dann wird an einer spezifischen Stelle, da wo eigentlich Vertrauen aufgefangen werden sollte, Vertrauensverluste, wird an dieser spezifischen Stelle auch ein Misstrauen geschürt und das ist ein besonderes Misstrauen. Da kann man nicht einfach drüber bügeln und sagen, ja ja, hier im Dreiklang der A, B und C und so, sondern da muss ein Kapitel drin sein zum Thema, woraufhin hat sich in einem Rechtsstaat das Vertrauen verlagert? Auf die Polizei. Was liegt da gerade im Argen? Sowas kann man da thematisieren. Außerdem, wir haben heute und es ist unglaublich, Vertrauensgewinne in einem Ausmaß, die undenkbar waren. Wir haben Reputationsmaschinen, eBay, Uber, Airbnb, Paypal. Wir zahlen irgendwelchen Leuten, die wir nie sehen, einfach nur, die haben eine Paypal-Adresse Geld. Uns werden Sachen geliefert. Wir gehen Handelsverträge ein unter Umständen, das kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Wir steigen in fremde Autos, in fremden Städten und fahren in fremde Betten und übernachten da einfach. Das hat es vorher nicht gegeben. Dieses neue Vertrauen muss beschrieben werden.
Ich wollte es gerade betonen. Ich habe ja jetzt ein iPhone seit ein paar Monaten und ich kann sagen, ich kann mich viel vertrauensseliger durch die Gegend bewegen, weil ich darauf vertrauen kann, dass ich mit dem Smartphone mich navigieren kann, dass ich mir damit ein Taxi oder ein Uber rufen kann und dass ich sonst auch noch mal viel leichter vielleicht den Veranstalter kontaktieren kann, wenn irgendetwas schiefgegangen ist. Ich kann also auf das Smartphone vertrauen, dass ich durch diese Welt, durch diesen hektischen Alltag, den ich jetzt in den letzten Tagen sehr stark hatte, geführt werde. Wenn ich jetzt noch das Risiko hätte, werde ich wohl auf dem Bahnsteig jemand finden, der mir den Weg zum Hotel beschreibt, werde ich dann noch jemand finden, der mich dahin fährt und werde ich dann noch im Hotel einchecken können, weil die ja gar nicht eine Nachtrezeption haben. Wenn ich das alles immer noch vertrauen müsste, dann wäre ich längst übergeschnappt.
Abhandlungen, ja. Ich will nichts mehr zum Thema Verlust, Vertrauen. Als nächstes schreibt Heinz Bude irgendwas zu Verantwortung. Solche Bücher will ich nicht hören. Ich möchte nur Bücher, in denen mir auch mal gesagt wird, wir verabschieden hier eine Sache zu Recht. So, wie zum Beispiel alte, überholte Vorstellungen von Demokratie-Theorien, denen dann nachgetrauert wird in Büchern, bei denen ich sage, so war es nie, war immer nur Sonntagsrede. Ja, und jetzt kann man es auch beim Vertrauen machen. Wir haben heute neue Vertrauensprinzipien und alte lassen wir zu Recht jetzt einfach mal Geschichte sein. Im Sinne von Senioritätsprinzipien oder was auch immer. So, außerdem, und das ist vielleicht das Wichtigste, Vertrauen und Geld. In der Soziologie gibt es einen Spruch, der ist ganz simpel, aber super richtig. Wer Freunde hat, braucht kein Geld. Wer Geld hat, braucht keine Freunde. So, Superreichtum ist von uns auch deswegen beneidet, weil dort sehr viele Sachen, die bei uns, wenn überhaupt allenfalls mit Freundschaftsdiensten, ach, ich kenne mal einen, und dann habe ich mal so einen Vorzug. Das kaufen sich Superreiche einfach, weil sie auf diese Vertrauensanwarnung, hier muss erstmal eine Beziehung gestaltet werden und so, pfeifen können. Sie legen einfach Bargeld auf den Tisch. Und wenn in Deutschland Verarmung ein Thema ist, dann ist das ein Thema für ein Vertrauensbuch. Und dann kann ich auf Seite eins drin stehen, um sowas kümmere ich mich hier nicht. Das ist einfach alles total Banane, was hier steht. Von daher, das ist wirklich, das ist meine Erwartungshaltung des neuerdings, Elmar Falani schreibt wie Markus Gabriel.
Ich befürchte es, es klingt ganz danach.
Ist nicht gut.
Ich mache es schnell noch einmal Kulturpass. Da ist mir ein Artikel aufgefallen in der Allgemeinen Zeitung von Christopher Hechtler. Der schreibt nochmal über den Kulturpass. Also es war ja so, dass er eingeführt wurde und zunächst gab es für die 2005 geborenen 200 Euro. Dann im nächsten Jahr hat man schon gesagt, so spendabel können wir nicht mehr sein. Es gibt jetzt für den nächsten Jahrgang, für die 2006er nur noch 100 Euro pro Kopf. Verwaltungskosten. Man hat 92 Millionen Euro ausgezahlt. Verwaltungskosten, unter anderem IT-Infrastruktur und so weiter, 30 Millionen.
Ja, das ist absurd. Sorry, das ist ein Drittel des Geldes.
Ja, also man hat nicht 90 Millionen ausgezahlt, sondern 60 Millionen ausgezahlt und eben 30 Millionen Verwaltungskosten.
Dann ist es 2 zu 1.
Es ist wirklich verrückt.
Also bei sowas ist akzeptabel 1%.
Ja, wie bei der Rente. Du hast ja eben gesagt, 0,8% oder was das da ist. Warum gibt es jetzt den Kulturpass nicht mehr? Da wurde eine Sprecherin befragt des Kulturministeriums. Antwort. 2023 haben nur rund 38% und 2024 nur rund 28% der berechtigten Jugendlichen ihr Kulturpassbudget aktiviert. Dies ist auch im Vergleich zu anderen europäischen Programmen ein niedriges Ergebnis. Also weil es nicht so viele gemacht haben, dann könnte man ja darüber nachdenken, wie schafft man andere als er das das mehr machen. Oder hat man das vielleicht auch gar nie diesen Leuten so richtig vermittelt. Also das wissen vielleicht Leute, die jetzt hier studieren gehen oder so. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das in vielen Bereichen gar nicht angekommen ist. Zudem musste man sich für diesen Pass anmelden mit dem Online-Ausweisverfahren. Oder man musste über Online-Banking der Sparkasse das praktizieren. Vielleicht lag es auch da an manchen Hirten, warum das nicht so ganz funktioniert hat.
Das ist wirklich kurz vor Schöpfungshöhe. Wir machen zur inflationsreduzierenden Maßnahme ein 9-Euro-Ticket, das dann ein Jahr später 60 Euro kostet.
Ja.
Hat eine Inflation von 600 Prozent, aber es ist eine inflationssenkende Maßnahme.
Eine halbe Million Leute haben es aber dann auf diese Kulturpass-App geschafft. Ich weiß übrigens auch von einer Veranstalterin, die so kleinere Sachen macht, sehr schöne Sachen macht, dass sie es einfach nicht geschafft hat, ihre Veranstaltung dazu zu registrieren, weil es zu viel Aufwand einfach bedeutete, dass sie dann, wenn jemand mal gefragt hat, geht hier auch mit Kulturpass, hat sie die einfach kostenlos reingelassen, weil sie dachte, es hat keinen Zweck. Dieser Kulturpass jedenfalls kostete 0,02 Prozent des Haushalts. Also da kann man überhaupt nicht über Geld reden in dem Sinne. Der Bundesrechnungshof aber sagt, ne, also das ist verfassungsrechtlich nicht gedeckt, dass man hier so Gelde ausgibt. Denn, du weißt es ja, Kultur ist Ländersache.
Ja.
Und da kann man natürlich nichts wahren. Eine weitere Begründung, warum es diesen Pass nicht mehr gibt, ist, ja, die hätten ja gar nicht die jungen Leute so alles gleichermaßen wahrgenommen. Die seien viel weniger in die Oper gegangen als ins Kino. Und dann denke ich mir, ja, und?
Das sind junge Leute.
Das ist generell so. Da ist ja ein Wunder, dass überhaupt welche in die Oper gegangen sind.
Wie man für jeden Kinobesucher ein in der Oper. Ja. Das ist sehr gut.
Auch hier interessant, also das meiste floss an Bücher. Also Bücher wurden gekauft. Eigentlich ja das, was man will. Weimar, der dann sagt, ja, nicht mehr wird nicht mehr gelesen alles. Die Leute haben Bücher gekauft, wird nicht weiter gemacht. Dann kamen Kinobesucher und dann erst Konzert und Bühne. Und da würde ich auch noch mal sagen, ja, weil wahrscheinlich auch viele Veranstalter da kapituliert haben und das gar nicht angemeldet haben. Es ist völlig absurd. Das wird dann kommentiert von Echtler, dass der Kulturpass für 18-Jährige dieses Jahr ausläuft, ist ein Offenbarungseid für die Bundesregierung, der man nicht mehr abnehmen will, dass die Jugend sie interessiert und auch für Wolfram Weimer, denn die Begründung für das Auslassen in seinem Kulturverständnis zweifeln. Es heißt etwa, der ländliche Raum und soziale Benachteiligte seien zu wenig erreicht worden. Nun, dem ließe sich entgegnen, machen sie mehr Werbung und senken sie die Anmeldehürden. Auch heißt es, vor allem Buchhandel und Kinos hätten profitiert, etwa die Oper sei weniger beliebt gewesen. Das ist zwar so und war sicher auch vorhersehbar, völlig unverständlich ist jedoch, dass hier vom Kulturstaatsminister Kunst gegen Kunst ausgespielt wird. Er ist ja gerade der, der sich als großer Filminister aufspielt. Er ist ja noch absurder. Ist nicht jedes Buch in den Händen eines Jugendlichen, der dafür vielleicht sonst kein Geld hätte, ein Erfolg? Sind 1,6 Millionen Bücher, deren Kauf der Kulturpass ermöglicht hat, wirklich ein Gegenargument, wenn nicht zugleich auch eine Verdi-Oper besucht wurde?
Ich erwarte von dieser Bundesregierung nichts mehr. Aus Zeitgründen mache ich hier mal einen Punkt ganz kurz. Jörg Henschel hat in der Süddeutschen Zeitung über die Potemkinsche Mediengruppe von Wolfram Weimar geschrieben. Nur zwei Zahlen, ja. Er hat diesen Ludwig-Ehrhard-Gipfel. Da kann man ein Mont Blanc-Ticket kaufen. Das ist ja also Zugang zu den Entscheidern und so weiter. Dieser Ticketpreis liegt bei 80.000 Euro. Wenn da 100 Leute kommen, kommt da viel Geld bei rum. Dann ist man eigentlich durchfinanziert.
Wäre auch mal eine Idee für einen Live-Salon, würde ich sagen.
Ja, total 80.000 Euro, Reihe 1 ist dann reserviert. So, jetzt ist die Frage, gibt es darüber hinaus noch andere Umsätze? Diese ganze Mediengruppe macht zweieinhalb Millionen Umsatz und 400.000 Gewinn. Ich würde sagen, das ist der Ludwig Erhard-Gipfel. Darüber hinaus hat sie mehrere Zeitschriften, Markt und Mittelstand, Wirtschaftskurier, Wirtschaftskurier, pardon, und Gazette oder so. Businesspunk hatte sie mal dann wieder abgegeben, nachdem die Redaktion komplett gekündigt hat, als sie wussten, sie leben jetzt bei Wolfram Weimer. In den offiziellen Auflagenzahlen stehen irgendwie 65.000 Freistücke von Markt und Mittelstand, die liegen also kostenlos rum. Die einzigen Abonnenten für alle Medien, die da im Angebot sind, sind überhaupt nur bei dieser Markt- und Mittelstand-Zeitung zu verzeichnen. Und es sind 289. Das ist das Imperium von Wolfram Weimer.
Naja, und der Rest läuft dann über weitere organisierte Konferenzen. Ich hatte mal von jemandem gehört, aus solchen Gefilden zumindest, nicht direkt bei Weimar, dass Unternehmer, um auf irgendeinem komischen Podium zu sitzen und da auch mal ihre Meinung kund zu tun, bis zu 40.000 Euro zahlen. Also man zahlt für die Anwesenheit auf einem Podium, weil man dann mal sich als der große Petner aufspielen kann.
Ob Wolfram Weimer da ja selber zum Bundeskabinett gehört, deren Nähe er annonciert, oder einfach sich selber dort verkauft. Und die Antwort ist natürlich Ja. Und ja, es ist der Ludwig Erdgipfel, dann gibt es das Finance and Future Summit und so weiter. Irgendwelche Markengalas, der Mittelstandspreis der Medien, der Science Award und so weiter und so fort. Das ist so...
Ja, wir können jetzt auch den Goldenen Bämbel ab nächste Woche hier verleihen.
Wir sollten tatsächlich im nächsten Sommer, bei der nächsten Gelegenheit einfach einen Preis auslösen.
Ja.
Dann laden wir jemanden ein, zahlen Preisgeld 1000 Euro.
Nein, nein, der zahlt uns 1000 Euro, dass er von uns den Preis bekommt.
Die Gäste, die dann kommen, müssen zahlen. Aber der Ausgezeichnete Gast kriegt natürlich von uns eine Dotierung, oder wie man das nennt. Und natürlich vergeben wir den Preis an Angela Merkel, ist ja völlig klar.
Ja klar.
Idemas kann halt nicht kommen.
Ja.
Peinlich.
Ich will einen Roman empfehlen, allerdings mit Einschränkung. Ich bin nicht restlos begeistert davon, aber weil wir so viel über KI diskutiert haben, dachte ich, ist es vielleicht doch für manche interessant, die tiefer da einsteigen wollen. Ri Kudan, eine japanische Autorin, hat einen Roman geschrieben, der heißt Tokyo Sympathy Tower. Es geht darum, dass eine Architektin, Sarah Makina, beauftragt wird, in Tokyo einen Wolkenkratzer zu bauen. In diesem Tower sollen Kriminelle leben, und zwar zu paradiesischen Zuständen. Vorbei ist die Zeit, in der man Kriminelle bestraft und in den Knast stellt. Und was bedeutet das eigentlich, wenn eine Gesellschaft plötzlich nur noch das Positive sehen will?
Also das ist ein Roman und es spielt in so eine Fixer-Zukunft.
In einer sehr nahen Zukunft in Japan. Der Roman beginnt mit der Turn zu Babel, kehrt zurück der Tokyo Sympathy Tower, wird unsere Sprache verwirren und unsere Welt wird in Stücke zerfallen. Doch wird dieses Chaos nicht ausbrechen, weil wir, berauscht vom Fortschritt unserer Baukunst, dem Himmel zu nahe kommen und die Götter erzürnen, sondern weil wir in hartnäckiger Verblendung unserer Sprache, weil wir missbrauchen, verfälschen, überdehnen und säubern, bis wir einander zwangsläufig nicht mehr verstehen. Alles, was wir sagen, wird zum Monolog. Keiner wird mehr den anderen hören, verloren. Fegen unsere Tiraden übers Land. Das Zeitalter des großen Selbstgesprächs bricht an. Es gibt Widerstand gegen diesen Tower. Es gibt eine ideologische Grundlage für dieses große Bauprojekt. Es ist der Text Homo miserabilis. So nennt man fort an die kriminellen Menschen, die unser Mitgefühl verdienen. Der Autor schlägt also vor, alles nur noch mit Positivität zu überziehen. Aber wo kippt das in Repression? Wo wird eigentlich die Sprache durch Harmoniesucht in einer Weise manipuliert, dass man nicht mehr frei ist? Erzählt wird diese Geschichte aus der Perspektive der Architektin und aus der Perspektive eines Journalisten Max Klein, der über diese Situation schreibt. Hinzu kommt noch Takuto, ein junger Mann, der prekär lebt, einfacher Verkäufer ist in Japan, aber in eine Beziehung mit Sarah kommen kann, weil er schön ist und sie betrachtet auch ihn wie ein Bauwerk. Zugleich geht es um die Aushandlung von Machtverhältnissen, sollte sie ihm Geld zahlen. Sie selbst ist auch Opfer eines Missbrauchs. Es ist ein Buch, das ja an vielem angelehnt ist, an Borgess, bestimmt auch an Fahrenheit 451. Es ist ein Buch, das sich in KI-Dialoge verstrickt. Da ist Sarah, die schreibt, ich und du, du und ich sind dieselbe Person, aber wir sind verschieden und KI-Bild sagt, nein, sie und ich sind nicht dieselbe Person. Ich bin eine künstliche Intelligenz, die darauf programmiert ist, Informationen bereitzustellen und mit ihnen zu interagieren. Sie sind ein natürliches menschliches Wesen mit Gefühlen und Bewusstsein. Wir unterscheiden uns voneinander und haben unterschiedliche Eigenschaften. Sarah sagt, analfabet, warum gewöhnst du dir nicht an, deine eigene Existenz anzuzweifeln? Und KI-Bild, es ist nicht richtig, jemanden zu raten, an seine Existenz zu zweifeln. Es ist wichtig, Analfabeten die Möglichkeit zu geben, zu lernen und ihre Lese- und Schreibfähigkeiten zu verbessern. Also wir sehen dann gleich so eine korrekte Antwort. Fünf Prozent des Romans sind, wie gesagt, mit KI geschrieben, mit Czecipti. Es ist vor allem ein Roman, der über die Sprache reflektiert, aber er ist ungeheuer verkopft und versucht diese, ja, verschiedenen Debatten auch um Vocal-Sprache und Vocal-KI und all das aufzugreifen. Nicht im Sinne von einem Kulturkampf, der hier fortgeführt wird mit literarischen Mitteln. Aber es ist doch ein Buch, das sich auf 160 Seiten so in all diese Gefilde einmischen will. Und dann dachte ich, vielleicht muss man eine Abstraktionsebene mehr einführen, um jetzt über das KI-Zeitalter zu sprechen. Es gibt ja dieses wunderbare Buch über künstliche Reproduktion von Menschen. Alles, was wir geben mussten von Katsu Ishiguro, der das wohin verlegt, wo man es überhaupt nicht ahnt. Und da wird es aber dann dran verhandelt. Und hier, das ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen zu entlang der Wirklichkeit geschrieben, sodass man sich fragt, wann kommt das Update von JetJPT, das auch hier wieder einiges aus dem Buch dann in Frage stellt. Also keine uneingeschränkte Empfehlung, aber immerhin, die Literatur beschäftigt sich jetzt mit solchen Fragen auch.
Sehr gut. Ich habe gerade eine Executive Decision in diesem LLM-Text, den ich annonciert hatte. Besprechen wir zum Monatsende, weil den müssen wir diskutieren. Deshalb ich mir jetzt nochmal Zeit nehme, hier für Born Rich or Die Trying. Wir hatten schon mal den Text von Human, der einfach so nebenbei hart aber fair schaut und dann an GPT und Notebook LM und alle die Frage stellt, das was da gerade gesagt wurde, stimmt das eigentlich? Und am Ende ist ein sehr großer LinkedIn-Text, von dem wir gesagt haben, ja, ein bisschen neue Gattung, so, dass man einfach gar nicht so selber die große Schreibleistung erbringt, aber dass man so eine Idee, die man hat, oder so eine Unschärfe, die man sieht, mal kurz ausformuliert haben möchte und das dann auch publiziert. Und aus diesem Frankfurter Kosmos ist hier von Sven Kalisch ein Text erschienen, auf seinem Subseq, der sich mit Vermögen und Einkommen und so befasst. Und von dem ich sage, das ist jetzt so der enzyklopädische, bilanzierende Text, den man typischerweise auch aus Recherche fällt dann doch etwas schwerer im Alltag. Dann würde man so ein Stimmungsbild schreiben, aber jetzt sagt man einfach, ich bleib mal bei den Zahlen so ungefähr. Und den will ich kurz vorstellen, gerade auch, weil er eben später sagt, er wird weitergeführt. Also es geht um eine absurde Kluft, nämlich 400 Milliarden, die jährlich vererbt werden und wir nur 10 Milliarden Euro Steuern draufzahlen. Und gleichzeitig haben wir aber eine Bürgergeldsempfängerdebatte über Fraulheit. Und das kann man ja mal auflösen oder zumindest diese Kluft einfach mal thematisieren und sich dann sagen, so ich gehe jetzt mal von oben nach unten durch. Er macht sogar drei aktuelle Anlässe. Also wir haben zum einen diese Familienunternehmer, die sich da der AfD, aus haben wir ja vorhin schon, der Gabo Steingart, das ist natürlich folgerichtig, dass die das machen. Diese Schweizer Volksabstimmung, dass Menschen einfach gesagt wird, ne, also wenn wir jetzt 50 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer auf Erben ab 50 Millionen Schweizer Franken machen, dann ziehen die alle weg und das Ganze voll keine Angst. So ja, also da ist ja wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Aufklärung mal liegt nah. Und der neue Armuts- und Reichtumsbericht. Also wir haben hier drei aktuelle Anlässe, die es rechtfertigen zu schreiben. Und als Textgrundlage nimmt da sich Martina Linatas Buch, das wir natürlich auch bisher ein bisschen noch nicht so ganz gewürdigt haben hier. Unverdiente Ungleichheit. Und es wird von ihm sehr gelobt. Und ich denke mir, ja, ich nehme mal an, das stimmt. Wir hätten es vielleicht auch nochmal etwas intensiver thematisieren müssen. Jetzt wird die beste Dekonstruktion, die er kennt, nämlich analytisch sauber, politisch mutig und empirisch satt. Und dieses empirisch satt, das ist so eine neue Qualität, die Texte heute haben, dank KI-Zeitalter, sage ich auch mal so. Diese Ungleichheit, die wir haben, ist politisch gestaltet. Das ist sozusagen Tenor. Es geht hier nicht um Naturgesetze, die so gelten. Weshalb wir, wie er sagt, eine horizontale und eine vertikale Ungleichheit thematisieren müssen. Denn wir haben es hier mit intersektionalen Mechanismen zu tun. Also Diskriminierungen führen zu schlechter bezahlten Jobs, führen zu weniger Sparfähigkeit, führen zu weniger Vermögensaufbau, führen zu schlechterer Bildung. Und damit vererbt sich dann alles. Also das, was ein Geld oben vererbt wird, wird halt auch unten weiter vererbt. Aber da kann man halt, muss man halt anders drüber reden, weil da ist es ja nicht das Geld, sondern alles andere, was durch Geldmangel passiert. Vermögen ist also strukturbildend und Unvermögen eben auch. Insbesondere da, und das sind dann die wichtigen Sachen, Kapital schneller wächst als die Wirtschaft. Also ja, Menschen arbeiten, kriegen dann vom Wirtschaftswachstum schon nicht das ab, was sie eigentlich verdienen. Und dann ist das Kapital drüber, das noch kräftiger wächst. Wir haben es also mit zunehmender Ungleichheit zu tun. Und das kann man ja auch in Trends, also dann die Relationen auch mal in zeitlicher Hinsicht für so ein Land wie Deutschland mal aufdröseln. Und das wird hier gemacht. Und er hat immer wieder so schöne Sprüche, Politik wird oben verhandelt und unten verwaltet. Ja, das ist wirklich sehr gut auf den Punkt gebracht. Der IWF sagt, Vermögenskonzentration, wie man sie in Deutschland sieht, sind ein Wachstumsrisiko. Die OECD sagte schon 2015, hohe Ungleichheit senkt Investitionen, Produktivität und Nachfrage. Also es gibt sozusagen aus dem Milieu und mit je heraus Argumente dagegen, dass man es weiterhin so organisiert, wie man es jetzt organisiert. Plus, Ungleichheit nimmt Lebenszeit. Und darunter diskutieren wir ja auch die Werbpflichtsdiskussion. Da wird über Leben und Tod verhandelt. Und soziale Ungleichheit ist ganz offensichtlich statistisch gesehen, er kommt mit den Zahlen des RKI 2018. Hier schreibt er strukturelle Gewalt vor.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Zahlen er jetzt hat. Ich habe Zahlen im Kopf, da sprechen wir beim obersten Deziel im Vergleich zum untersten Deziel von sieben Jahren.
Genau, sieben Jahre.
Also das heißt, die unteren zehn Prozent sterben sieben Jahre früher.
Ja, dann, so wie Marfallani sagt, Vertrauen ist ein wichtiges Thema, schreibt Sven auch. Ungleichheit zerstört Vertrauen. Quelle OECD 2017, World Bank 2016. Das kann man nämlich da alles mal heranführen und sagen, ja ja, Ungleichheit ist ein Treiber politischer Instabilität. Wenn man nämlich Geld mit reinholt, kann man Vertrauensverluste auch besser thematisieren, weil man dann einfach eins plus eins mal durchkalkuliert. Wie ungleich ist Deutschland? Hier also der Krisenwiderspruch zu deiner dritten These zum Buch. Einfach die Genie-Koeffizienten mal miteinander verglichen.
Ja, ja, das ist natürlich klar.
Das reichste 1% hat nicht 22%, wie üblicherweise thematisiert wird, sondern Nachrechnungen von Carsten Schröder, vom DIW, die hier genannt werden, 35%. Das Top 10% kommt nicht auf 59%, sondern 67%. Also nicht nur werden überhaupt mal Zahlen genannt, sondern es wird noch eine Debatte zu bestehenden Zahlen und wie sie, ich glaube, ihr könnt nachschauen, aus welchen politischen Lagern sie so kommen. Aber es gibt Zahlen, dass die DIW rechnet, viele rechnen und das kann man dann hier auch mal vergleichen und kommt dann einfach zu anderen Schlüssen. Wir haben eine Vermögensungleichheit der Superlative, zieht ihr da aus Linatas Buch. Michael Hartmann, da würde ich sagen, ja, es gibt so ein paar Autoren, die sind, also Butterwecke, Hartmann und so, die sind jetzt gut bekannt. Ich brauche sie in Texten nicht mehr und ich finde auch, und zwar nur, weil ich weiß, wie mediale Debatten laufen. Texte funktionieren manchmal besser, wenn man sie vermeidet, nochmal zu nennen. Also auch, wenn ich Butterwecke nochmal mit seiner komischen Frisur, muss man echt sagen, auf der Bühne sehe und lieber vielleicht nochmal Abstand nehmen, obwohl die Arbeit natürlich super wichtig ist. Oder eine andere Frisur. Oder eine andere Frisur. Zieht euch bitte einen Anzug an, wenn ihr auf der Bühne steht, ja. Ich gehe auch nicht schlabbern zu Lanz, sondern ich habe da natürlich meinen Anzug.
Oh, bin schon sehr gespannt.
Ja, so. Geringe Mobilität spielt natürlich hier eine Rolle. Milanović wird natürlich auch genannt. Ah nee, ich habe Milanović mir hier nochmal reingeschrieben, weil zur sozialen Mobilität, die er hier anhand von Bildungszahlen, DZHW zum Beispiel aufgreift und andere Häuser. Also, wie viel akademischer Haushaltskinder haben Zugang zu Hochschulen in Amerika? Wie viel sind es in Deutschland, wenn man das miteinander vergleicht? Also nicht akademischer Haushalte an Hochschulen in Deutschland, 25 Prozent. Das kann nicht auf persönliche Leistungsfähigkeit zurückzuführen sein. Ja, wird hier einfach, also die, die würde ich dann wieder reinbringen, die Meritokosy Trap wird hier ganz explizit gesandt. Und dann zum Finale, es ist eben kein Naturgesetz. Die wirtschaftliche Realität, die wir vorfinden, ist politisch so gestaltet.
Ja.
Und darüber ist dann auch das Handlungsvermögen der politischen Gestalter, was in einer Demokratie immer noch wir sind, außer jemand macht den Vorschlag, wir wählen den nächsten Kanzler erst drei Jahre später. Dann sind es natürlich nicht mehr wir. So, das ist dann blöd, ja. Und am Ende macht er diesen interessanten oder was heißt interessanten? Also ich finde, man kann es am Ende, wenn man sich so viel Zeit genommen hat, es auf bilanzierende und relationaufzeigende Empirie, ja empirische Substrate runterzubrechen, dann darf man sich am Ende erlauben, im Finale zu schreiben, wenn Superreiche drohen, das Land zu verlassen, wenn sie etwas zum Gemeinwesen beitragen sollen, dann zeigen sie sich nicht nur unsolidarisch, sie outen sich schlichtweg als Leistungsverweigerer.
So, ganz wichtiger Punkt. Es sind Leistungsverweigerer. Und ich finde, das kann man jetzt überall benutzen, auch bei der Wehrpflichtsdiskussion. Warum wollen wir eine Gruppe verpflichten, damit andere fein raus sind? Ja. Und dann kann man nicht immer nur über die jungen Leute und so weiter, sondern entweder hier ist was zu verteidigen, dann muss aber wirklich jeder erklären, welchen Beitrag er zu leisten bereit ist. Und wenn wir bei jungen 20-Jährigen sagen, die brauchen wir jetzt ein Jahr, dann muss bilanziert werden, das sind fünf Prozent deren bisheriger Lebenszeit. Was in fünf Prozent ungerechnet, sind denn die Boomer bereit zu geben? Und dann bitte Vorschläge der Boomer auf den Tisch, anstatt einfach solche einseitigen Diskussionen. Also Leistungsverweigerungen lassen wir hier nicht mehr durchgehen in diesem Land. Sehr gut.
Zum Schluss ein musikalischer Tipp.
Ich habe heute auch noch einen musikalischen Tipp.
Oh Gott. Das ist nicht gut. Ich sollte hier das Schlusswort haben, denke ich. Winterreise von Franz Schubert. Schon mal hier vorgestellt und gelobt. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Einspielungen, gute Einspielungen, eine mittelmäßige schlechte Einspielung, herausragende Einspielung. Dies ist eine herausragende. Sie stammt von dem Bariton Johannes Martin Krenzle. Begleitet am Klavier wird er von Hilko Dumno erschienen. Ist das Album bei Hensler Klassik, aber ist natürlich auch digital abrufbar. Muss man nicht als CD kaufen, wenn man keine CDs mehr hört. Dieser Bariton ist phänomenal. Ein großer Opernsänger sowieso. Und ein herausragender Interpret, der mit seiner voluminösen Stimme, einem warmen Tambre eine Melancholie ausstrahlen kann, herüberbringen kann, wie man das selten hat. Der aber auch mit diesem Bariton energisch verzweifelt sein kann. Der sprechen singen kann, singen spricht, aber nie auf Kosten von Melodik geht. Ebenso auch seine Begleitung. Die wirklich nicht abgehackt in irgendeiner Weise das interpretiert, sondern schon versucht, diesen Bogen immer zu spannen, dass das Wandermotiv, das durch all die Lieder durchgeht, ja miteinander zu verbinden. Es ist eine ganz, sagen wir, difficile Sache, weil man könnte so leicht nur ins Harte greifen, weil das ist ja eine grausame Geschichte von einem, der von der Liebsten verlassen wird. Und jetzt einsam, immer einsamer, sich in die Welt hineingeht. Die Hunde knorren durchs Dorf, kommt er, niemand ist da, alle liegen in ihren Betten und schlafen den Schlaf der Gerechten, aber er allein. Und dann geht er immer weiter durchs Dickicht, irgendwann auch dort, wo gar nicht mehr die üblichen Wanderwege sind. Er entfernt sich aus der Welt. Und man kann jetzt natürlich da ganz rabiat reingehen, aber er macht das sehr, sehr fein, dieser Hilko Dumno. Und die Interpretation ist phänomenal deshalb, weil wir eine solche Bandbreite hören, dass diese Texte zu Geltung kommen, dass wirklich das Melodische dabei immer im Vordergrund steht. Es geht nicht darum zu sagen, ich bürste das gegen den Strich, sondern es ist alles sehr angelehnt, an eine romantische Weise Lieder zu singen. Aber der Ausbruch darf sein, der Ausbruch der Gefühle, oder gerade da, wo die Gefühle unterdrückt sind, wo sie unter einer Eisschicht sind. Ich will ein Lied vorlesen, das ich immer schon mochte, aber das mir jetzt eigentlich besonders nahe gegangen ist in der Interpretation von Krenzle. Das ist das siebte aus dem Zyklus, also insgesamt sind das 24 Lieder. Da heißt es, der du so lustig rauschtest, du heller, wilder Fluss, wie still bist du geworden, gibst keinen Scheidekruß. Mit harter, stacher Rinde hast du dich überdeckt, liegst kalt und unbeweglich im Sande ausgestreckt. Wir ahnen also, dieser Fluss ist vereist, das ist ja Winter. In deine Decke grab ich mit einem spitzen Stein den Namen meiner Liebsten und stund und Tag hinein, den Tag des ersten Grußes, den Tag, an dem ich ging, um Namen und Zahlen windet, sich ein zerbrochener Ring. Mein Herz, also jetzt die Ansprache wirklich an das Herz selbst, an das eigene Herz. Mein Herz, in diesem Bache erkennst du nun dein Bild, ob's unter seiner Rinde wohl auch so reißend schwillt. Und dieser Ausbruch, wie das gesungen ist, das muss man unbedingt hören, wie man den ganzen Zyklus hören muss. Es ist phänomenal, ich zähle jetzt diese Winterreise und ich habe doch viele zu Hause zu einer meiner Liebsten, Johannes Martin Grenzle und Hilco Dumno unbedingt anhören.
Sehr gut. Ich hab's ja dies Jahr auch im Konzert gehört, das war ja Leons Prüfung, der auch einmal die Winterreise gesungen. Ich möchte auch Musik empfehlen, ich war in Wien. Nach Wien fliegt man mit Austrian Airlines oder so, da steigt man in die Kabine und da wird schon gespielt. Das ist natürlich sehr gut, genau. In Wien gibt es sehr viele sehr prachtvolle, prunkreiche Orte, wie zum Beispiel die Nationalbibliothek. Der Saal heißt Prunksaal, also man kriegt genau, was man versprochen, was im Programm steht. Und ich war ein bisschen überrascht, wie sehr ein Ort, der typischerweise des Google vor zweihundert Jahren war, also da ist man hingegangen und da wird sehr viel medizinisches Wissen und so, wurde da archiviert und man hat da halt relativ engmaschig dann die Universitätssiege, alles in Fußweite. Und das Archiv von Johann Strauß wird dort auch sehr gepflegt, also da gibt es Regalkilometer mit Partituren und der ganze Kram. Und man erfährt dort auch, dass Johann Strauß vielleicht ein bisschen faul war beim Komponieren, er hatte also sehr gute Ideen und hat dann anderen Leuten die Aufgabe überlassen, zu sagen, das ist die Idee, jetzt macht das mal fertig für die Instrumente. Nun kann man das also spielen, wie es in den Partituren steht, oder man wandelt das ein bisschen ab. Es ist jedenfalls ein Unterschied zwischen, da Strauß hatte so eine Melodienfolge als Idee und danach hört man es halt. Und wir sind ja immer sehr froh, wenn es in der Oper sehr viel Werktreue in der Musik liegt. Also wenn einfach die Regie sich ein bisschen austobt, aber wenn man die Augen zumacht und so weiter bekommt man sozusagen.
Das wird jetzt ganz schlimm werden, glaube ich.
Bei Johann Strauß Nummer zwei, also ich meine schon unseren Walzer König, ist es offenbar auch eine Frage, wer es spielt. Und ich habe mir natürlich viele Sachen angehört und muss sagen, es macht einen Unterschied, ich höre es sehr. Und im November kam eine neue Sammlung, die Werkuntreue in sich trägt, denn es wird hier mal ein Lied von da, da mal ein Lied von da und so. Ja, jemand hat eine Playlist zusammengestellt. Und natürlich rede ich von André Rieu und seinem Johann Strauss Orchester. Dieses Werk, wo einfach wild zusammengesucht wird, heißt Thank You Johann Strauss. Also es ist so plakativ, wie es geht. Aber ich finde, die Idee, wie Johann Strauss meinte als DJ seiner Zeit, ich mische jetzt hier mal eine Party auf, wird da einfach richtig gut umgesetzt. Du hast mir im Vorgespräch, als ich das kurz andeutete, dass du bitte nicht in Ohnmacht fällst, wenn ich nochmal die Johann Strauss-Interpretation von André Rieu heute mitbringe, hast du Tielemann und so genannt. Und ja, ich habe mir einige Aufnahmen angehört, bei denen ich sage, krass, wie leblos man es auch spielen kann. Und ich meine jetzt nicht konkret Tielemann, sondern so andere. Weiß jetzt keine Namen mehr. Aber es gibt sehr viele Aufnahmen, bei denen ich so denke, wow, das ist nicht so ganz die Idee, die Johann Strauss hatte. Aber ich möchte euch doch dieses, ich will nicht Album sagen oder so, sondern er hat halt eine Kopilation. Genau, André Rieu hat seine Lieblingsstücke jetzt dafür gebaut.
Du weißt jetzt schon, dass diese großen Dirigenten, die man so hören kann, mit den allerersten Musikern spielen, also zum Beispiel dann den Wienern.
Ja, ja. Ich sehe schon, welches Orchester da spielt und wer dirigiert. Das ist ja noch, bevor ich auf Playclick gestehe, das ja da.
Und meistens werden auch ein paar mehr da am Orchesterkram sein, als bei André Rieu.
Ja, alles richtig.
Und André Rieu ist ja dafür bekannt. Der macht das ja zugänglich. Der macht das ja mundgerecht. Das heißt, der spielt das, so würde ich jetzt mal unterstellen, geglättet von all dem, was das noch so...
Es wird auch nachbearbeitet und alles. Es wird das Maximale rausgeholt aus der Idee, die Johann Strauß hatte und wie man sie heute...
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also ob der diese Idee hatte, das wage ich doch sehr zu bezweifeln.
Wie auch immer.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du da so eine Bonbon-Idee vom Walzer im Kopf hast.
Ich möchte euch vier Sachen empfehlen. Fata Morgana, den Nonnenchor, Karuchagalopp, wie auch immer, und Wer uns getraut. Und diese vier Stücke gefallen mir so sehr. Ich erwische mich manchmal, dass ich eine Stunde lang einen Titel davon einfach in Dauerschleife habe und mir dann denke, ich höre es mal einen anderen, aber ich bleibe bei, wie André Réjeux meint, die Welt nochmal zu informieren darüber, was Johann Strauss meinte, als er vor 200 Jahren so langsam auf die Idee kam, ich hinterlasse Musik. Es ist wirklich grandioser. Also ich bin so krass gut unterhalten davon. Es ist wirklich eine Freude einfach.
Ich werde es nicht mehr weiter kommentieren, sondern nochmal darauf verweisen, dass wir...
Warst du schon in Mitridate?
Noch nicht.
Ich war in der Premiere, das erste Mal in einer Premiere. Es ist eine Oper in Frankfurt, die Ballett mitbringt. Ganz toll.
Ich werde es mir ansehen. Wir wollen noch unsere Termine ganz kurz nennen für die Live-Salons im neuen Jahr. Sagen an dieser Stelle auch schon mal vielen Dank. Wir werden uns ja dann wieder hören im Live-Salon. Außerdem nochmal hier der Hinweis, wer den Salon verschenken will, kann das tun. Man kann für ein Jahr den Salon verschenken, wenn man zu steady geht. Vielleicht gibt es jetzt da Leute, die sagen, unbedingt sollte der Onkel das mal hören, was die zu Branko Milanović erzählen. Oder zu F. A.
G.
Schentkirsch, ja.
Unsere Termine lauten nächstes Jahr Freitag, der 20. März, Freitag, der 19. Juni, Freitag, der 18. September, Freitag, der 18. Dezember. Es sind also immer Freitagstermine. Man kann die Wochenende in Frankfurt verbringen. Jeweils 20 Uhr. Es gibt keine Tickets mehr per E-Mail, sondern ihr findet in den Show Notes einen direkten Ticket-Link zu jeder Veranstaltung.
Wunderbar. Bis dahin.
Bis dahin.